the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess
club the a-listers of American chess are
back at the US Women's and US Open
championships in St Louis the red
carpet's been rolled out and the stars
are ready to strut their stuff recent
chess 9lx champ Sam sebian is hoping for
a sequel performance that will keep his
name in lik and the young star is on his
way after a convincing win two-time
champ turned commentator Nazi pit hit
all her marks in her return to the board
winning her game to claim clear first
the cast is set and the plot is in
motion day two of Championship chess
coming up
[Music]
[Applause]
next
[Music]
welcome back chess fans to day two of
the US chess championships and US
Women's chess Championships held here at
the St Louis chess club we start the day
in front of the club as we are waiting
for the players to arrive it's been a
fantastic start to this event and
there's still a lot of fighting Spirit
left let's go to the studio and start
the
action welcome to St Louis to home of
Chess in America as the St Louis chess
club proudly presents the US and US
Women's chess championships there are
two clear leaders as round two begins
right
now hello and welcome everyone thank you
for joining us I'm karinaa and I am here
with yaser San Kate it's just so much
fun and we started with a bang and these
new Studios I'm feeling great energy
amazing games yesterday truly truly
hello everyone and Welcome to our show
yesterday was starting with a bang but
strangely enough even though the chess
was incredibly combative we only had two
winners one in each group Kate do the
honors and tell our viewers who they are
who they were yeah they are let's take a
look at the standings in the Women's
Championship we have Nazi PID who is the
leader who is the only person in the
women's section who won a game yesterday
against ashita esan all other players
made a draw we're going to see something
very similar in the open standings as
well exactly here we have Sam savian who
is the sole leader of the open section
who won Incredible game against Ray
Robson all other players made a draw and
tell us about the format for these two
national championships the format is two
12 player round Robins which mean which
means that each player plays everybody
else in their respective section the
time format is 90 minutes for first 40
moves followed by 30 minutes for rest of
the game and there is a 30 second
increment from move one no draw offers
allowed whatsoever and the traditional
scoring system 1.4 win helpful point for
a draw and zero points for loss no draw
offers makes for competitive chess
indeed and tell us about the schedule
the schedule is very simple we have one
round a day and we always start the
coverage at 1:20 p.m. Center time after
round four players and all of us have a
rest day after round 8 again second rest
day and then we play and if necessary
there will be playoffs on October 18th
wow kind of looking forward to the
playoffs already very nice and as always
we're we're honored by Christian you're
being in student and I just love the
fact you're right here energy it's a
different energy and the players have
brought the energy yesterday as well we
had a lack of decisive Gams but I have
to say that's not a testament to the
brand of Chess that these players
brought to the table these Champions
brought to the table and speaking of
Champions let's take a look at some of
the past and the present champions in
both sections as well we're going to be
mentioning a few notable names and we're
going to start with the ladies section
take a look at that Gilla can gresser
nine time Champion over the span of
three decades that's just an incredible
feature that this lady has brought to
the chess tables the next lady is of
course one that we in fact have in this
year's championship that is Arena Crush
Grandmaster Arena Crush eight time
Champion starting in 1998 and finishing
in 2020 and so much emotion in that 2020
Championship if you remember she was so
happy happy to win her eighth title and
of course we have another player that's
featured in this list that is Anna
zatonski in this year's championship as
well she's a four time Champion starting
in 2006 and finishing in 2011 just an
incredible player and she represented
the United States at so many Olympiad
successfully I might add the next one on
the list is one that we also have in
this year's championship that is Nazi
PID she's often here in the studio with
us as a commentator she's a two-time
national champion in 2016 and 2018 just
an incredible young lady and she's one
of the leaders as we are entering day
two the next one is the defending
champion of course I'm talking about
Jennifer Yu she's a two-time champion
2019 and 2022 and what an incredible tie
breaks she had last year against the
eight time National Champion Arena Crush
she was lost in that game but managed to
Swindle her oppon oent turn it all
around and win the national championship
the next one is another Jennifer
Jennifer shahad she's an incredible
player she has won it two times in 2002
and 2004 and she was also one of our
colleagues here in the studio as well
and in the open section let's take a
look at what we have there but also
let's not forget about
Sab our social media exactly social
media manager here at the St Louis chess
club she's a one-time champion in 2017
and what a story uh that was she was not
one of the favorites she was one of the
underdogs but she managed with an
impeccable performance to win that
championship and let's take a look at
the open section what do we have in the
open you might recognize some of these
names of course we're going to be
starting with Bobby Fisher a Time
National Champion a decade of dominance
starting in 1957 ending in
1966 everybody knows who Bobby fiser is
the next one on the list is one that
we're missing greatly in this year's
championship that is hikaro Nakamura
five-time Champion he had previous
commitments and unfortunately was not
able to play in this year's
championships hopefully we will be
having him back just an incredible
player the next one is uh well you might
know this
guy sah W four time National Champion
starting in 1981 and you also won it in
the 2000s congratulations Yer incredible
CV there the next one is a player that
it is in this year's championship
present Wesley so three-time National
Champion
2017 2020 and 2021 he hasn't had the
best years so far but definitely he can
turn it around with a victory in this
championship of course we could be
talking about an illustrous list without
the defending Champion that is Fabiano
Carana two time National Champion he had
to wait six years in between these
championships he hope he hopes that he's
not going to have to wait another six he
will be trying to defend his uh National
Title in this year's championship the
next one is Sam Shanklin we had him on
the show he was not very happy with his
performance but still plenty of games to
be played just an incredible win in 2018
he was head-to-head going into the last
few rounds with Fabiano Carana he just
simply scored more points than his
opponent Fabiano caruana with plus six
he won that event just an incredible
score and of course we had this man on
our show as well he's the newly inducted
into into the US Hall of Fame Yuri
Schulman he won it in 2008 he is a
one-time Champion a lot of Champions
around St Louis around the US
Championship you were having fun with it
I mean if we had to list all the
Champions going back to the 1800s we got
a list of three pages we missed a few
you had some fun with it I really like
that thank you Christian absolutely and
even though uh we don't know uh the
champions of today who is going to win
these national championships tell us
about the pairings for these round two
Kate yeah let's take a look for the
women's section we have eswaran playing
against toir Jova abrahamian playing CLE
very big match right there big match
here Yip against you the two US Women's
Champions uh cantes playing Crush
bashian playing sien and the only leader
in the women's section pza playing
zatonski absolutely and in the open
section pairings for that section let's
take a look we have Karana playing his
Olympic teammate Dominguez Scher playing
against saw the leader in the open
section savian playing niman something
about that right
I like it I like it Kate go on please
and we have Shanklin playing Robson
Mishra playing tank and aonan playing
Jong and let's just go to the World
Chess Hall of Fame and see uh the
players as they get ready to do battle
this round they started wow I mean that
was a snap that was quick wow didn't
expect that uh and by the way every time
I see these photos I can't help but just
say gorgeous gorgeous chest tables the
pad that
LE craft it so well exactly exactly get
Goods here in the studio with us just uh
beautiful Chessa absolutely uh in fact I
was so jealous at the Players I Kate I
mean when whenever you get the feeling
you want to throw some moves my
direction I'm ready for you all right
all right as we see in this game of tatv
that it's a a Russian defense with his
night three players Christian who play 1
E4 have are having a terrible time
they've got to face the Berlin they've
got to face the pet but you have to deal
with a lot of unpleasantries if you play
one D4 as well you have the Namo which
is extremely solid and you have a lot of
other ideas as well the Queen's Gambit
decline the Queen's Gambit accepted so
many problems with both E4 and D4 but
you know these players have a lot of
weap s at their disposals they have a
lot of seconds behind them as well
always looking for ideas in their spare
time so yeah I don't pity them too much
right we do have just a little bit of a
problem in terms of getting my board
updated I I think we should definitely
see what's happening in the Fabiano
versus Lenard game I wanted to do the
Nazi an because I just always like uh
the leaders to start with the leaders
respect and honor their achievement of
leading the tournament it's also very
interesting to be looking at Players
when they are in the opening kind of
part of the game they're not really
looking at the board just like figuring
out which line they want to you know
play just figing figuring what was in
their folder to play in that like
they're not really focused on
calculating exactly recalling their
files but I'm just looking at the life
shot there and I see in Fabiano's game
it's the bishop C4 Joko piano uh the
quiet game if you will the Italian game
but nowadays the quiet game is not so
quiet I think there's so much theory
that goes into each and every line it's
a completely different opening than it
used to be 20 10 even years ago and
Coach break that down for us when you
sit there no no no no when you sit there
and you say okay we've got to do this
training and we're going to learn I
don't care an opening system it doesn't
matter a French defense I mean you know
what are the challenges that that that
you have to go through I mean thousands
of games yes books well the thing is
there's so many options right there's so
many options uh nowadays you have to you
have to be very versatile in your
approach you have to be able to play
different type of structures different
type of openings uh on a on a de you
know you okay tomorrow we're playing
this okay let's learn it in the next
five hours wow tomorrow you're playing
this variation okay let's learn it in
the next 5 hours you create a file with
the help of the engine with the help of
your friends and then you try to work
that out and try to memorize but in your
spare time outside of competition you
have to accustom yourself to all of
these different type of variations
different type of structures middle
games things of that nature so you have
to be a very comp complete player
nowadays yeah and this versatility be
able to play either one E4 or one D4
Kate when I was a professional one of
the things I did is I cheated I wanted
to have a guide I wanted a guide
somebody who was a professional in their
openings and I would choose them and I
would say okay uh if I'm GNA play The
nidorf Well Gary Kasparov he gets this
challenge how does he handle this this
question when somebody plays the night
or and plays this move against him so I
picked God and I said okay that's going
to be uh the person I followed did you
do the same thing do you did you cheat
and have a guide I wouldn't call that
cheating I did but I did have I think
the whole you know list of the books
play like an an after one E4 right I
think it was like 12 books and I was
really going through them a lot I don't
know why I picked an maybe because there
was just these books maybe it was the B
yes but sometimes you like a certain
opening right then you pick the player
accordingly so it changes time to time
lovely well let's get back into the
games quickly and Christian uh that
started you wanted to start us with
Fabby it's on you absolutely I'm just
trying to kind of understand all the
different scenarios that could be
playing out and this is what I'm
spotting in this one A5 followed by the
next move as you will see Castle is
obviously the main move in the position
a lot of games have been played with
that one H6 is another big move in this
position the idea behind H6 is that if
you do go Castle Bishop to G5 comes and
this is a very aggressive approach from
White and if you don't know exactly what
you're doing you might end up in trouble
as black because you have to start doing
H6 followed by even G5 at times G5 in
this position things of that nature and
whenever you're weakening your king side
like this this becomes extremely
dangerous so players are trying to avoid
this with the move H6 but we're seeing a
completely different approach from
with this move Bishop to A7 getting out
of Dodge getting that Bishop out of
Dodge of this attack with the move d4
right from White and right now
immediately responded by Fabiano by the
way Knight to A3 Knight to D2 are very
typical ways of dealing with this
position A3 has also been played quite a
few times Bishop to B3 the game's
continuation has only been played three
times who which is quite interesting to
see and right now this has stopped
linear for second he thought for a while
and he played the move Castle now I'm
very curious to see whether Bishop to G5
is going to come on the board that's an
option maybe H3 H3 was played twice
Knight bd2 these are all the usual
continuations that will most likely
transpose into some of the main lines
that we see so often but Bishop to G5
this one is an interesting one an
interesting moment I'm curious to see
because for sure Fabiano expected this
move Castle I'm curious to see what he's
going to bring to the table in the next
couple cou of minutes let's perhaps take
a look and see what his reaction is
right now all right well thank you for
that Christian and I just uh bringing up
a a game of our tournament leader in the
open section that's Sam Sean and he's
playing against H Neeman I dubbed him
the bad boy of American chess but
there's something there's a rivalry
Brewing between they're similar in the
ages I think Sam has an edge uh more
experience than h but what Hans did
yesterday what Sam did yesterday
the really really uh enthralling game
they're definitely very young players
who are there for the blood who want to
fight exactly we have a Catalan Bishop
G2 and Hans is thinking uh does he want
to play with the closed calan uh Bishop
E7 castles maybe B7 B6 as well as C7 C6
does he want to play D5 take C4 and open
Catalan and so they're very very early
uh days here Kate where would you like
to take us so maybe let's take take a
look at all the other games uh in the
open section so we can start with well
we did we we just saw the Fabby game
Wesley so uh versus darish um well I as
mentioned the Berlin defense if you play
one E4 you got to expect you're going to
run into the Berlin defense and uh well
Wesley said I like to play the Berlin
Wall let's see what you've got
uh planned and okay again this is a I
want to say uh slow treatment or just
you know white isn't trying to get a a
massive advantage or something like that
from the opening he's trying to get a
playable position with certain pluses in
and no risks whatsoever right very
peaceful game but uh the whole idea is
that you're kind of playing against the
Knight like for example Knight D2 here
throwing uh bringing up Knight E4 you
want to put your Bishop back on D3 and
the idea is that maybe this Knight on F5
really should be on F6 and maybe this
bishop that's on F6 should really be on
D6 so it's just a little bit awkward for
the moment but when when Black manages
to start trading more pieces pretty
balanced uh lots and lots of draws in in
these games Sam Shanklin versus Ray
Robson big fight between Olympic
teammates here as uh Ray yesterday boy
was he distraught Christian I mean he
knew he had a winning position against
uh Sam and just let it go but he didn't
know up until our interview with him
really actually you're talking about Ray
Robson I thought you were talking about
Sam shankland no because that was
another case I mean what a difficult
situation for Sam shankland as well but
Ray yes he knew that he was winning
because you can feel it when you play
those type of positions you can feel
that the checkmate is right there the
King on E8 completely exposed you only
have to find that move Queen to C2 Queen
to G6 the attack you have to defend read
Rook to H6 and after that open the
position with C4 he knew that he's
conducted so many similar attacks in his
career right and unfortunately for him
he almost never lets his opponents go in
those type of positions and this is a
big big accent I have to say remarkable
just hearing what you were talking that
game seared into your mind imagine how
it seared into
yes tell us what's uh going I'll tell
you what's going on in this one because
as you mentioned you want to give the
flowers to our leaders as well so let's
talk about this game between Nazi pza
and Anna zansi we have an interesting
Catalan but take a look at this next
move Castle we usually see castle and
then D takes C4 is one of the main lines
but Nazi essays this move Queen to C2 I
sort of like it's a rare bird right
because of this specific move C5 and
after Castle in fact the engine is
saying that black is even slightly
better but I guarantee you that's not
necessarily the case right we're going
to see a very imbalanced game in case
she takes on D4 and if you don't take on
D4 I'm going to be able to go Rook to D1
and enter the type of position that I
want to say will probably uh give the
advantage to white but take a look at
this almost forc line C takes D4 now you
probably have to take back and E5 right
this is the critical response against
this move move Queen to C2 and then I'm
sure Nazi has prepared with her coach by
herself we know that she's kind of a
lone wolf and when it comes to
preparation she told us that during the
interviews Knight to F5 D4 but you are
giving up the two Bishops as black and
this is something that is not easily
done right from a practical perspective
and take a look at this next move which
is the main line in the position you
cannot touch that pawn do not touch that
pawn because after taking Bishop to A3
you're going to lose the
this is game over so don't do that after
the move B4 you have to stop White's
Avalanche of Pawns on the queen side
with a move such as A6 follow it up with
Knight to C6 it's a battle between my
Pawns in the center controlling your
position quite nicely you cannot um
develop your pieces nicely you cannot go
to Knight C3 Bishop to B2 is going to be
B by this Pawn wall in the center but at
the same time look at this beautiful
Bishop
on G2 is going to create a lot of havoc
in Black's position I have to say this
is very very uh a very interesting
option but Anna already thinking and
thinking for quite some time she has 1
hour and 21 minutes against 1 hour and
33 minutes Nazi definitely knowing what
she's doing in this position this one is
going to be a very interesting encounter
I have to say well with Anna we know
that she loves her time trouble
mismanagement can't can't cure it's a
good strategy right if you are Nazi it's
a good strategy to ask her questions
early on yes and she took on D4 by the
way okay so we're going maybe towards
that variation right now wonderful uh
just wanted to bring up the game of uh
Sam Shanklin and Ray Robson as we go
around uh the tournament Hall uh in the
open section C4 E5 English G2 G3 Michael
Marin wrote a fantastic book on the
English where he prescribed specific
speically this approach of G3 and he
really explained why this early
fianchetto should be chosen Knight
F3 E4 Knight D4 D5 be has suddenly
become really the most topical variation
it's just remarkable how you know
fashion comes in and out now in my day
everybody played C takes D5 Queen takes
D5 and here was a key moment number
players like to play Knight C2 that
looks like a very natural move yeah so
that you could play Knight C3 and then
this Knight on C2 strangely enough often
popped out to the square E3 where it was
actually pretty darn good then other
players like to play the move E2 E3
maintaining the knight in the center and
playing for Knight C3 in a quick double
F and Shadow if you will uh already we
had
a well for me the main line is Queen
takes D5 queen queen B6 a bit of a
sideline variation I don't know if uh Ry
will appreciate me suggesting that Queen
B6 is a side variation and then this
move is a big surprise for me Queen A4
and suddenly I am not on Terra FMA
anymore um this is like the latest and
greatest in uh opening Theory sorry no
I'm wondering if Sam is just saying you
know it's move six maybe I'm winning a
pawn because you can recapture the pawn
on D5 there is a pin right no way so I
mean the the way I would approach it
what's the difference between between
Queen takes D5 and queen B6 well
obviously when I play Queen takes D5 I'm
recapturing the pawn immediately when I
put the queen on B6 I'm
trying I believe uh to follow up with
the move uh Bishop C5 and obviously I
can't recapture the pawn on D5 because
well frankly that would be illegal so
Bishop C5 if white wants should he take
on on C6 but I'm a little bit surprised
that Ray doesn't make this move
automatically right Knight takes C6 well
Queen to A4 is a novelty is a novelty
que to A4 is a novelty and in fact this
move Queen to B6 guess who is on the
black side of uh the most topical game
in this line after Queen to B6 Ray
Robson against Don chenko only a year
back so definitely Sam has been
preparing this line at home and he play
uh this novel move Queen to A4 Bishop to
C5 by the way is a mistake is a mistake
wow Bishop to C5 the most natural move
in it sure is by far is a mistake after
d takes C6 now the computer is already
saying plus one Knight takes C6 Knight
takes C6 Knight takes takes this is
where it was going Bishop takes and now
I would assume you're going take with
the B Pawn you want to keep the Queens
on the board yes if you exchange the
Queens then E3 your Bishop gets stuck
yeah I don't want to do that you're in
deep deep trouble after that so you want
to take with a B Pawn but now I just
simply go Knight to C3 you still have to
contend with this E4 Pawn I'm not going
to take it with a queen because that's
going to give you a lot
ofation knight7 Bishop F5 you have a lot
of ideas but Knight to C3 is the main
move in the position but the king is
stuck in the center it is it is it is
but I have a feeling your king might get
stuck in the center as well so what if I
go Knight F6 and just want to Castle
very quickly I'm with you on this one
now he takes you cannot Castle right
yeah Knight takes F6 is not fun no so
you want to take take and perhaps Bishop
to E6 but now I can snatch another Pawn
with Ave Bishop to H3 right wow are you
going to if you're not aware of these
variations of course if you haven't
analyzed this at home are you willing to
give up two pawns and hope that you have
enough compensation no I would want to I
would want to prepare this yeah I'm not
so sure about that and by the way this
seems to be a good Avenue for black
because after King to h8 it does seem
like he has enough compensation but
without the knowledge that the engines
give you are you actually going okay so
you're saying to me the natural move of
Bishop C5 is wrong what's the correct
approach I would say Bishop to D7 or
Knight to F6 just the simple Knight to
F6 it's all about finishing your
development in at the position as black
that's how you're going to try to uh
reach your compensation so if we if we
ask the question I take the pawn yes and
now I take back I take the Knight and
now I don't take back I go Bishop to D7
so you see I'm trying to develop my
pieces with Tempe and ruin your
structure as well this is not easy stuff
right this is really not easy stuff this
is not natural play for uh black so Ray
Robson right now the pressure is on him
and Sam Shanklin once again shows his
Poise in the opening phase the game
thank you Christian and uh two of our
youngest competitors in the field
certainly Mishra I'm On Solid Ground by
the way y I just see that Ray made a
move and he did Play Bishop D7 that is a
good move as well yes against Queen A4
Bishop to D7 and we're expecting Sam to
Blitz out some move
because that's given by the engines as
one of the top moves and I think Sam is
ready for that right Bishop to D7 and he
took on C6 immediately right I think we
have the ABI Manu versus Andrew on the
main board but now we we're back to it
yes yes but now I'll bring up uh Misha
and Andrew as uh we have I called this
uh Bishop C4 variation well of of course
it's the two knights but Bishop C5 were
transposed into a Joko piano but uh when
I was studying it this was known as the
Hungarian variation Bishop E7 and the
funny part about the Hungarian variation
was at the time it was considered a very
solid but passive line now the funny
part is I've seen PE I've seen players
uh nepo for example playing the move
Bishop C5 and then bringing once white
plays the move Bishop G5 bringing the
bishop right back to E7 so the Hungarian
uh variation was ahead of its time
Bishop E7 uh Castle D7 D6 A4 castles
Rook E1 King h8 now that's borrowing a
page right out of leavon erodian opening
chess book because leavon loves to play
these moves King h8 Knight G8 and F5
let's see how the game unfolded from
here Knight F3 Bishop G4 H3 Bishop H5 oo
should we ask the question Kate would
you like to play G4 I was just wondering
what is the question yes I mean are you
going to sacrifice the Knight that's the
question are you going to play Knight
takes
G4 I would need to think
but let's have a look see let look so
it's not our game so we can risk our
pieces well the good part about being a
a chess commentator is when we make a
mistake doesn't cost us any rating
points when they make a mistake it costs
them uh plenty
yes Bishop takes G4 would you rather
play white or black black is if it's
black to move F5 you might be we
together might great great uh trouble
what do you think yeah so we can would
you play a move like for example Rook E3
with the idea of breaking the pin are
you afraid of Knight D4 and F5 I'm
definitely afraid I'm just wondering if
to start with King G2 or okay let's take
a look see on that one too King G2 we
might have to uh consider the the um how
are we going how are we going to deal
with a move like F7 F5 uh breaking open
the file for a rook uh you can see why
white
might not want to play the move G4 why
white might want to play Bishop E3 as a
preliminary move and and get in G4 is it
a threat could uh could uh uh um Mishra
play the move G4 by the way uh Christian
after which move in Bishop Bishop C
instead of Bishop to E3 yeah pardon me
yeah instead of G4 has been played a few
times yes has been played a few times uh
actually by my student maybe I should
have known that but this is 2010 Oparin
versus kusov um he was definitely not my
student
time but actually in fact Knight hg4
seems to be just uh much better for
black so w perhaps this doesn't work
because the king is already on h8 right
so I'm very close to opening up the f
file I'm one move away from opening up
the f file and that's a problem because
you need a couple of moves to go King to
H2 Rook to G1 Rook G3 right if you could
get that those moves in you would be
perfectly fine the problem is after the
move King to H2 F5 Rook to G1 I'm just
simply going to go Queen to E8 this is
the key move in position threatening a
check on H5 in fact threatening check
mate after Queen H5 followed by Queen to
H3 so this one is not looking very good
he uh was not able to play the move G4
I'm sure he knew about it as well that's
why he played the move Bishop to E3
quite quickly take a look at what's
happening in the other ones as well by
the way we're seeing some Italians today
some today catalans and catalans as
well and take a look at what's happening
in this one after to move H3 I think
this is where we left it off H6 was
played we were discussing about the
threat of playing Bishop to G5 and
complicating matters with this pin after
H6 Knight bd2 B5 which is a novelty the
best move by the engine but a novelty
Dominguez is one of the leading experts
I would say in the Joo piano with both
white and black and also Fabiano as well
um take a look at this B5 A4 four B4 of
course you're not going to take on A4
because after Bishop takes A4 your
structure is just simply going to be
damaged for a long time yes yeah why did
you do that it's a strategical mistake
so take a look at this move Bishop to C4
Bishop C4 Bishop B3 back to C4 there's
all this maneuvering going on for both
sides and Bishop to B5 is coming this is
the idea of this move Bishop to C4 I'm
trying to create some problems for the
Knight on C6 and once you move the
knight from C6 then I'm going to follow
it up with D4 and try to put the
pressure the typical pressure in the
center after this move a D4 so I really
like this move Bishop to C4 Fabiano
still within his theoretical knowledge 1
hour and 32 minutes against 1 hour and
15 a lot of pressure I have to say on
lener he probably expected okay I'm
going to make this uh nice little
novelty with B5 I have some ideas that I
analyzed a couple of months ago and he's
not going to know what he's going to do
and we're going to uh I'm going to be
able to equalize no no no no A4
immediately and Bishop to C4 countering
with a strong sequence of moves so I
really like what's happening in this one
for uh question can let there go just
now like Knight E7 Knight G6 oh you can
definitely do that but now I'm going to
go D4 once you move the knight from C6
I'm going D4 and now you go Knight to G6
right mhm now I'm going to take on B4 in
fact wa yes pause pause p suppose
because I see you might want to take on
D4 yes uh that that that's a center pawn
and usually but that's an extra Pawn for
me right uh if you well it's a double C5
Knight B3 you think you can keep the
pawn on a A5 I I think I can yeah so C5
first of all that's going to kill
more Bishop on A7 right but I still have
a kind of a preponderance in the center
and
perach give you that pawn with the move
Bishop to B5 follow it up with Knight to
C4 E5 I'm starting to get some play
right you're you're starting to feel the
energy in White's position right yeah
okay I can I have to say some pressure
early on from Fabby and let's take a
look at what happened in Sam versus Ray
because well big developments take a
look at this uh Bishop to D7 take on C6
take on C6 Knight takes C6 Bishop takes
C6 everything uh was prear Queen to B3
and now H5 the best move in the position
I'm so impressed by by the way Ray
remembers his analysis because I can
guarantee you he hasn't looked at this
line in a very very long time but he
remembers the best moves or he has a
sixth feeling for H5 is the best move
try to get more space okay forget about
the fact that you Pawn down I'm just
trying to get more space now there's a
couple of ways in which you can deal
with it let's say you exchange the
Queens right first sure how are you
going to continue this uh end game you
might be looking at the position and be
like hey I'm just a pawn up I'm a pawn
up let's let's finish our development I
have a better structure let's say Pawn
up Bishop to G2 why not but now I go H4
Knight C3 let's go Knight to C3 yes and
now I go Knight to
F6 I defend everything I'm a little bit
Kate I'm a little bit worried of H3 so
H3 right yeah so maybe I'm not happy but
I Castle you Castle okay if you and
without the Queens H3 you hide the
bishop you Tu the bishop on
I do I do I do and now I go Bishop to C5
and guess what the assessment is in this
position it's in fact more compensation
better for black more than compensation
how about ah now it's l down now it's
zero
yes forget about it it's easier to play
for black it's easier to play for black
it's going to be very difficult to
develop the bishop on C1 right for sure
yes yes so very interesting uh things
are happening in this one what's
happening in the ladies section guys
yeah I'm just going to go right through
uh Mishra and Andrew Tang Because by the
way Bishop E3 not that move G4 because
uh Bishop E3 was played and uh I'm
expecting that Andrew is going to uh
Aspire for the move F5 I I don't know if
he wants to play Knight D7 Knight B6 but
somehow I think this Knight on um F6 is
going to get maneuvered around finally I
have to say I'm a little surprised that
uh Andrew decided to move King h8 and
then play Bishop G4 not com yeah not
following up on that F5 idea yes if
you're going to play King h8 you really
do expect that the Knight will go back
and the pawn will go to F5 right away
yes it's because if you want to play
Bishop G4 you can do that immediately
yeah this seems to be a little bit of a
logic glitch birthday boy yeah happy
birthday Aon and a big shout out and our
congratulations to leavon uh this is
looking like the Wesley so game uh a bit
but it actually is not a Berlin it comes
from uh a uh Petro a Russian defense
where you get four versus four and three
versus three again white is just
actually playing for you know the pieces
being a little
bit not harmonious I would say but again
jeffy's position's very very solid now
let's go to the ladies and oops sorry I
brought up the no I did that right I
just have to do it this way just a
second there it is and uh I've got the
game between uh asria and beum on our
board this is that Berlin again no this
is actually an old ruy Lopez exch
exchange I I pulled this uh rabbit out
of my hat there against anat carpov in a
competition in Monaco and you know I'm
so jealous of the players today uh I had
this marvelous preparation and T you
walk right into it like 20 moves and I
didn't
play I it ended up making a draw I had
to I had a i i i i uh played the wrong
sequence of moves golly and that's why
when uh coach tells me that he preps the
players five hours and they learn a new
system I'm thinking to myself how do
they remember it's so easy to like
switch move order and then everything is
completely different absolutely their
opponent can suddenly respond
differently yeah I suspect that we're in
a very uh well-known theoretical Waters
in this one well maybe to give you an
idea of how they do that how many games
were you playing per year back in oh
very very few I'm thinking 60 to 90 and
90 was the very very very high high side
because those 90 maybe I played in a
world open and a New York open something
like that I played a lot of games in
those there's a huge difference between
the players of today and the players of
the past because nowadays 90 is not so
high nothing actually uh I think Hans
played 90 since April right 90 official
games and you can imagine how many
countless of games he has played online
so you can practice new openings all the
time right this is the big difference
there aware of what they have to do in
different type of setting different type
of structures also think about how many
games you can actually see in today's
times and how many games you can analyze
keep up exactly back in the days you had
a book you were studying that for like
five months right okay I'm going to go
with this book for the next five
tournaments right and I carry it around
with me that's not the case anymore
there's so much more information and
that's why it's so easy for them to
adapt to new information much faster
than uh the play
I still think it's a challenge Kate you
jump in uh uh here on this one don't you
find it hard to to to to to maintain
your discipline and and keep up with all
the openings even the ones you play yeah
keeping up with openings and studying
openings that's really not that's not my
forte that's not what I like to do um I
am also not playing that much anymore
competitively so I'm happy I don't have
to do that I still do tactics I look at
you know Strat
strategy and like cool games but
starting opening is something I don't
miss at all wow it's tough it really
really is everybody's favorite coming
into today's uh uh well in the
competition um Alice Lee uh was my pick
and as she is up against tatev and the
the players are playing again a very
theoretical uh topical pet with this KN
C3 and when I was playing everybody
Knight C3 was not the move at all I mean
it was all about D4 and Knight takes E5
but Knight C3 has really kind of
superseded uh those lines of the past
and queen
A5 well again this is just one of those
positions where you know you've got to
do your prep but what oh sorry you
you've got I looking at the different
one but I can uh quickly glance at this
one as well it is are is there a novelty
in here or is this all uh there's a
novelty a long time ago Bishop to G4
King to B1 we still in some sort of a
theoretical battle Queen to D7 seems to
have been the novelty in the position D5
was played before which by the way is
the best move according to very sensible
you're looking at this4 if you have one
more move you play the move Knight to E4
and you're very happy in the position
and you know white has to deal with that
she has to go something like h three if
now if you take on F3 I control the
square E4 I also have the G file for a
potential attack despite um my structure
which is a bit damaged I would be
playing Bishop H5 and which by the way
Bishop G6 has never been played because
of G4 Bishop to G6 and after Bishop
takes G6 H takes G6 I'm losing a pawn
you're losing a pawn with G5 yes you
don't want to allow no no no no I don't
so D5 has been played you do have to
know all these variations and the
assessments after Bishop takes F3 which
is not easy right it's a completely
different imbalanced position right
that's why she played this move Queen to
D7 but unfortunately for her I have to
say after this H3 Bishop takes F5 Bishop
takes F5 Knight D4 everything is coming
with a Tempo Queen to
A5 where's your attack on the queen side
cuz I know where my attack is I'm going
to go G4 I wanted to play Knight E4 and
Bishop F6 yes but Knight E4 Queen to D
E3 Bishop F6 Now with uh the move G4
implemented uh I have Knight
F5 okay Knight F5 is an idea even though
Knight takes C3 might be a problem so I
have to be careful by the
way that tactic this is beautiful wow
yes we definitely have to see this one
through because now it's a double tack
you attack this Christian a moment ago
you asked me where my attack is
I yes very good very good in case you
missed you got to be you got to this one
very good very good um yes the attack is
dominating right now I mean remarkable
move the rookies hanging as well you
cannot defend both so I'm going to have
to be a little bit careful not Knight to
F5 but Knight to B3 Knight to B3 where
is your queen going actually I assumed
A4 just to be a past right but then
maybe bishop to D4 is one way F3 seems
to be a big problem in fact also okay I
can believe that white is for Choice
here yeah the pawns on the king side are
going to just start running I agree
white is winning right now even winning
plus plus two Advantage wow yes ask me
why but it is a plus two Advantage I wow
okay so and I played natural moves E4 F
Bishop F6 yes yes so it's not that easy
but she needs to find this move and to
be honest I mean what else are you going
to do I mean you have to throw your
pawns we're talking about tat tat
loves but I think F3 could be an option
too right just not allow the Knight to
jump to E4 great move yes great move as
well F3 or G4 F3 is the more controlling
option of course maybe you're giving me
a little bit more time to set up my
defense with Bishop to f8 G6 Bishop G7
something along those lines and also uh
with the E file open once you move the
bishop I'm going to start chopping uh
the Rooks down the E file because I want
to exchange as many pieces as possible I
want to get closer to the end game as
possible because I know an attack is
brewing uh coming from a white side and
TV is a vicious attacker I mean you give
her an attack she's going to Checkmate
you she's ready for it but you had
Carissa and Jennifer that you you had up
on your screen and that looked like a
very very fun caroan it's a caroan and I
have to say I'm surprised by Jennifer's
choice because I know Karissa loves
these structures she loves to play
against the French and she loves to play
against the car I don't know what it is
but she gets very good results in those
two openings and Jennifer essayed the
caran but unfortunately after this move
Bishop to G7 so H6 G5 you're trying to
get more space on the king side F4 but
you also have to know the follow ups and
G takes F4 in this case is not the one
because after Knight to D3 I'm going to
recapture that with the Knight on F3
then that Knight is going to land on H5
and the Bishop G once this Knight lands
on H5 so for example let's make a couple
of moves castle and then Knight to H5
this is not looking good because I'm
going to take that your H6 Pawn is also
going to be extremely weak and there's
no attack over the G file so what she
had to do after the move F4 and we've
seen this I think it was a game from it
wasn't just 9 Alx but it was one of the
tournaments that we've had here between
Ali Resa and laner this type of
situation and Ali Resa just simply gave
up the pawn with the move Queen to C7
you have to do this take take Bishop
takes G5 you cannot really do this
because now I get a lot of counter
chances C5 F6 is an idea as well even on
the Move Knight takes E5 creates a lot
of problems for white so D takes E5 and
Bishop takes C5 and just play it like
this with a pawn down because if you go
H3 then Bishop takes H3 comes and you
have a lot of compensation in position I
really like this for black that looks
cool exactly exactly but have to know it
yes and you have to be aware of these
type of structures I don't recall
Jennifer being a caroan player not 100%
sure but I don't recall seeing her
playing the Caro Khan so I'm a bit
surprised by her opening Choice K uh
first of all uh close up on Carissa yep
19 years young okay wow and already a
former US women very accomplished player
USC a rating
2464 and a 2021 US Women's just champion
and now a Stanford student I wanted to
remind you of happy memories from the
Baku women's Olympiad and that variation
that Karissa and Jennifer are playing
you won nicely with the white pieces you
won nicely with the white pieces in Baku
on the Olympic team against Olga giria
right very important win because we won
the US team against uh the Russian team
yes we did and uh you won I was the
women's team captain and you won Top
agent for the day baby that was great we
had a great time there almost medled as
a team yeah that was off fell off the
stage on that one uh but okay so that
was the Jennifer and Carissa game and
again I'm just going to go around the
horn here so let's see atusa against
ruangan just a second here bringing that
one up this actually looks like a
sveshnikov no I haven't seen a oh it's a
nidorf uh with the English attack Bishop
E3 and E7 E5 okay be
transpose uh lines uh to kind uh with
Knight F3 this was a old favorite of uh
Grandmaster John vanderville from
Holland he like this Knight F3 and he
was going for very very quick Bishop C4
and the whole idea was to control the D5
Square as best as as possible and when
they went Bishop E6 he he enjoyed
playing Knight G5 let's see how the game
actually went H2 H3 stopping the
potential for Knight G4 now you have
your Bishop C4 move okay
castles Knight D5 interesting move so
atusa is not worried about her Pawn on
e4 why not that's a question I would
always ask Bishop
B6 yes so that attacks my queen I don't
don't want to play Queen E8 falling
victim to a fork uh so I have to put my
queen on a very ugly square right in
front of my Bishop uh I can imagine that
this is just uh a positional
compensation you know you can play moves
just for argument sake like Queen E2
Castle long Castle yes yeah and black is
all kind of messed up I mean the
bishop I I wouldn't want to play this
and I'm a pawn Grabber so it it goes to
show probably grab grabbing the pawn uh
on e4 is a mistake look at the time by
the way so ruang yangang spent 20
minutes already now on her move whereas
atusa is playing rather quickly and she
grabbed the pawn the move Knight takes
E4 wow okay well Ru yangang yen is about
to get a gold membership
into Association but uh was that a why
did did she get caught with her hand in
the cookie jar uh Christian night takes
C4 no takes C4 is a great move yes I
think atusa might have not necessarily
missed it but underestimated it now the
question is obviously Bishop B6 Bishop
to B6 right you play Queen to D7 not
Queen E8 because of Knight to C7 that's
a double attack makes no sense but how
do you continue there's no I mean queen
to e okay so this is how you want to
create something but long okay Castle
takes Bishop takes yeah but now maybe
Queen to E8 maybe Knight to B4 okay
let's try to be a bit more aggressive
aggressive Knight to B4 I Bishop B3 you
have to right because if you give me the
light Square Bishop then it's
over and joy that's it right that's a
queen C6 everything comes with tempo
right and Bishop E6 is coming next so
once black develops Bishop E6 we are in
trouble but where is your attack I mean
yeah I need like
G G right yeah no no no I we back yeah
so I mean Bishop B has to be the move
right maybe Knight B6 right maybe you
want to go Knight B6 and take the light
Square Bishop after Rook to
B8 at least play for that play for
dominance on the light squares to do the
now I really don't believe it though I
mean because I'm developing I'm
developing black I'm doing him a favor
Bishop B6 I spent like four moves to
grab a bishop that never develop no
Bishop B6 was played by the way so we're
expecting Queen D7 instantaneously to
come uh from Young Alis Lee but I have
to say I mean no excuse me not Alis Lee
um really good I really thought queen2
long castle and we are very happy
obvious uh attacking uh one more look if
you don't mind Queen two pardon me Queen
D7 queen7 queen2 Queen E2 Knight F6
castle and these are not difficult for
me these are all all great knight takes
D4 Rook takes D4 Rook takes D5 yeah Rook
take pardon me Rook takes D5 hoping for
a quick Queen F5 is very very powerful
right okay G4 right and then Bishop F6
and then we're kind of happy okay so I
go here
back but even here I can I can play this
move in fact really Bishop F Bishop e
and then Queen E4 oh we don't have
Bishop D3 MH not yet Bishop D3 kind of
amazing that the queen stands in the
middle of the board and I can't yes Rook
D1 Rook D1 right makes a lot of sense
but now I have Bishop B6 this is minus
four guys I mean wow I don't want break
your bubble but Bishop check I take the
queen yes they check on H seven right
actually on and I take the queen okay
well we like to make illegal moves but
well first of all I mean uh kudos to
ruang I mean recognizing that the pawn
was grabbable but I have to ask you guys
yes what is the most difficult thing to
deal with when you're playing the Joko
piano for both sides in your
opinion yeah you go first not to have
like a super boring uh position what
okay that's that's interesting okay what
about you yeser uh for me when I'm
playing the Joko piano and for both
sides I think of these trench warfar
we're fighting over four very key
squares right in the center of the board
E5 D5 E4 D4 whether I get to play D4
or whether you break with D5 it's all
about those breaks I find the Joko piano
to be very difficult to understand for
me is the change of structures yeah okay
and let me show you what I mean by that
with this game between Fab and ler take
a look at this so first of all black can
do A6 A5 you have so many options B6
Rook e Bishop E6 Rook E A the natural
way the classical away white can stop
that with A4 white can try with A3
followed by B4 so many ways in which you
can deal and we haven't even mentioned
the center yet right as you did right
structure but take a look at this B5
okay you can play like this as well A4
okay now the structure changes once
again B4 and take a look at this bishop
to C4 Bishop to B6 was the move played
by ler wow take a look at this bishop to
B5 Knight to A7 and another very
atypical change of structure could
potentially arise on the board Knight C4
Knight B5 knight uh Knight a takes B5
Bishop to E6 and now Knight takes B6 C
takes B6 you don't see that no in any
other opening this type of changes of
structures back and forth and you have
to be able to assess them right it's not
easy right this is for me the most
difficult thing lenier seems to have at
least taken Fabiano out of his
preparation with his idea Bishop to B6
and Knight to A7 Fabiano thinking right
now Knight to C4 and we might actually
go into that M Bishop to E6 or Knight
takes B5 first and then we're going to
see that complete change of Pawn
structure very very difficult position
to understand very difficult position to
assess but that's why these players are
the best players in the world and in the
United States of course if you go back
just a few moves uh because you threw me
so so uh off kther go go back a few
moves Christian so just uh even the the
bishop going yeah so in this position
when you talk about the change of
structure and things I was almost
certain you were going to go 97 go ahead
if you don't mind D4 take it take it on
D4 that's another change ofuure take it
on D4 and play D5 and then you were
going to say you know like a completely
new structure and then when you did it
on the queen side with Knight takes B6
and Knight I'm not even aware the
material is endless right in which way
you want to change the structure I mean
was crazy there's just too many things
that you need to be able to assess in my
estimation at least but you know these
players are embracing it are like okay
bring it
what you got and we have one last game
that we haven't looked at yet and that
is telia Tella cantes The Local Hero
from St Louis yay go tell you she's up
against Arena Crush what do we have here
it looks like a Queen's Gambit no it's
actually I was about to say Queen's
Gambit accepted it looks like a Queen's
Gambit accepted position but it came out
of a Morano variation A7 A6 and it's
absolutely crazy uh Kate I can tell you
that without putting too fine a point on
it this position we literally studied
for years and you know you won't believe
what we were studying we were studying
whether or not black should play A6 as
was played in the game or go B4 B4 with
the idea then following it up with
immediate C5 and important games in the
world championship match absolutely
absolutely uh many many many uh big
games uh A6 Queen E2 uh I don't think
that that was considered the most
theoretically combative I think
everybody looked at E4 C5 D5 back in the
day and this was the this was I think
there's Queen B8 right after heavy
theoretical battles here uh Queen E2 uh
C5 takes Bishop takes and I was going to
say we've kind of reached a point where
black you know you just stop and say to
yourself one of my goals in the opening
well I want my fair share of the center
I want effective uh peace development I
want a safe King and I think that for
both sides they would kind of Pat
themselves on their back and say okay
now may the best player win because uh
both sides have accomplished their goals
they've got a fair share of the center
maybe black would be happier to have the
Knight on D7 on C6 instead to Target
well then D well who knew the on F3 was
disappearing too right the Knight on
F3 yes it is and uh jump there and you
know for example let me just put a move
well it is black to no it is white to
move I apologize uh Knight F5 Rook E8
often times you see black you know
you've got a very powerful knight on F5
tickling the G7 pawn and often times the
bishop just goes back to f8 and says
okay you got your knight to F5 but then
go ahead and do your work
uh who else is backing up your play over
there and black is happy that uh she
doesn't have to worry about Bishop G5
because the Knight on D7 is guarding the
Knight on F6 exactly exactly so uh
balance there I'm going to go to n's
game with Anna before tossing it back to
Christian because I was more than
curious uh this was this early Queen C2
Catalan a little bit off the beaten path
takes takes and then Christian was
saying this move E5 Knight F5 was a big
thecal uh fight there that was not
played Anna chose Queen B6 Rook D1
Bishop C5
E3 Knight A6 Knight C3 and we're caught
up with the players but what is
threatening yeah Knight A4 my first
thought was that uh Nasi has actually
gotten something nice here this Catalan
Bishop Bishop is looking good of course
the moment I get to play A3 and B4 and
Bishop B2 I'm looking really good um but
are you sacrificing a pawn here if I
what if I take that pawn on C4 I will
immediately play to recapture the pawn
with Knight A4 and I go Queen somewhere
A5 A5 can I can I recapture or not
that's my question uh Bishop D2
you would probably play Bishop B4 right
yeah yeah because then I'm happy to
exchange Bishops Fair now in this case
Queen takes C4 I do have knight uh
Knight B3 and Bishop B Bishop D2 on my
agenda I feel whenever I've got this
open Catalan Bishop I feel black has to
have something immediate like you you
got to be really really quick otherwise
you're going to get in into a trouble
here yeah and the bishop on C8 it's
going to take some time I would like to
play E5 Bishop E6 but I just don't have
the time for it you're right Bishop E6
Bishop G5 in this particular case I am
tickling the I am threatening the Knight
B3 um I'm not sure I like what Anna has
done in this game uh Christian or maybe
I'm wrong you are wrong but you're also
right at the same time it's all about
the bishop on G2 it's all about the
bishop on G2 right if you manage to keep
it open as white you have a great
position and this is specifically why
black needs to play the move E5 not not
obvious at all this is very difficult
stuff don't go Knight to F5 because
after Knight to B4 your queen has to
drop back to B1 in order not to lose
Knight on F5 this is not looking good
right after this queen B1 I just simply
take the pawn land the Knight on D3
that's not good news for you so what you
have to do after the move E5 Knight to
A4 seems very natural first of all right
it's a tempo but the problem is after
Queen to A5 how do you
continue I guess I take if you do take
on C5 then I'm just simply going to be a
pawn up after Queen takes C5 is it so
simple yeah knight3 I think it is I
think it is and now I just simply take
on C4 I can even go Queen to C7 and
maintain the pin and try to take back on
C4 with the pawn this is even uh not as
easy for white for example if you go C5
now I can go Knight to not my first
choice yeah this is not easy stuff right
but if you don't go C what do you do cuz
well I was thinking if you went Queen
takes C4 I would trade and go Knight A4
Knight Knight A5 I beg you pardon and
you can do that again the bishop on G2
yeah this is what you were saying uh
just quickly get the
bishop let's go let's go it's all about
the 10 piece yeah if you put a rook on
E1 I go Knight B4 Knight C2 really quick
so you have to be uh ready for that I am
a pawn up and once you take on B7 I will
be able to use the opening of the B file
to put enough pressure on you Knight to
C5 is going to come a lot of pressure on
the B file after Rook to B8 not looking
good not feeling good right for white
you don't have enough but E5 is key so
this is the key moment then Anna has to
play E5 and if you go Knight F3 now I go
E4 and now we get back to this idea of
Clos now you got Bishop G Contin
psychologically it's so difficult to
keep allowing the Knight A4 move to be
honest because you it's still in back of
your head like it can be a problem you
have to accept it yes that's the thing
you have to accept this idea of allowing
white to potentially get your dark
Square bishop and fight against the two
Bishops but again it's all about
priorities and the priority as you
nicely pointed out is to close the
bishop on G2 if you manage to do that
you'll find even better as white but I
have to say I'm looking at the time
expenditure as well right 1 hour and 20
minutes for Nazi 53 minutes for anasty
we know that Anna has some problems with
her time management always has always
from from the start of her career on the
other hand you know the problem the the
thing about this specific position is if
you're sitting in Black's seat the hot
seat and you're looking at Knight A4 and
you're looking at C takes D5 as issues
that you've got to you're almost obliged
to play E5 because everything else is
going to be not so you might be tempted
by taking but once again I mean this
bishop being open like this after Knight
to A4 yeah looks good it's not easy so
what about Bishop D7 just at the
beginning just not allow or like protect
against but you lose a pawn right can we
take twice on D5 well I have Knight B4
and then I can recapture yeah that at
least you get the two Bishops compens
continue with a move Knight to I take
Bishop takes and then Queen takes I got
rid of that kind of bad Bishop on C8 I
keep my knce on C5 you did you did but
the Knight on A6 the bishop on C5 still
the bishop you still have to take at
some point right can I play Rook C8 Rook
a C8 yeah of course Rook a C8 I take on
D5 Knight
takes but now maybe I can even take on
D5 right Knight B3 KN B3 is a very good
move yes yeah Knight B3 and you're just
uh again this bishop on G2 looks good
and yeah this is more comfy let's just
say for white for the moment I'm looking
at this position and I'm putting myself
in Anna's shoes and I'm seeing maybe in
my uh in my vision this potential Avenue
and I'm thinking okay maybe it's not
that bad yeah well I mean con structure
is symmet C to D7 takes A4 right if you
take on D5 at least you're giving up the
light Square bishop and I'm surely going
to have enough compensation I can maybe
redirect my Bishop to F6 I'm thinking
about it and I'm saying okay it's not
that bad but in fact the assessment is
plus one for a big that's a big not easy
to understand that right right very
interesting position for sure absolutely
yes uh we get uh ready for our first
break uh
where where do we see the decisive game
I mean ruang has won a pawn but uh what
from all of the games that the positions
that we've seen thus far what has struck
you as a game we we could expect a
decisive I think K say against Jennifer
you right Christian was saying how much
he enjoys that position oh but the
Knight didn't get to H5 because in this
position when Karissa played the move
Knight D3 Jennifer spotted the awkward
uh position she would arrive at if the
Knight landed on H5 Knight F4 Knight H5
was the uh maneuver prescribed by
Christian so she played Knight G6 and
took it and we have a kind of a well a
French defense although we know it's a
caroan because the bishop is outside the
pawn structure and well we see Jennifer
is ready to go castles and F6 and Rook
G8 and take control of that g file and
again uh because of your great
experience winning uh as white what's
your take on the position uh
Kate so do you like white or do you I
see very clear plan for black and I feel
like always yeah Castle F6 Rook G8 G8
and those three moves more or less play
themselves yeah right okay so white has
to figure out how to Counterattack or
prepare against this uh maybe attack to
just make some defense because I I
remember in my game I went A4 A5 or
actually I think I went A4 my opponent
play A5 right but if I go A4 here A5 I
don't know how much I can accomplish
well exactly so the idea is you're kind
of embracing white Black's King you you
see that as soon as Jenifer puts her
King under uh the pressure there but A4
A5 yeah you were about to ask an answer
yourself yeah whenever white go yeah if
I go A6 black just plays B6 and just
says thank you now I'm covering all the
squares there one thought that I have is
the half open f file is that a source uh
that you might for example uh consider
like maybe it's not your first idea
which is to trade off these light Square
Bishops with the move Bishop D3 but you
know maybe on a good day you could uh
uh test the uh weakness on the yeah
because maybe white has to kind of
realize that there's not much future on
the queen side so maybe I can uh
reshuffle my pieces on the king side and
double Rooks on F5 something like Rook
F3 Rook F1 and Rook over it's that time
of our show that uh we like to check in
with our good friends at the uh Q
Botique and see very good friends yes
what they are offering today uh it's the
St Louis chess club a travel bag tote
your rollup board and your chess pieces
in style with the official St Louis
chess club logo travel bag the zipper
pouch holds an entire set of pieces
comfortably while your board fits
underneath gold green printed ink on
durable vinyl don't forget the chest
pieces and vinyl roll up board all your
chest needs are available at Q Boutique
louis.com and as we take a break we have
a very very special and very important
message from our board of directors here
at the St Louis chess club and
Scholastic Center have a
[Music]
look
yeah um it's amazing what the club has
done for chess in general because I mean
it's already been 15 years and they've
done countless uh national championships
tournaments for juniors helping around
schools and they've just grown the game
so much across the unit States I think
if I look at my own career and I look at
American chess in general we're in a
much better place than we were 15 years
ago and so the contributions have been
immense and of course it's all thanks to
Dr juny singfield and Rex
singfield I would say that St Lua Club
is like a rock in the ocean of Chess and
we know that it's it's there it is there
it will be there I think it send a hope
that the game of chess will always stay
afloat but mere fact of its existence I
think it it it sends positive waves
across the
globe the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States we bring the educational benefits
of Chess to thousands of students across
the St Louis area we also promote Chess
at the highest levels hosting all levels
of the US championships as well as
high-profile tournaments that attract
the world's best flag ERS become a
member and enjoy perks such as free
classes and lectures weekly tournaments
and so much more visit St Louis chess
club.org to claim your membership
today the World Chess Hall of Fame
located in the heart of St Louis's
historic Central West End want to know
why chess has intrigued people around
the world for nearly 1,500 years stop by
and learn about the impact of Chess from
our three floors showcasing the art
culture and history of the game the
World Chess Hall of Fame has something
for everyone to enjoy for more
information on current exhibits please
visit World Chess hf.org
[Music]
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85,000 students in both in
school and after school programs we
created the select chess training
program and the junior select chess
training program in order to elevate the
skill level in students across the St
Louis area these students receive
professional training from grandmas
veran niobian other programs include
chess cops a partnership with the St
Louis Police Department looking to
improve relationships between atrisk
kids and police officers in the St Louis
area with over 600 students playing
chess over the board since
2019 the St Louis chess club has also
created a chess merit badge for the
scouts BSA quickly becoming one of the
most popular badges with more than
250,000 Scouts earning the badge since
2011 students of chess can also pick up
a copy of read and write chess thanks to
Club co-founder Dr jeie Karen sinkfield
anyone can learn how to understand chess
notation in no time we view chess as a
Val educational tool learn more about
our Scholastic programming by visiting
St Louis chess club.org
[Music]
seducation St Louis the chess capital of
the United States boasts the world class
St Louis chess club and the World Chess
Hall of Fame it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Cuban Boutique you can
shop both in store and online for chess
merchandise autograph Collectibles chess
campus souvenirs and much much more from
quirky greeting cards to luxury chest
sets there is something for everyone at
Q Boutique and all purchases go right to
benefiting new exhibitions and programs
at the World Chess Hall of Fame
dedicated to exploring chess and its
immense impact on art and culture
located on the first floor of the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy a shopping
experience like no other and become
everyone's favorite Gift Giver if you
can shop in store make sure to check out
Q Boutique stl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to
enjoy the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States and is among the best in the
world thanks to co-founders Dr jeie
Karen sinkfield and Rex sinkfield the St
Louis chess club is a nonprofit
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess locally and
internationally we bring the educational
benefits of Chess to thousands of
students across the St Louis area
promoting cognitive development critical
thinking concentration and analytical
skills the St Louis chess club welcomes
chess lovers of any age and skill level
to come and enjoy the game of chess we
also promote Chess at the highest levels
hosting all levels of the US
championships and the American Cup as as
well as high-profile tournaments that
attract the world's best players
including the prestigious sinkfield cup
Ken cup and many more all tournaments
can be streamed via our YouTube and
twitch channels that also include over
2,000 chess lectures for anyone to enjoy
become a member and enjoy perks such as
free classes and lectures weekly
tournaments merchandise discounts and so
much more visit St Louis chess club.org
to claim your member MIP
today the World Chess Hall of Fame
located in the heart of St Louis's
historic Central West End want to know
why chess has intrigued people around
the world for nearly 1,500 years stop by
and learn about the impact of Chess from
our three floors showcasing the art
culture and history of the game
landmarked by the world's largest chest
piece sitting outside our front door the
world World Chess Hall of Fame has
something for everyone to enjoy
including various exhibitions monthly
concerts and much more whether you are a
beginner or a professional there is
something for everyone to learn here at
the World Chess Hall of Fame enjoy free
admission to our rotating exhibitions in
our Galleries and sign up for chess
events familyfriendly programming and
art classes and don't forget to stop by
our award-winning gift shop Q Boutique
and Shop a wide selection of chest
related merchandise for more information
on current exhibits please please visit
worldes h.org
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to our
coverage of the 2023 US championships
we're very pleased to have in studio our
curator from the World Chess Hall of
Fame Emily all right all R sorry thank
you for having me on the broadcast it's
been brilliant and gosh I feel like I've
known you for so many years and the
exhibits over the years they come
flooding to my to to M what was your
favorite um I have a lot of favorites
some of the ones that hold a special
place in my heart are the ones where we
explore the history of chest sets so one
that we had a few years ago was called
ponds and passports and that's where we
show chest sets from our collection that
we're from all around the world but
we've also worked with a lot of really
cool collectors like John crumiller
exact and that's we've done some really
wonderful shows with him too I know I
love those old sets but we're here to
talk about today's exhibit TS Elliot yes
so we have an exhibit right now it's
called TS Elliott a game of chess and it
explores the connections between one of
St Louis's best known writers uh TS
Elliot and um our favorite game chess uh
he included chess as a theme and some of
his uh and some of his poetry and he is
a chess player himself exactly and Emily
can you tell us a little bit more about
Elliot and St Louis and the location of
uh the World Chess Hall of Fame yeah so
Elliot grew up in St Louis um and after
he left St Louis his family moved to a
home that's in St Louis's central
western neighborhood which is where
we're located um the world chest Hall of
Fame wow so it's amazing to actually
have the exhibition there very close to
his uh place yes yeah it's so a really
wonderful connection between our show
and his family um his mother also was
very involved with a social club um
that's located not too far from the
World Chess Hall Fame the link
Auditorium perfect and can you tell us a
little bit more specifically about how
Eliot Incorporated chess into his poetry
yeah so the show is mainly focused on
his poem The Wasteland and um in that
poem there's one section called a game
of chess so there the poem explores all
sorts of themes from um you know
relationships which a game of chess does
um to the Fallout of World War I um and
a game of chess he's talking about the
relationship he had with his wife um
whom he married after not knowing for
very long and quickly had difficulties
in the relationship and so he's using
the game of chess kind of as to talk
about how in relationships she might try
to make a move to have the advantage and
things like that um but we I can't
believe that you know you try to get the
upper hand in a chess game and in a
relationship as well yeah um but we have
some
artifacts um either on view in person
where you can see um uh some of the
books that he included references to in
the poem um there's some there's some
chess poetry that we have in the
collection and we have that on view but
then we also have photos of his own
chest set that people can check out his
chest books and um even a little
notebook that his father put together of
Chess columns he'd cut them out and
paste them in this little uh this little
book so I really I have to say I'm
always so amazed how you all at the hall
of fame know so much about chess players
and about like people related to chess
and chess culture because we like titled
Players let's say we know about Chess
and chess games but specifically about
the players I'm always amazed every time
I'm there I I learn something new me too
Emily thank you so much for joining us
and tell tell everybody where they can
go in the Central West End uh to visit
your exhibits yeah so we're located just
across the street from the chess club
and you can learn more about our
exhibitions if you're not able to make
it to St Louis by going to World Chess
h.org again Emily thank you so much
thank you than you thank you for being
here with us and our pairings for this
uh round two uh do the honors please
Kate how about the ladies yeah so the
women's section esan is playing to
jonova AB hamam is playing Lee Yip is
playing Y cantes is playing crush porian
is playing Yen and the leader of the
women section p is playing zatonski and
in the open section the pairings there
we have Karana playing Dominguez SCH
playing so savian the leader in the open
section playing niman shankland playing
Robson Mishra playing tank and aronian
playing Jong and and Christian got to
ask you where's all the action there's
some action in this one guys ABI Manu
versus Andrew tang and ABI Manu
definitely is trying to get an advantage
out of the opening and potentially a win
in this one because he's playing the
lowest rated player in the event there
is always a Target on your back when
that's the case when you're the lowest
rated player in the event take a look at
this this by the way has already been
played uh in a game between two grand
master Grand Masters I believe from
Poland if I'm not mistaken but G F3
obviously has to be played I'm not
really sure why it hasn't already and
queen to H5 in fact it has been played
King to G2 forced move you have to
defend the two pawns on F3 and H3 if you
don't if you do allow black to get one
of the pawns back that doesn't really
make a lot of sense because uh you know
your Pawn structure is damaged you're
not going to have enough for an
advantage if you are not a pawn up so
King to G2 has to be played it has uh
been played already and now the onus is
on black to prove his compensation how
do you do it because I have a big threat
in the position F4 exactly allow me to
go F4 by losing one Tempe like this and
you're pretty much done and dusted
because after F4 Queen to G4 if we do
exchange the Queens I have the extra
pawn and the compensation I have the two
Bishops I have the extra Pawn I have the
center this is not looking good for you
so what you have to do is stop me from
going F4 with the move Bishop to G5 but
are you actually stopping me is the
question and perhaps this is what Manu
is trying to answer as well in his
calculation and his assessments because
better ending F4 I mean this is going to
lead to a better end ending Queen takes
D1 Rook a D1 Bishop takes F4 now I can
start harassing your um well the
especially the square E8 right and the
return of the Knight to C6 C3 followed
by B4 these are the type of ideas that
I'm looking at and I have to say I'm
looking at the position sure you're
going to exchange uh the Bish point on
E3 but then my Rook is going to swing on
the third rank I have this expansion
potential expansion on the queen on the
king side King to G3 followed by F4 it's
looking really good for white I was
surprised when you said the players were
following a game uh tell us where the
novelty I mean up to this point this is
all standard yes F4 this has Queen takes
D1 Rook a D1 Bishop takes F4 this was
actually the game Bishop takes F4 Rook
takes F4 and E5 was the way they played
E5 D takes C5 the game end it in a drop
but two dozen moves here Kate this is
remarkable so many games being played
every day wow wow wow okay that was a I
must say that was a surprise for me when
you said that the players were the
dictates of the 1 hour and 23 minutes
for ABI Manu 35 minutes for Andrew T So
for Andrew he's the one who's been
playing this very very slowly and after
the move King G to I mean I know what
you were saying about the move Bishop
Bishop G5 but I mean I think for a lot
of players they would be attracted to
the move Rook
G6 Rook F6 with the idea of playing Rook
to G6 again I'm hiding I'm hiding you
give me a check I hide no no sorry Queen
G6 check Queen G6 check okay Queen G6
maybe Queen to G4 or King to H2 what
queen takes E4 am I blundering Bishop D2
your Bishop on E7 your knight B4 as well
uh it's a double hit huh this might be a
problem right yes I mean you do have
some ideas to try to give me some I can
harass that's just one check it's only
one that's it it's it's only one Che it
looks so dangerous Rook H6 just Rook G6
I had to double
check you can go Rook G6 we can Rook H6
Rook H6 give me a me there is Queen G4
and I'm H6 threatening
Checkmate I'm turning the tables on you
exactly yes d yes oh wow oh that was a
nice move Queen G4 and that yeah that
clears the cobwebs yeah no this is wow
okay that's why Bishop G5 and by the way
Bishop G5 F4 was played in the game just
as you've prescribed it yeah wow the
players remarkable they're following
uh following Theory so so very very well
wanted to turn our attention to our
tournament leader in the open section
Sam ion he's up against Hans nean lots
of developments in a very very
theoretically disputed Catalan there was
a player in my time GNA Zano and GNA was
considered the leading expert on the
Catalan so whatever Genna did you know
his acolytes all went and then one day
ganna zanko played the move Bishop D2
and everybody went
what and he lost about half of his
acolytes and then only much much much
later uh did we really appreciate this
move because it looks like such a modest
move you know everybody would understand
if you played Bishop
F4 attacking the pawn bishop G5
potentially just pinning the Knight
Knight C3 Rook all of these moves really
but Bishop
D2 and uh this move by Gana had this
really nice idea and it's actually a
remarkable idea often times in the open
Catalan it's all about the move C7 C5
and what Gana would do would be to play
the move Bishop A5 and B2 B4 and take
command over the C5 square and stop the
move C7 C5 so the fight is for the move
C5 uh Rook A7 I know that this is
theoretically uh advisable as well uh
again again a very very peculiar move
and that's why we all study opening
Theory the idea here in this case is our
Knight on B8 hasn't moved to D7 so
Bishop A5 is going to be met by Knight
C6 many many times this bishop
um the move Knight G5 comes with a gain
of tempo and the bishop on B7 is
undefended the move Rook A7 is as a
two-fold idea the first is to defend the
bishop second the second strangely
enough is sometimes The Rook actually uh
magically appears on D7 and challenges
on the a file all of this is really
theoretically well known and uh here's
another reason a a move right uh putting
more pressure on that diagonal uh
seizing control of the closed a file
what do you think of that is an
annotator you got well I like that we
are seizing control of the diagonal and
then getting ready exactly Rook C8 C5
and trying to break and kind of get rid
of that delayed Pawn exactly and that's
what the fight is all about and what is
the theoretical
uh
evaluation of uh this sharp position it
does seem like we're still in some sort
of theory right now well you're
following a game I can see that it's
right right I'm not sure how accurate
this game is it was played between a 23
and a 2200 so not the Grand Master Level
but still this position has been seen
before Rook A1 was played in that one
the position seems to be very very
balanced and I really like what Hans has
done in the last few moves with this
sequence Rook A7 Knight D7 Queen to A8
it seems like you're getting ready for
uh the best placement of your pieces
obviously the queen on8 and the bishop
B7 are creating a very dangerous and
very controlling battery on the long
diagonal I really like that but I also
like the idea of C5 see how that will be
played out in the next few moves you're
going to go either C5 first you're
already ready for to push C5 but you can
also start with the move Rook to C8 so
this is the battle right now will white
be able to control the C5 square and
stop black from doing C5 maybe the move
Knight to B3 jumps to mind right the
problem is I can actually give you the
pawn with C5 yes I can actually
sacrifice like this and after d takes C5
just simply Bishop to E4 kick the queen
around a little bit right if you go
Queen to C4 I can go back to D5 you
cannot touch this one because after Rook
to B8 you're going to lose the Knight on
B3 so you have to go back to C2 but then
of course I have so many options both of
my Rooks are ready to go to the C file
this one to C7 this one to C8 at one
point I'm going to recapture uh that
pawn on C5 with dividends because I mean
my position is so ACC active all of my
pieces are placed on the ideal squares I
really like what black is doing in this
one and I have to say from the position
that we currently have on the board it
is white who has to be careful not to
fall under a tremendous strategical
disadvantage after to move C5 well let
let me play the devil's advocate for
just a moment so after the move Queen A8
I like the move Rook F1 to C1 Christian
and you're going to play Rook C8 just at
uh I'm actually going to go C5 but
and I'll go with your knight B3 and the
reason why I played Rook fc1 because in
this case after Bishop E4 I Was
preparing Queen D1 uh Square so but I
can still go C5 first right let me take
on F6 take on F6 Bishop takes F6 let me
play Knight takes C5 yeah you can take a
pawn that's the thing you can take a
pawn but first of all I have Bishop
takes D4 right now and you wouldn't
believe but this is actually just losing
for really just losing yeah and I can
see I'm on I'm in this you take on4 I
take on G2 and then you lose I'm not so
that was why you played C4
takes uh a moment ago you can do this
but now I have options I can go Bishop
D5 Bishop E4 I can even go A5 so it's a
slow game the thing is and the idea
behind this position and Black's plan is
that white doesn't actually have a way
to improve his position anymore you move
the Rook from C1 to try to get the other
one in plate you lose the C5 Pawn you
you move the knight from B3 you lose the
C5 Pawn so you don't have a lot of ways
to develop your initiative and uh there
is no active plan for white while black
is enjoying himself he has a lot of ways
in which he can develop his pieces this
is just looking much better it's pretty
cool to see the cooperation of the
pieces right Bishop E4 the other Rook
can slide to C7 the like black species
are on the eighth and seventh rank
pretty much but they have a lot of
Cooper together yeah they compact nice
nice thank you uh Christian boy I I got
to say not obvious uh insights there uh
a slow play going on in the game between
uh lener and uh Fabby not too many Moves
In fact when we left it uh Christian
essentially had this position on his
board and was he was showing us the
changing of structures from night takes
Pawn takes Bishop D7 Knight takes Pawn
takes and when did you see a structure
like that on the queen side no said
lanir I want to include the capture on b
b uh B4 takes C3 I want to include that
capture and really what I want to do is
take and double up the pawns with move
Bishop B6 or potentially trap the bishop
with
C6 I mean it's not yet kind of the A6 is
still yes a possibility but okay I I I
get that uh an alert um talking about a
change of structure so I like the two
Bishops let's see what we've got here
for just a moment and again I do like
the two Bishops I'm gonna I'm G to
tickle Knight C6 I've got Bishop B7 in
mind and I don't want you to take at
least what I want to do to rescue my
Bishop is I want to play D4 and bring my
Bishop back to F4 one what do you think
so can I go Knight C8 Knight
C8 gosh darn it that's a very good move
that's just a very good move uh I I
don't want to go that will help me in
the future to even move the Knight to E7
right after I kick the bishop yes
exactly so I almost feel like I have to
go back and Silent draw offer night7
acquest to a draw solid play here let's
go uh further let's see uh the game of
darush and Wesley and and we kind of
expected this kind of thing from the
opening these the these games these the
positions that occur out of these
openings are so solid and I I feel like
I've seen Wesley do this movie again and
again and again he really uh plays these
positions very well and he almost
invariably uh draws them Sam Sean um and
Hans nean Sam Shanklin I meant to say
and Ray Robson this was the pawn
sacrifice let's see how well guess what
they pretty much uh continued out
variation varation right H4 we were
suggesting here and then
H3 yes we were actually somewhere I
don't know even if it was
H4 what did we do maybe an e well we'll
just put it on on the board we had
something of uh this nature as we were
looking at ideas of F3 and you were
explaining well we're Pawn up but we
have a very serious issue to solve our
dark sare Bishop right and apparently uh
what's the time between the players
because Ry had been playing very quickly
right but right now Sam has 1 Hour 4
minutes and Ray Robson has only 37
minutes significant time 30 minutes
Advantage for Sam a long Ong with his
Pawn so we'll keep an eye on that one
again Misha versus Andrew Tang big
theoretical battle uh the engines prefer
White's position but uh we kind of felt
it was okay for black as well and
finally our birthday boy leavon aronian
versus uh Jeffrey Jong similar um middle
game/ end game to the Wesley so game
again you know four versus four on the
Queens side Center m 3 verus three on
the king side uh still looks very even
uh to my eyes here just a lot of
maneuvering toing toing and throwing so
uh Christian where's the action well
let's take a look at the ladies action
right because that's that's where I
wanted to go Kate was waiting to jump in
with yep remember when we looked at this
game T versus Alis Lee and we were
discussing G Knight E4 Queen D3 Bishop
F6 and Knight to B3 and we were
wondering where the queen is going
that's exactly what happened wow really
yes yes they follow the best moves by
the engines these players are good and
queen to A6 was played this is the
problem that yes the best move in the
position but not a very uh fun move ATT
not a very attractive one because now
after Queen takes A6 B takes A6 this is
going to be such a nice end game I mean
look at the pawn on A7 long Bishop on E3
and first of all you cannot cut that
action of the bishop on E3 with the move
C5 that's another weakness on D6 the
pawn structure is just really bad for
black so this is where the advantage
lies I also have a very nice initiative
on the king side potentially after the
exchange of this Knights maybe G5 F4
make like life difficult for the dark
Square Bishop on F6 so this one is
really not looking good for black for
Alice Lee and I have to say she had some
problems in the previous round as well
she's having some problems in this game
also and here's a graphic of our
youngest player 13 years old Alice Lee
usca rating
2471 and she is the youngest American
woman to achieve I am title so she is I
am elect and on the next FID Summit
she's going to actually get that title
next to her name right officially she's
just an FM but we know she's about to be
and I am uh the move Queen A6 uh
remember bent Larson uh stating very
matter of factly uh to me yeser I don't
play Such moves as Queen A6 I
mean not an easy move so so impressed
that even Christian said that's the best
move in the position you know
voluntarily to go the end games are yeah
but like at at this age and you know
she's very strong obviously so she still
understands that going into this worse
end game is still the best shot for her
better than the dynamic middle game she
was facing Queen A6 uh no kind of you
don't like it either nobody likes it
you're forever going to suffer in that
end game with right doubled pawns but
also is this a is this um a way of
playing the opponent because for tatv I
mean she'll be happy that she's in a
better ending but then she's not so
happy she's in an ending because she
when you play a move like G4 you're
ready to go F3 and H 4 and G5 and let's
go a big attack trading Queens there
goes the attack that's true but on the
other hand you are very happy that you
kind of start feeling it's like a two
result game you can win or you can make
a draw but you're unlikely to lose so
Christian what else got your eye well
one lady that we didn't highlight uh in
that graphic with past champions was one
Champion Karissa the 2021 US Women's
chess champion and she's been having a
very good event up to that point even
though only one round has passed because
with the black pieces against Arena
Crush she got a crushing position and
she could have won that game easily so
definitely that shows she's in good
shape she also got a medal at the world
juniors definitely in good shape and
she's crushing this position as well
take a look at this Knight to f8 C4 open
up the position everywhere uh everything
is opened on the king side you cannot
Castle there how about you will not be
able to Castle on the queen side either
your king will have to get stuck in the
center and that's what's going to Aid my
attack we have D takes C4 Knight to A5
I'm not in a hurry to yes why not and I
think she miss the D6 Square yes yes
that's where the Knight is going that's
where the Knight is going Knight A5
Knight C4 Knight D6 and you're going to
suffer because of that I'm curious
because we are looking at this position
after Queen D2 and I thought we want to
like long castle and keep that Knight on
D7 so time play actually C4 we can
transfer the Knight to B6 and D5 AG
right so maybe I can go uh Knight to a
five first right and I'm keeping ideas
of in fact not only C4 but B4 B5 as well
also alive yeah yes and this one I have
to say it's not looking good either but
perhaps better than what's been played
in the game Knight f8 I have to say
that's not the right direction for
Knight and after that Knight takes C4
Knight to D6 is coming you have to be
very precise not to lose in the next 5
to 10 moves right now as black this one
is looking very dangerous and very very
bad for the defending Champion Jennifer
yissa is on a rooll and this one I have
to say he's feeling good he Lo she loves
this type of positions that's the thing
we highlighted this at the beginning of
the show as well she loves to play
against karakan she loves to play
against the French and you can see that
on the time expenditure as well she's
much more comfortable right now 1 hour
and change for Karissa in only 36 minut
it's for jary you wow I I really for
some reason uh when I saw the move uh C4
and I was looking at takes tak6 kind of
thinking Black's okay Knight G6 but the
moment you see Knight A5 takes C4 to D6
you know your complete impression of the
position has just turned uh upside down
or right side up uh speaking of past
champions that we've uh allowed it uh
Arena Crush eight-time Champion she's on
the black side of a game with a local
hero telia cantes when we left it we had
just seen the move Knight H4 shall we
catch up castles Knight F5 G6 G6 wow we
were expecting Rook E8 Bishop f8 but G6
putting the challenge putting uh white
Under the test Knight H6 check King G7
what do you have in mind B very natural
move Queen B6 equally as natural getting
out of the pin defending kind of
reinforcing an attack Knight G4 okay I
was expecting something like Rook A1
actually because the idea is that if you
want to start trading my knight like
Knight G8 I can always like Target the
Knight on D7 with my Rook with some
discovered attacks precisely another way
of uh thinking about it is from uh the
art of attack uh by uh vidmar uh wuk the
idea is that white has put in a lot of
energy has spent a lot of time bringing
the KN and the bishop uh to the king
side so the move Knight G4 kind of loses
a Tempo it loses a little bit of the
crispy character the position the
problem is white is not going to win
with just those two pieces you have to
play for F4 whether you like it or not
moves like King h8 F4 or as you uh
prescribed Kate bring your bring the
rest of your pieces in the game Rook D1
Knight G4 feels wrong uh frankly and
maybe even a little bit helpful for
arena having said that let's try to get
up to date with the players A4 I suspect
uh arena is about to play B4 take it
away this is interesting so maybe Talia
is thinking about doing a lot of Trades
because now I don't know if we want to
put A5 there just like or just keep it
but but take on F6 with everything we
have you mean Knight takes takes Knight
Tak Knight takes Bishop takes uh Queen
takes I supp queen takes a knight D5
right and you're you're saying you want
to go into a bishops of opposite color
position let's say I play A5 yeah now
I'm thinking maybe I should have put A5
exactly okay so from the beginning so we
take it all back we're in this position
we've just seen the move B4 so now we
want to go into that ending that you may
have uh just prescribed for us I'm not
sure I want to where I go with a queen
but here now you you don't I guess you
do have to rush because otherwise you
don't get the square D5 so you do have
to rush takes takes takes takes takes
Knight
D5 uh I just want to say that uh we just
like cleared off the entire chess board
here I don't know do you feel like
you've got something here though I mean
I agree the pawn on A6
is a little bit of a Target but I don't
know I could play E4 maybe E3 myself
Bishops of oppos a color right uh the
other idea I thought that you had in
mind uh was after the move
a five which I kind of like is you know
just keep the
tension what do you think just keep the
tension unless no you am I do I have
time for that I'm not sure cuz if I
capture well you got to ask the question
right what happens if I
capture uh this guy's hanging I can toss
in a check I don't know if that's
helpful or not shall I just have a look
see a peak and then I take
this and you take this take this I've
got a knight F6 check at the end of the
day that might be awkward right oops
Yeah I got and the Knight of6 check I I
uh
conspired against Arena here uh in this
position um Christian jump in on this
game of Talia and Arena as the
position this there's a lot of tension
oh absolutely yes and it's very balanced
the position is as well very very
balanced according to uh the assessment
of the engine it's a z0 maybe even a
little bit better for a black it's a
very awkward position right this bishop
doesn't belong on C5 this bishop should
be on G7 I mean what is this bishop on
C5 doing right but at the same time you
have quite a few um resources around
your king especially these two knights
protecting the king nicely so I don't
see the danger for the black king even
in the absence of the dark Square bishop
and at the right moment I can always go
back to f8 if I really need to right so
yeah I'm looking at the position A5 is
in the books
D6 probably the best move in the
position and how do you continue this
one if you go Knight A4 I put a B Pawn
D4 right and that's going to be a
problem but also you're losing a piece
so you have to be careful Knight H G4
followed by Qui yeah I guess I have to
include Knight F6 you have take all take
take and now Knight A4 Bishop
D4 I don't know I'm looking at the
position the engine saying z0 but to my
eyes it looks much better for black you
like the bishop on D4 I capture the
Knight on F6 Christian I don't play
Knight A4 I capture the Knight on F6 and
with a bishop yes yes but Queen takes F6
and Knight D5 I have a feeling I can
take and then go E4 right you might be
in trouble because of e after that
sequence Bishop C4 it actually I still
don't see the trouble E3 is so E3 E3 is
a big problem yeah and if you take Rook
takes E3 if I play F3 that pawn is just
ooh if you allow this Pawn to live on E3
I mean this is going to be a long uh
long torture for for white right not
happiness F3 or F4 I start pushing my H
Pawn down the down the board you
actually don't have any counter play
yeah as if you don't mind Christian go
back to the position with the Knight on
H6 for just a moment the pawn was on a
A2 okay so instead of the move Knight
G4 uh first of all did the engines like
the move Knight G4 what did they like
instead um Knight to G4 is not the
prescribed move by the engine Queen to
F3 but still the position seems to be a
bit more comfortable for black whatever
you
Play3 Rook D1 Rook A1 a D1 is one of the
moves as well it's all about slow play
but my play is much easier and I have
clear plans on how to improve my
position also Knight to C5 Knight to E6
is an idea right now that I emptied this
C5 Square the quality of my pieces is
just Tire M that it's it's simple as
that it all comes down to that and let's
take a look at the time situation as
well 41 minutes for Talia 53 minutes for
arena Arena definitely filling these
positions much better and she played the
move Queen to D6 best move in the
position quickly as well thank you uh
Christian nice and a game uh that had
caught our eye earlier atou uh versus
ruang y ruang grab that pawn on E4 were
very proud of her she followed what we
thought Queeny T long Castle right here
uh we thought taking on e4 was a nibble
that we should best avoid rang was like
no it's a free Pawn I'm going to grab
that I'm not going to trust my opponent
it's uh it's a prep right and queen E2
they're following everything and I have
to confess I thought this was great
compensation
until not that move I think we said
night this was the move that really kind
of jolted us because the idea is as
simple as it looks we want to take this
put our Queen on C6 gain a Tempo against
the bishop and the bishop out do you
think you know night before before that
maybe ruang and did not want to allow
like Knight takes E5 but that's so many
pieces right for the queen ah here here
what do we have we we gave up two minor
Min and a rook for a well not even a
pawn right oh yes it is a one one Pawn
no I I would take black right the two
Bishops are really strong Rook C8 coming
up to Target C2 pawn and the king is
safe and just the king is safe as well
uh if she if she avoided this line
because she didn't want to give up her
Queen I think it was an error of
judgment but the move Queen E8 I applaud
simply from the perspective of I want to
fight for the D5 Square Bishop E6 Knight
B4 on the agenda we think Knight B4 was
Stronger but uh at the moment uh White
is the one who has to prove that her
sacrifice is Justified don't think so I
I still like uh Black's position and
let's jump in maybe to Nazi pza and
anon's game absolutely super interesting
what was going to happen after that we
left around3 move these
Bishop D7 there you go I thought not
allowing Knight a your inner US champion
there uh Kate but no I we thought that
Knight A4 might still be the way to go
Knight F3 okay that's a bit of a
surprise
Retreat rookie a A3 now that move I can
I can support because you got uh B4 and
C5 on your agenda takes and I'm assuming
uh after this Nas's intention was to
play Knight to E5 and Target this Pawn
um jump in Christian uh engine approved
uh who who improved their position since
uh we last looked oh it's definitely
black it's definitely Anna zansky who
has improved her position right now that
night way4 was crucial right we had to
play that move night A4 she did not she
missed a bit in that regard and right
now she needs to hand down this Pawn get
yeah give it give it back to me but
unfortunately after the move Knight to
E5 I go Queen to C7 you can take on D7
and by the way we have the first result
we anticipated this one Wesley so with
the black pieces without much problems
Against the Wild Card darus fards in
this one that was a draw Knight to E5
Queen to C7 of course you can take on C4
the problem is once you take on C4 now
all of your pieces are kind of in
shambles right where is this Knight
going you cannot go back to E5 right
there's a lot of pieces on this file and
I can take full advantage of that with
the move Rook A8 I just have the better
placement of the pieces in the position
Bish C1 is an issue right and it's very
easy to see this visually right you feel
that black has the advantage right now
so if you go for the bishop Pawn D7
Knight takes D7 instead of Knight takes
C4 now I can just simply take back and
you still need to utilize a lot of
resources to get that pawn back on C4 so
I'm starting to like Black's position
Anna's position there's one problem
though Time Anna's time management we
are at move 13 right now and that's a
problem because she only has 21 minutes
on her clock right those 21 minutes are
going to go down fast right so this is
not looking good from that perspective
but I have to say uh the last few moves
definitely have favored Anastasia well I
can tell you that the space time can
Continuum changes when you're in time
trouble it's like your
heartbeat goes faster and time goes by
slower and it it's it's a very very very
strange phenomenon I have to tell you
when I was on Olympic team or um world
um Championship women's team and I was
sitting next to Anna and I saw that
she's on move like 15 and she has 6
minutes left it was stressing me out
that I decided I cannot be looking at
her clock it's a team I have to focus on
my my game or look at her game but not
the clock she's used to that but for me
it was like I thought she's already in
big trouble and she plays really well
under pressure so I know that if she has
10 minutes to go she is still not going
to lose her skill yeah which is the most
amazing thing is almost it feels like
Anna plays better under the pressure of
a ticking clock the same story I I
follow you completely six time US
champion Walter Brown he was was forever
getting into time trouble and I remember
an Olympiad in uh Lutzer and Switzerland
where I was playing as you say just
right next to him Jou the Jou and I just
I didn't want to look at the clock
because I knew you know the the table's
shaking and Walter is moving and it's
like frantic energy and uh he did very
well on the team he was like what's
going on just very very very confusing
and uh let's jump to tatev and uh Alice
Lee because do have that end game
because this move Queen A6 I mean it
takes well some courage to play a move
like that because you know longterm your
pawns are really spoiled and as was
mentioned the A7 Pawn is perpetually
messed up and just almost every kind of
ending is going to be inferior but C4
move
that's for me a little bit unexpected to
open up the bishop but for the diagonal
of the bishop uh you were imagining that
this Knight might get kicked kicked
around transfer our Knight to A5 C6 I
like that I like that a lot uh just uh
Curious once again we a couple of
broadcasts no I'm not going to do it I'm
not going to be able to do it it's
always the two minor pieces uh versus
The Rook uh here I had imagined that you
were going to play Knight C6 and allow
me to play um uh Bishop takes E1 but you
do have Bishop D2 as a way of not losing
an exchange so I can't play Knight C3 so
Knight C6 Knight A5 pardon me totally
legit move uh maybe I have to go the
other way uh I'll get my I need
counterplay if I sit if I just you know
twiddle my thumbs and do nothing play
Quiet Moves Like H6 I'm going to get
killed um so uh yeah 85 seems more
aggressive Christian you have a special
guest in studio we do indeed Darius uh
today a much more peaceful game than
yesterday how did you recover after that
crazy game and how did you approach
today's game tell us your
story hi hi guys I'm glad to be here um
so yeah yesterday uh yesterday game was
totally insane um at some point I was of
course lost but um yeah I mean at some
point I was also winning uh after such
roller coaster right I was thinking to
take this game today so I mean pretty
much in solid manner especially I have a
bad memory of playing in round two
against Wesley two years ago in
singfield Cup Where I Was overly
ambitious and I got punished for that so
I wanted to take my uh take this day
more calmly and that's why I guess I
also chose this uh more quieter line
I wasn't expecting KN F5 in the opening
um
so yeah I was expecting 8 um and after
night night five um is also a move I had
a game against rajabov I think here uh
but I didn't really review this because
Wes was playing exclusively 98 and
similar positions so that's why I focus
mostly on that and I had some prepared
some ideas there based on some magnus's
games uh he played recently against I
think van Forest D also Guk in some
online tournaments so I had some
inspiration from these games he won all
them I guess so so I was uh hoping to
get some some action going there of
course there's nothing special on this
rookie one line but it is it is what it
is there's no one refuted Berlin yet so
absolutely and you also wrote a couple
of books on the ru Lopez that definitely
helped you in yesterday's match did you
uh feel that influence coming from your
books as well and what about today's
game
uh actually from both books I I analyze
these these lines um you know for rookie
one Merlin for white um but yeah somehow
I couldn't recall night five ideas and
uh I what happens after night five and I
was you know as like I said most mostly
focus on KN d8 and yesterday's game well
in my books I covered Bishop C2 in this
smaller or ar Angel um but Bishop Buffy
also is a move that I heavily studied
too so um yeah it's one of the most
interesting and fighting opening uh
choices for black so I was thinking to
try it out yesterday and uh I had a good
position so I guess opening wise it was
a good choice uh later of course it was
very very complex and complicated but I
mean uh chess is a complicated game in
general so chess doesn't have to be easy
thank you very much darus go uh recover
get your energy back and we'll see you
tomorrow see you guys good luck indeed
uh just checking in on the Mishra versus
Andrew tangame because uh now that we
know the theory and the whole thing like
it's really extraordinary uh for for
folks at home who are joining us a
little bit late you know we're getting
into these mesmerizing positions and
then we're discovering that they're all
uh still uh theoretical I mean we were
so impressed during the 2023 us Juniors
right how far they preped how much
preparation they have and here we see
Mishra move 23 1 hour 23 minutes and
Bishop A4 is still the engine's number
one recommended move very deep
preparation wow extraordinary what also
is a really again uh for me a big
surprise even though Christian did
mention it if you do trade on E3 The
Rook takes on E3 and you got to be a
little bit mindful that The Rook could
come across either to the C3 or B3
Square now on the other hand as a
classical player I I was always told if
you my opponent have the two Bishops I
got to take them away from you I can't
so the move Bishop E5 is kind of
contrary to how I was trained like I
mean okay maybe I don't play Bishop
takes E3 but I don't shy away either
from the trade Bishop D4 which you know
again uh um contrast and a rook d8 and
we've caught up with the players and at
this point uh Misha has an intriguing
option for example C3 Knight C6 let me
just put this position on the board for
a moment as a structural list and what I
mean by that is I take a look at the pwn
skeletons right take all the pieces off
the board and I just look you know I see
this isolated Pawn I see these double
pawns I see this isolated pawn and I
think well you know King anding games
roning games must favor me but maybe
it's just one of those things black has
weaknesses but how you going to get to
them right you know maybe it's one of
those uh give us your insights uh Kate
on this current position but before we
do that uh we have guest special guest
special guest um I think well it's a
surprise for me too
so my guess is is Wesley so I haven't
been told who we have but it is Wesley
Wesley welcome back to the show
hopefully with better audio today tell
us a bit about this game uh how did you
approach
it uh yeah well thanks for having me
hopefully you can hear me better than
yesterday right I wasn't sure if you
could hear me at all but it's good to
see you guys well yeah I mean I just you
know wanted to play I mean I noticed
that darus has been playing a lot of
different openings lately so I didn't
actually think he would go for one E4
considering he tried that before against
me and uh yeah I mean I got to learn a
different opening than the
Berlin I I mean I looked at magnus games
and then he you know he plays like the
perk he plays the Sicilian Knight C6 he
plays the pen plays the night dorf he
mentioned I got I got he mentioned the
game from the singfield cup when uh he
got overconfident in his position with
the white pieces is over pushed and then
lost were you hoping that those type of
Dynamics will play once again in today's
game uh yeah yeah for sure but they're
very unlikely to I guess they're not
likely to happen because everyone knows
I played the Berlin but yeah that was uh
that was a good game that was a good
tournament for me uh that one in the
singfield cup and not a good one for
Darius
so um yeah he's I mean he's a very
strong player he's very very well
prepared he's very aggressive uh he
knows his stuff in the Sicilian so I did
consider playing the nidorf uh at some
point but uh I wasn't sure that he was
going to play one E4 I mean for sure you
know if your opponent wanted to play he
could over push but also against the
Berlin there are many safe lines that
white can choose from but again you know
it's it's a it's it's still early on in
the turn
uh Wesley talking specifically about
this uh US championships do you worry
about making too many draws or do you
think that you're going to have probably
something like 11 eight draws and maybe
a few wins what is your approach to
draws in general in this
Championship yeah it's actually a good
question I mean last year I lost two
games yeah
against one against a 15year old so
you know Christopher you yes but yeah
yeah he's very good uh but uh in 20121 I
won the tournament with two wins and no
losses so I mean there are advantages in
disadvantages to both
approaches but uh at some point you just
got to start winning some games and see
how it goes
um uh in know it's it's hard to say but
some point you just got to make a move I
think in
2018 I won my first two games and then
drew the
rest and in 2016 I also started on fire
like winning the first two games as well
I
think so
uh yeah I mean you it's I I think you
have to keep it balanced but at the same
time you got you got to make a move at
some point yeah perfect well thank you
so much Wesley oh yeah thank you very
much uh Wesley indeed as uh we go uh to
break we'd like to leave you with Sabina
who caught up did her own podcast with
Fabiano hope you
enjoy hi Fabby thank you so much for
joining me today uh can you tell me a
little bit about your chest upbringing
yeah it started when I was pretty young
I was around 5 years old uh and I was
living in New York at the time uh so it
started after school with other kids
from uh from the chess club it was a
very very small Club very few uh players
very few kids were interested in chess
but we had good coaches and uh my first
two coaches I remember from those early
days as well um Bruce Pini and Miran
Sher who sadly passed away a few years
ago but they were like very instrumental
in my early coaching and very prominent
in the New York circles so a lot of the
kids I grew up with also became very
strong players like Robert Hess is is of
course a houseold name he was one of the
one of my competitors when I was a kid
and also one of my friends and Mark
Arnold and other other players from the
New York area became either very strong
players or grand Masters so it was a
really good scene chest to grow up in uh
and of course the the Marshall chess
club is is famous as like one of the
oldest chess clubs in in the world and
um dedicated to Frank Marshall in in New
York so it was really good to like grow
up in that atmosphere and being being
able to play strong players even as a as
a kid to play uh International Masters
or Fay Masters or players of of quite a
strong level uh in my kind of early
formative years as a chess player so
that that was my upbringing and after
that of course uh I had to at some point
make a branch between school and chess I
had to make that decision so I made that
decision pretty young and and from there
I became maybe not professional but
started my path towards becoming a
professional chess player how many hours
would you say you were spending on chess
studying various things early on it was
probably I didn't have much incentive on
my own I like to play but I didn't like
to study so if we count pure study then
it was probably like 2 hours a week just
working with my coaches I'm talking
about like when I was still in school
and playing I I did play pretty much
every day uh every evening after school
my dad would drive me to the Marshall
Marshall chess club and uh and we would
play there and then when I stopped going
to school then I was working on my own
quite significantly those were still in
the days where computers weren't too
strong so I think a lot that was very
important as well that I got that
experience of working over the board on
my own um and I I was very interested in
it in it I think if I hadn't had the
interest that I developed let's say when
I was 12 until my late teenage years
then I probably wouldn't have gotten
quite so strong I don't think I would
have improved so easily but I had an
interest that was very strong during
those years and that really helped me a
lot cuz I I could apply myself for hours
and hours every day so from like 12 till
let's say until I became like a strong
Grand Master like 16 17 I I was working
a few hours every day and when you say
working you mention that you had a few
hours with your coaches and then you
worked on your own was there a specific
book that uh you remember now that has
had an impact on your chess career yeah
I remember a lot of books I'm not sure
which one I would say has like a very
strong impact but all of them like gave
me something and and I do remember um
like I I I worked a lot with John
Watson's books when I was in like those
early teenage years and I would like go
through the examples of course it's hard
to say now like how much of that
knowledge would hold up to engine
analysis but I think just just the
process of working on your own is is
already very beneficial even if let's
say the all the uh all the stuff that
you look at isn't correct that's not the
main part the main part is just that
you're applying yourself and you're
thinking critically about Chess and that
that's going to lead to Improvement so
uh definitely the material I looked at a
lot of uh John Watson's books a lot of
Jonathan Ron's books um of course
kasparov's books uh and and there were
some old classics that I also worked
with quite a lot and and with coaches uh
a lot of like studies I remember when I
was working with cherin for about 2
years he would uh give me like entire
palbo studies which would take sometimes
two hours to fully go through and just
sit there and calculate things from
beginning to end so I do remember
sitting and looking at like one position
for let's say 2 hours straight um yeah
of course a lot of that is is like very
root work but it really can can make a
difference when you're when you're
improving especially when you're young a
lot of those ideas sink in a lot of the
like um thought process that you work on
sinks in during your games I love how
you said that even if specific books
don't hold up maybe to the engines these
days they still have a big impact in the
development of a person people sometimes
forget about that and it's very
important to have a strong player like
yourself mention those things because
working on your own it's it's really
something that's building up a strong
understanding yeah yeah I think that's
the most important thing cuz sometimes
we focus on like you work half an hour
on a position and you find out that the
the book was wrong cuz let's say it was
written before computer times and
they're going to make mistakes and then
you think this whole process was
worthless but in fact I think that just
because you were sitting there
calculating is more worthwhile than
whatever like let's say objective value
of the position was of course and you're
coming in this year as the champion do
you feel any pressure um getting into
this competition considering that you
have to switch from classical chest to
Rapid 9lx do you feel any pressure for
this particular event to bring back the
championship I think normal amounts of
pressure because every year it's pretty
much a tossup like anyone could
potentially win so I don't feel like um
like let's say all the pressure is on me
I think the pressure is kind of evenly
split among players who who all have
their hopes of winning and yeah very
often it comes down to um who's just
who's just uh on the best form during
the tournament so I we have guys like
Levon and Wesley and lenier uh and also
the the younger players are very
promising very dangerous now they're
growing up a bit so they're kind of
maturing more in their chess approach um
we saw like seon was um was very
impressive in
9lx um but also Jeffrey and and Ray and
all these players are very capable so I
don't feel like I have so much pressure
on me compared to other players I think
everyone will be dealing with this a bit
and also the last very serious
tournament I played the World Cup uh I
don't think that the pressure is going
to compare to that that's a bit more
because it's like a knockout and more um
riding on a single game or a single move
that this pressure is is probably going
to be a bit more uh Pleasant compared to
that well thank you Fabiana thank you
very much I wish you good luck and
looking forward to seeing your games
thank
[Music]
you yeah um it's amazing what the club
has done for chess in general because I
mean it's already been 15 years and
they've done countless uh national
championships tournaments for juniors
helping gr own schools and they've just
grown the game so much across the United
States I think if I look at my own
career and I look at American CH in
general were in a much better place than
we were 15 years ago and so the
contributions have been immense and of
course it's all thanks to Dr juny
singfield and Rex
singfield I would say that St L CH Club
is like a rock in the ocean of Chess and
we know that it's it's there it is there
it will be there I think it sense a hope
that the game of chess will always stay
AF flat but the mere fact of its
existence I think it it it sense
positive waves across the
globe the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States we bring the educational benefits
of Chess to thousands of students across
the St Louis area we also promote Chess
at the highest levels hosting all levels
of the US championships as well as
high-profile tournaments that attract
the world's best players become a member
and enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments and so much
more visit St Louis chess club.org to
claim your membership
today the World Chess Hall of Fame
located in the heart of St Louis's
historic Central West End want to know
why chess is intrigued people around the
world for nearly 1,500 years stop by and
learn about the impact of Chess from our
three floors showcasing the art culture
and history of the game the World Chess
Hall of Fame has something for everyone
to enjoy for more information on current
exhibits please visit World Chess h.org
[Music]
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85,000 students in both in
school and after school programs we
created the select chess training
program and the junior select chess
training program in order to elevate the
skill level in students across the St
Louis area these students receive
professional training from Grandmaster
verua niobian other programs include
chess Coxs a partnership with the St
Louis Police Department looking to
improve relationships between atrisk
kids and police officers in the St Louis
area with over 600 students playing
chess over the board since 2019 the St
Louis chess club has also created a
chess merit badge for the scouts BSA
quickly becoming one of the most popular
badges with more than 250,000 Scouts
earning the badge since 2011 students of
chess can also pick up a copy of read
and write chess thanks to Club
co-founder Dr jeie Karen sinkfield
anyone can learn how to understand chess
notation in no time we view chess as a
valuable educational tool learn more
about our Scholastic programming by
visiting St Louis chess club.org
[Music]
seducation hello everyone and welcome
back to our live coverage of the 2023 US
championships and uh we're just going to
take a look at a gander at the results
we only have one so far in the open
section the open section only one result
SCH Drew against s in that Berlin Wesley
kind of complaining that you know what
he's making a lot of draws with the
black pieces and yeah he's maybe I need
to learn more openings right about his
openings speaking of openings and
something that has gone wrong I want to
take you immediately to our tournament
leader in the women's section and that's
uh Nasi against uh Anna because I really
don't like what has gone on in the last
uh couple of moves four five six moves
already uh probably right here it starts
with this Retreat Knight F3 that just
feels wrong on uh different levels
either you capture or you play Knight A4
one of those two but I didn't like this
Retreat and then compounding it was this
move A3 because now it gets even harder
to recapture this pawn and then finally
this move E3 E4 I think nasio is getting
frustrated at this moment uh wanting to
develop her Bishop but she's actually
doing a great favor for Anna Anna jumped
uh quickly and I love this move by Anna
Knight
G4 provoking Rook F1 and this move
especially as well uh the move Bishop D6
what what's so uh great about that move
well the moment you
see5 and the Knight coming either to D3
or B3 and you're hitting F2 and if this
knight ever gets chased to E 5 good
things are happening great things are
happening also Rook C8 immediately
allows to defend the pawn on C4 exactly
and still that now the Catalan Bishop
that once Ruled The Roost on the open
diagonals all blocked in don't like
what's happening for our tournament
leader here and Christian jumping over
to you uh where do you see the action
I'm looking at the open section and
there's a lot of actioning a lot of
people building up their advantages
respective advantages is in this one
take a look at this one ABI Manu versus
Andrew tang and I have to say look Rook
to E3 is a perfectly good move the one
that he played he's still borderline
winning in this one I have to say from a
practical perspective this one is not
looking good for Andrew Tang but I was
going through the lines and there's one
very specific uh line that was brought
to my attention take a look at this
bishop takes E5 D takes C5 and now
F4 this is a completely unexpected Pawn
sacrifice why would you do F4 of course
Rook takes F4 is not possible because
you lose a rook on d8 you can take on D1
first and then still Rook takes uh F4 is
not possible because you get checkm so
most likely you will be taking back with
the pawn and now I'm doing very much
caveman chest I'm just going to push my
pawn and nothing is going to stop me
take a look at this because of this
bishop on A4 by the way controlling E8
if you go C6 the problem is I'm going to
continue with E6 and add the right
moment I will have the move C3 for
example if you try to stop me with Rook
to E8 and saying that E7 I go King G8
something of that nature C3 is coming
right now you cannot touch the D5 Square
because after Rook takes D5 your on E8
is is losing yes yes yes and the same
goes if you start with King to G8 I can
still do this Rook takes D5 and E7 and
you cannot stop my Pawn from promotion
so that's a problem right
but what if I go Knight to C6 what if I
try to plug this diagonal with my knight
E6 and at the same time control E7 Rook
takes D1 Rook takes D1 Rook to E8 it
looks good controlling finally stopping
the pawn right right E7 you're not
stopping anything in this position if
you take on E7 I take and you get
checkmated it's a one tempo calculation
you have to stop me from going Bishop
takes C6 and Rook to d8 so the only
other alternative to your defense is
King to G8
now if I take take Rook d8 King F7 and
you're actually better with black pieces
right mhm but what you can do is take a
look at this and this was what surely he
has missed because this is not easy at
all Bishop to D B3 King to h8
BR that's I would be laughing at you if
you would ask me that question Bishop to
D5 and that's it game over no Bishop A4
no Bishop A4 back because I go King to
G8 and that's a draw now there's no more
King to to G8 that's illegal right if
you take with a rook the same problem I
take on C6 and Rook to d8 Checkmate you
cannot do that I do have a big threat so
if you play something like G6 say Okay
King G7 next and I'm getting close no no
no no no no no that was you play King G8
you cannot fly your king to F7 right so
that's game over you have to take back
on E7 with the Knight but after Rook to
E1 I Pin It to Win It Bishop to F7 is
coming next you're losing the piece this
completely in shambles for back Rook d8
Rook E7 Rook D5 rookie a check you
cannot do that you cannot save your
piece this one is looking good guys I
mean what a nice illustrative game for
back rank issues right yes yes what a
nice calculation it's one of those
things that's a precisely right it's a
tactical calculation that's a deep
sequence and instead when you play a
move like Rook e 3 you think I'm playing
strategically masterfully I like it look
I like it right it's very difficult just
happens that four was winning we don't
yes it was winning we don't see this
pattern very often right with the bishop
on A4 controlling E8 and then this
bishop to B3 Bishop to D5 very precise
maneuver it's a very beautiful maneuver
but still the pressure is on Andrew tang
and by the way Andrew how are we looking
on time 45 minutes for white good 19
minutes and a lot of pressure on
Andrew's shoulders right now well the
question that uh I would have for you
though is this move Rook E3 has really
put Andrew it's very good it's still
very good and and asking him what is he
going to do what should he do uh Bishop
to
F4 and then follow it up with C5
but you have to be extremely precise and
by the way this is not over I go Bishop
to E3 now you have to go back to E5 this
is still a decisive Advantage for white
decisive Advantage yes gosh and it
doesn't look like black did anything
terribly wrong yes yes and it just shows
you I mean look they were following one
of the games all the way up until this
position a game that ended in a draw
right but then abim Manu knew the
Improvement which was Bishop to A4 he
played his move Bishop to A4 very
precise play by abib Manu and now he's
just borderline winning and I've got to
tell you for me the move Bishop B3 to A4
isn't such an obvious move I would
probably find it only because I know the
Knight has to retreat to C6 and so I
want to uh be there before you get there
but I really like in just those Quiet
Moves that are so powerful because they
don't do anything by themselves but they
don't allow your opponent to do
something which is the important kind of
very very very impressive stuff and uh
again just to catch up a little bit on
the Anna zansi we only had a a sequence
of a couple ofly but it was important
Bishop F4 G takes F4 so so again a
little bit of compromised Pawn structure
and Knight C5 and I'm looking at this
Knight gosh I got to tell you um Kate
I'm seeing this Knight coming to D3 and
that structure is just going to be
viscer uh Knight takes F4 and Nasi also
I know she's good on the clock but
that's about the only thing going for
her at the moment I she's a pawn down
and I don't like uh I think that
black has the attack so yeah sir what if
I try H3 here all right I wasn't sure if
I wanted to take actually exchange the
Bishops but let's see H3 forcing you to
retreat probably F6 okay and now Knight
E5 okay Knight E5 so I'm targeting the
C4 Pawn which I
appreciate I mean you got to get that
pawn back and okay the the rook and the
bishop are kind of in stepping on each
other's toes so I can do uh the move
Knight pardon me b Bishop to B5 which
does have the advantage of opening up
the dile protecting the pawn on C4 okay
but potentially I can capture it and
then Bishop F1 something so let's clear
that uh uh spot on F1 so Rook F1 D1 Rook
F1 to D1 and now uh is it it for for me
the question is the move Knight to D3 I
really want to take this Pawn if you
trade Knights well you've just
transferred the pawn from C4 to D3
unless no I want to capture the bishop
capture the bishop fair I capture the KN
and now I capture on C4 with Knight and
you've got to suffer you're just going
to suffer no I want to capture with
night I don't want to suffer you don't
no suffering for you huh night takes
night takes night takes night takes and
Bishop oh if I play Bishop F1 I have
Queen G5 in let me
show
Bishop let's write the next chapter of
the book what did we do wrong no that is
Anna zansky our Karen CH Karen Cup
champion uh she could be snatching the
lead uh from her black is really fast
with this Knight E3 and targeting it
feels it uh Christian over back over to
you AB Manu is winning Andrew Tang
blundered as we sort of expected there
was so much pressure on him take a look
at this
C5 was the move but this is just simply
losing after Bishop takes E3 and a very
powerful move right now Rook to F3 you
cannot touch either of my Rooks because
you get check wow back Rank and I have a
huge huge threat in the position go G6 I
take take and then I just simply invade
with my Rook on D6 a beautiful entry
Square now that the pawn on C7 is no
longer there and then my next move King
to G7 C3 you lose a Pawn but you lose
much more than that more than just a
pawn all of your pawns are weak in the
position this is absolutely hopeless if
he plays the move Rook to F3 beautiful
game by ABI Manu and I have to say
Andrew Look he knew something in the
theoretical battle but unfortunately for
him this was just not a good line he got
out prepared in the opening he got a
worse position and he couldn't handle
the pressure and Christian is rug D6 the
only move that wins or no no no there's
a lot of moves that that point you can
go Rook to D7 as well you can start with
C3 this is just one of those positions
that never get better because I have all
the resources in the position I have
rook and Bishop coordination against
rook and Knight which we know that it's
better I have the open file to start
attacking your pawns as well you have
the weaknesses in the position C5 E5 B7
the potential double pawns on the C file
after Knight C6 Bishop takes C6 there's
so many things that are going in my
favor as white and not in yours as black
in this one so this one is not looking
good and I have to say abim Manu is
looking primed to win his first game of
us us Championship absolutely there we
go he was so thrilled first game at the
US CH championships he was so thrilled
in in the Juniors CU he said in an
interview early in the junior
championships yes my goal is to
qualify first place is the only thing
I'm interested in I want to qualify for
the US championships and if I don't this
will have been a failure I was like wow
okay I got
it all right uh I wanted to jump to the
game of Karissa yep and uh Jennifer uh
two of the favorites coming into this uh
ladies Championship we left it here we
had seen the move night A5 and we saw
the that night was like a magnet a super
magnet heading to the D6 square and I
was more than curious to see how
Jennifer handled her business uh the
night there it is I mean and talk about
radiant Glory that is a huge Knight
Knight G6 Bishop G3 it's really bad I I
wouldn't mind just sacrificing in
exchange for uh the Knight and the pawn
but the bishop on G3 is the one that
then the pawn on these sticks can be
even more dangerous yeah exactly well
there you go there
exchange completely winning right but
look she did get a pawn but it's that
you were just about to tell me that this
Pawn on D6 is even more of a monster
than the Knight I think we're just about
to see a resignation in this one wow and
that is such a powerful move because
whenever I I break the
blockade then you know Bishop takes
whether I take a recapture with the
queen which I think I would do it it's
just the point that The Rook is
supporting the passer and that's just
that's just too easy if we could
magically transfer the knight from G6 to
D4 wow we are talking about some
compensation yeah but now the Knight is
kind of useless on G6 and all the pawns
are hanging wow and that would be a huge
win for Chrissa and you were mentioning
on the show that uh yesterday against
enena Crush uh she could very
easily have won that game does feel like
she's in good shape and uh she also won
her last two games at the world juniors
so she's definitely coming with a lot of
confidence and look at her go she's just
snapping out those last few we seen
Queen takes D6 Bishop takes D4 and now
we see the uh trade of potentially the
Queens as well uh Queen takes D6 what
just happened uh I think
oh uh Chris uh Chris uh bird has
informed uh that you've got to keep your
score sheet up to date and I think
Carissa had actually uh miswrote
something on her score sheet so uh I
think she's excited she's just
about I think I think that's exactly
what happened uh I I do have to confess
myself that at times I haven't always
been super accurate in uh my score sheet
because of what you just said my my
enthusiasm for making my next move and
for now to D1 to exchange the Rooks as
well and by the way look at the time
Advantage Karissa has 52 minutes against
Jennifer's 9 Minutes wow and I must just
say these moves are just she's just
popping out these moves as Karissa like
look I I know this is over I mean
material advantage you want to trade
pieces right so kiss is ready to trade
Rooks that's
Unstoppable yeah at this point the best
you you can do is allow the trade and
hopefully try to evict the king I would
never go back by the way once uh The
Rook is you know snuck into uh the back
rank there I keep it I keep the rook and
then I would just uh bring my king I
actually think Rook D5 just wins a lot
oh you want to go uh Pawn hunting Rook
D5 Rook F5 or Rook H5 gotcha you give me
whichever you want I'll take one of them
I'll uh and that also cuts the King
right the king cannot approach the king
side which feels nice
fair fair I you know I've worked so hard
to get to get to the eighth rank you
know I kind of like like to hang around
and just uh see how the water is but
you're right Rook F Rook D5 to F5 and or
H5 and uh Carissa has got this game uh
checking in on tatev and uh Alice Lee
Alice is we've said it since the start
of that Queen takes a A6 that uh Alice
is going to be suffering and I'm curious
how did the Knight get out of the get
off the board well we saw it with C4 and
C5 tatf created weakness we got here and
then she said let's get rid of the
Knight Knight to D2 and that was how the
knights got traded we're up to date with
the player this is a very comfortable
position for D so many weaknesses to
Target D6 A7 A6 potentially right uh
turning to our time uh you one sorry sir
one second please I want to ask you I
turned it off what's the assessment okay
I turned it off but badly all right
what's the assessment right now after
you see when he sets us up for these
types of question it's going to be like
equal like like okay after Rook E6 after
Rook to E6 I'm not going to I just
thought the position's close to winning
for white how much 1 five I'm going to
be a little higher 1.6 just to just to
be on the no I want to be on 3.1 no I
would never have been close to that 3.1
this is completely winning after simply
Rook fd1 there's so many weaknesses once
again you can defend Bishop E7 I go Rook
D5 Rook A5 something's going to give and
once you lose the pawn on A6 you lose
the pawn on A7 as well this is over you
have so many white pawns on the queen
side and there's no counterplay this
Bish Pawn E3 is such a good offensive
and defensive piece at the same time
right no this is looking really good
Rook to E6 Rook fd1 this one I mean it's
T's game yeah right now see this is why
I feel engines hate my guts you know you
will show me the most extraordinary
position with chaos happening all over
the board and I say I like white and
they go three
zeros that's what I'm happy then you
show me a position where it's a nice
comfortable advantage and then they go
4.0 like wait it's just nice nice
advantage but it's an easy position to
play right I mean you you start
understanding why the engine is saying
plus three because you don't have
counter counter CH that's the problem at
some point you're actually going to be
two or three pawns down gotch in the
very near future you know y when we talk
about computer evaluation I'm happy we
were on the right trajectory I was
worried Christian is going to say no
it's equal z0 Z because of something
crazy but yeah you're 1.5 my 1.6 and you
not even close uh B okay and then to
atusa because that's super interesting
game with that down uh this is the um uh
exchange uh ruy Lopez uh this early
Bishop takes C6 and this is what white
does not want to have this is a dream
position for Berlin players right if you
play the Berlin as black you cannot ask
for anything better your majority is
being you you is being pushed
essentially and your two Bishops are
actually working very nicely on the
queen side as well so this is a position
that you definitely definitely favor
Black and you're saying oops why is my
knight on B1 I mean put the Knight on D5
where you know it's in the game and
there's no counterplay on the king side
right no G4 coming because the bishop on
E6 is uh guarding it pretty well with
that pawn on H5 as well as the bishop
and there's no G3 F4 coming either so
for me this is all uh Play on- One goal
right and uh beum looking very very good
here you wanted to go to the game of
atusa atusa against ruang yep that was
our Pawn Sacrifice game and let me just
go back because this is where we saw the
move Queen E8 prepping Bishop E6 we did
like Knight B4 but King B1 Bishop E6 H4
time to do something takes takes night
before we are Pawn down so it's
attack but after Queen trade there is no
attack um I think she cashed in her
chips a little bit early did uh ruang
here because okay I mean I still
obviously prefer uh black and the extra
Pawn but having said that you know we've
doubled up our pawns we given white a
bit of a nibble you and Bishop C7 in the
future targeting that D6 Pawn exactly
exactly so Rook Rook can also slide over
to D one maybe I even start with C3 but
you know I have Knight A6 I know the
move looks very ugly but after you kick
okay3 by the way A3 happened it's on the
board okay uh like it like it you have
Knight A6 you wanted to say yes I don't
like the Knight on the edge of the board
but I'm not allowing Bishop C7 so I do
know I feel like I've gotten a smidge of
play and if I go before no problem I
I'll probably just kind of cement
I I could take but I was thinking I was
going to play A5 and cement the bishop
keeping in mind Knight C5 will probably
cost the E5 Pawn but let's say Rook fc8
rook
fc8 and finally I get in my yay much
voled to
A5 uh what I'm saying is a moment ago I
was awned down and I felt like I had
nothing like no compensation here at
least you know the pawns are doubled um
but Knight C7 Knight o going to E6
Knight C7 sorry going to
E6 H this is not exactly what I I truly
wanted no this is not exactly what I
wanted I was hoping that I'd have a
little bit more play than this something
to keep in mind we'll uh we we'll keep
this one on the boil tell us what you're
looking at at the Hans game but I do
want to ask you guys what you think of
the position maybe you can start
analyzing because I've been looking with
the engine the engine is always saying z
z but I still want to try to understand
whose position is easier is it White's
position is it Black's position so maybe
we can do some moves without the help of
the engine just kind of understand
Engage The Situation from a practical
perspective exactly uh hate the KN on B3
just flat out hate the night on B B3 uh
is in the way a love the Knight on E5
mhm right love the bishop on E7 the that
that structure Knight was played by the
way are we going to see a repetition oh
was R7 Knight F4 King G7 Knight H5 I
smell a repetition okay King G8 Knight
you know what I mean right or King oh
whoa O King H6 no repetition here King
well there might be a repetition Knight
to F4 I think is coming immediately
maybe we can pan out and see the players
right now to see what they're
thinking um because I have a feeling we
might see a repetition after King H6
King H6 Knight F4 Sam King G7 H NE let
me just check on their times too just
Hans is a bit ahead I believe he has 30
something minutes against yesterday he
got into very severe time trouble and
remember when he moved his he was going
to take on G5 and he played Queen F5
instead and this is the moment right now
if he goes King G7 and allows Knight H5
it's kind of an invitation to make a
draw by the way I think Sam Sean is down
on time right Sam only has 10 minutes
versus the whole 35 minutes uh for uh
Hans I I wanted to say that in my view
uh I would prefer black right but the
question is how do you make improvements
in the position oh that's easy my uh I'm
going to go F5 Bishop
G5 okay you know
I if I could get rid King on H6 you were
not afraid that you're going to get
checkm well I thought the king would be
on h8 to be honest I didn't expect it to
be on
H6 H is ready for some aggression that's
for sure I mean that came out of I mean
a good a good General leads his Army to
victory but uh King H6 was a little uh
well over exuberant are we going to see
F5 and a continuation of this game or
are we going to see into to G7 and Hans
was mentioning this you know he was
saying ambition is a double edged sword
yesterday too much ambition can you know
cause some problems especially if you
over push and perhaps he's thinking
about his words and maybe he's going to
choose queing to
G7 on the other hand is black in danger
I mean after F5 white is probably going
to play something like Rook fd1 do we
agree on that well I don't know if we do
because I'm seeing Bishop G5 and the one
thing I don't want to see is Bishop
takes F4 gf4 Rook G8 and then I'm crying
right so right but maybe whenever you
vacate the E7 Square from the bishop C5
is kind of empty for my knight true that
so what do you think you want to go
Knight C5 now want to encourage Bishop
takes F4 thanks oh you you I'm scared
okay I first take the Rook very
important otherwise it would have been
very very scary uh actually lost but
still this looks good for black actually
right Queen G8 maybe Knight G4 right I I
I start to wonder where
exactly yeah why am I encouraging uh
black here it's good but how good is the
question because okay you go Queen G8
right okay right let's try King H1 King
H1
Knight G Knight G4 and now I defend well
first to gain time on the clock yes we
Queen A8 Shack but after Queen A8 I may
have Knight G4 Knight G4 sorry okay
Knight to G4 so now obviously I'm not
going to go
F3 Ben FAL
says do not play
F3 you've got to play E3 but E3 I don't
like because of this queen A8 idea right
and the feels like you're getting too
close to my
my king right it it it's uncomfy so
maybe I have to go Knight D3 Knight D3
oo okay but I feel like black is very
happy here Christian right I I don't
like allowing Bishop G5 I I think back
who one I think if black is playing to
play the move F5 and Bishop G5 I I I
would assume is the way uh to continue
and I thought you were want wanted to
play this one iate yeah Rook cd1 Rook
cd1 so that you can do the The Rook swap
but then in this case what don't allow
Bishop you know go back whether you go
back to H3 or whether you go back to G2
I like G2 yes yeah you like G2 I like G2
because I also want to like play Maybe
H4 to try to kick the bishop away and
then and or F4 yeah I get you okay so
this one feels the right way just don't
go into that pin on uh The Rook on C1
very good we haven't seen the two 2800s
who are crossing swords on board one
Fabby our uh defending Champion my pick
uh my pick as well yeah well yeah okay
you guys stole
that
ridiculous I was jealousy is not a good
look I wasn't going to pick Fabby and
all three of us are going to pick the
same player right look just because he's
your podcasting partner doesn't mean and
what is going on here uh this was what
you were telling us this these change of
structures and the difficulty the
players have in assessment by the way F5
was played in hans's game so he is not
going for a draw he is and look at this
you you you were telling us the whole
way through pay attention to the change
of Pawn structures and look at this last
move D5
uh how many different pwn structures I
mean it happens every single every
single move almost right but this one is
a a whole Pond right I mean uh Fabby is
cruising here isn't he you know we were
discussing this with this is an extra
bar in uh during one of the breaks and
we were like yeah yeah he has it in the
back Fabby Fabby has it because he has
the extra Pawn even though it's Bishops
of opposite and I look at the engine and
the engine is saying zeros get l
something Bishop take H3 oh well Queen
no no no no no Bishop takes H3 I'm just
going to play like this I'm going to go
Bishop to F7 and try to exchange
everything and say that this Knight on
D5 protects against any sort of Bishop
D6 Bishop C7 or Bishop to d8 to try to
go for my B6 Pawn you're not getting
there you're also not getting anything
on E7 and if you do trade the knights
then we're going to have opposite color
Bishops by themselves right so Bishop to
F7 seems to be the One Way Out followed
by Rook to E1 Rook to E8 exchange
everything and it doesn't seem like
there's any way that you can improve
your position as why there's a blockade
in the middle game in this position
right now it's actually pretty
interesting that the Knight on C6 is
kind of stuck right that's why he played
F6 so that the Knight cannot go back to
uh E5 and by the way Bishop F7 is on but
but this is really really harsh Zer this
is really harsh on me because if you
gave me this position and you said yes
you get an extra Pawn you get a powerful
knight on C6 I'm all Gang Busters I'm
enthusiastic and then the modern engine
say you got nothing I got a blockade but
it seems like lanir also understood that
wow wow because right now he's making
his moves quickly kudos to he 13 minutes
and Fab's catching up at some point it
was 50 minutes for Fabby against 13
minutes right now he's 26 minutes
against 13 minutes and the move are more
or less Easy by the way this is
mindboggling to me right now Queen to G3
and it says black is better wow after
the move Rook no no no just because I'm
taking the E file away from you it means
that black is better with a pawn down
this makes no sense that's crazy you
know I remember a lesson I had with my
coach Sergey barzan he called these
pieces like Paper Tigers like they look
they're like really dangerous but
actually they are out of paper so you
don't have to worry about them
so when I
see are you kidding me and by the way he
traded Rooks and went for the exchange
that was going to be prescribed before
aw of course before the move Queen G3
was played uh Queen takes but Rook E6
black is slightly better apparently
black was slightly better yes it's
absolutely crazy that H you your trainer
was Sergey who bzuk yeah yeah yeah oh
well big shout out to Sergey
where did he take you from from expert
to master master to International Master
where grandmas actually he was the most
important coach I had because under his
uh kind of training I became European
Champion second in the world and
everything kind of he took of the career
with me yeah I think I had him under
when I was 13 or 14 wow okay big wow
that's impressive second in the world
nice okay uh once again we're just going
to kind of go around we did Knight
G2 just as you prescribed actually we
thought a move later but yeah didn't we
so it it's King H6 Knight F4 F5 Knight G
oh we were we were playing Rook D1 first
Knight G2 right away King G7 caught up
with the players we think uh also
because of the clock situation yes has
to be careful less than 10 minutes that
yes exactly our tournament leader in the
open section Sam Sean and under a little
bit of pressure here with the white side
uh Sam Shanklin and Ray Robson broken
games that is some specialty well it was
like we left it he was a a pawn up
nursing his extra Pawn I want to say and
he did go for this
D3 and well the
players basically swapped a lot of
pieces off the board and as you were
saying rook and Pon ending specialty but
he's getting one of these pawns back
very he's going to win a pawn back so
this game likely to be a draw yeah it
feels like Sam is promoting his
book for in round one and now in round
two Christian back over to you yeah the
engine is not agreeing with you white is
completely winning oh you see once again
last two Advantage after the move Rook
to B3 which by the way I don't think he
played or perhaps he's still thinking
but was hinting at touching the other
Rook I I had a feeling ah Rook B3 Rook
takes A2 you want to play C4 no I just
want to take your Pawn Yeah so he played
Rook B1 Rook to B1 that was the second
best move I
think Rook to B1 nope never mind now the
a draw yes H G3 H G3 and take yes okay
take on B6 take on B6 take on B6 and
this position perhaps is just just to
draw take take I put a rook on A3 right
you have to go on B2 passive and I'll
just push my king in right unfortunately
while you bring your king all the way to
B1 I'm going to be able to create enough
counter play on this side Christian King
G quick question what if I capture first
on A2 instead of C3 is that a big
blunder
or so I first take take take take uh not
take on C3 but take on A2 right okay but
now I can maybe start with D4
and we're going to get a similar
position let's say you take and I take
but this is a a better Pawn for me the
pawn on D the on a remember right um
than this one mhm so yeah it's a better
better situation for um for white all
right and uh is
Mishra um doing very well when we left
it uh we thought Mishra was winning and
he had by the way he did play that move
Rook
F3 Rook G8 that's that's you indication
that things have gone astray Rook F5 and
yeah it looks like he's doing just great
actually he's a pawn up and he's about
go uh hunting and collect another one
for Mishra again I mean this is this is
what he has prepared his entire career
for he he envisions himself being a
future fut Olympian part of the US team
and it it starts playing in the national
championships and he's getting off to a
good start here uh in round two he's
definitely extremely talented player for
the US future uh Olympic
team and uh a closeup of Mishra here as
we look at that 14 years young
unbelievable us rating
2677 youngest ever to earn Grand Master
title at 12 he earned the international
Master at the age of nine and in
conversations when you just talk to him
he doesn't sound like a 14-year-old he
sounds like a mature young man who's
traveled the world and has uh you know
interests all all over it's just amazing
that uh he's so accomplished so so young
14 he's ready to play Rook
A7 uh here just uh double-checking
wanted to say a game that got away from
us leavon versus Jeffrey Jeffrey jeang
when we left it we left it in the
position where we thought it was uh a
balance and there was a lot of just
toing and throwing back and forth let's
see if something concrete happened and
it did takes on A4 followed by C5 Queen
D7 okay this is not something I'm really
eager to do I whenever I trade Queen
somehow I want to do it on my terms I
don't know what those terms may be but I
was thinking wouldn't you want to play
B8 and I don't know put some pressure on
here uh trading on what I think is my
opponent's terms I I I I do my best to
shy away from that in this case I'm
looking at the fact that the bishop is
eyeballing B8 and I think Knight takes
f8 is actually a threat it's something I
would concern myself because I I think
that the minor piece the bishop on G3
would be better than the Knight on E6 uh
Jeffrey felt the same way that was why
he didn't allow Knight takes f8 and we
caught up to the players Rook e five
feeling a little uncomfortable here
aren't I yeah but the yeser please how
do you feel about the queen D7 move I
was kind of surprised I understand
Leon's point to kind of get a better end
game or put some pressure on the defoul
but I thought he's just going to play
Queen C2 maybe H5 and I don't know do
something there on the king side I can I
I I can get behind that approach too I I
kind of like Queen C2 The Rook on D1 uh
makes me ambitious it makes me think
that if I could take and play Rook takes
D5 I'm a happy camper so I and I like
that I'm controlling the H2 B8 diagonal
so any time you want to play Rook B8 you
kind of have to be careful so you don't
jump somewhere with the KN that you're
not comfortable with ex exactly uh just
to catch up once again on the play uh we
do have this position I do see Rook
takes D5 as a very serious and
consequential followup to the previous
moves um get Jeffrey has only 12 minutes
left for 10 moves Christian uh give me
some insight on the game between leavon
yeah that Jeff there's definitely some
pressure now what Jeffrey needs to
understand is
that off the queen side right right A4
A3 get rid of that guy I think what he
needs to understand is that once you
take on D5 I need to be able to pin you
and you not have the so Rook to A6 is a
very cool move right now just to
interrupt you for a second Kissa did win
her game against Jennifer you expect
that quite a few minutes ago yes big
victory with the white pieces to uh
start in in great shape this Campa this
campaign all right sorry just to yeah
Rook to A6 for sure is a big move but
again it's all about the pressure right
now on Jeffrey with only 11 minutes as
you were mentioning and still 10 11
moves to go this is not that easy right
Rook A6 Rook takes D5 and the idea is
that after Rook to d8 you're kind of
stuck in this position right now but
you're not or he played Rook E8 okay
this is also a good move and Rook takes
D5 is most likely going to come on the
board who whoa whoa whoa whoa sorry
there's Knight B6 takes D5 right but
Knight B6 perhaps I can even start with
R8 Knight takes D5 and then Bishop D6 ah
Bishop D6 and you're unraveling that way
pardon me because you cannot go Rook e
and then you lose the the Knight on D5
so no Rook to d8 is a good move Rook
takes D5 I think we're going to see on
the board and now Rook A6 is not the
only obviously but it's I feel it's a
good move if he finds it just to take
away this Knight B6 this recovery
against this pin on the defile for white
I think if he spots that then he's going
to be in good shape to equalize this
position uh very very fair indeed uh
thank you Christian but uh if you don't
mind pulling up that game that Karissa
just won when we left it Karissa was
playing the move rook d8 and she was
trading off The Rook uh the Rooks uh at
the end and she wanted to play right
here we left it here and uh I was
suggesting the move Rook
88 you suggested the move Rook D5 and
Carissa agreed with you she's going Pawn
hunting and she
succeeded and Kate uh just remind
everybody the results so far start with
the women yeah let's take a look at the
women's section we have one result so
far Yip one against you and that is and
we are just looking out the game of oh
that was nice that that is a very uh
Snappy finish and for the open and for
the open section we have one result Dar
Drew against Wesley saw exactly the
Finish you know you always like these
finishes when you're an exchange up and
you have that luxury of uh taking the
night results are
comate hot and heavy as Mishra uh won
against Andrew Tang Mishra was up a pawn
looked like he was going to win another
Pawn so he's going to be two pawns up in
this rook and pun ending and at this a
very satisfying uh finish uh by Carissa
you're just going to hbon it's the hbon
express she played the move Rook takes
C4 Rook takes C4 stopping any ideas of
Knight takes B2 King takes and uh
actually Jennifer just resigned as yeah
it's the H paon Express all the way up
the board I might as well collect
another Pawn on F4 at some point yes
exactly and when you're when you have
nothing else to do king takes F4 uh
Mishra he played the move Rook A7 oh
yeah that's how he ended after Rook to
A7 Rook to B8 and just the simple move a
B3 stopping any sort of counterplay I'm
already a pawn up I'm going to be two
pawns up probably three after I pick up
the C6 Pawn as well everything is
falling in this position for black and
Andrew had enough he was like okay you
got it you got me out of the opening I
didn't stand a chance to recover after
that I have to accept it I'm going back
back home going back to a drawing board
and trying to do better tomorrow yeah
well this game if you go to that moment
where you played Bishop A4 Christian
because one of the things you were
talking about as coaching and uh
learning openings is yeah you you give
your students uh all the database the
ideas and it just feels to me that
Mishra was much better prepared like
Andrew might have had a shallow
knowledge Mishra had a deep knowledge
and that was the difference here Bishop
A4 and Andrew never recovered that was
the key move and to be honest it's very
difficult to recover I mean you have to
make very unnatural moves H5 this is not
an easy move to make like what is H5
doing in the position loss of tempo
you're actually just giving your king a
little bit of space and that's what you
have to prioritize in this position but
it's not easy to understand after Bishop
to E5 Bishop to D4 I have to say Mishra
played the perfect game wow playing very
accurate with this Knight on B before I
think I think it's very uncomfortable
for black so you really need to know how
to kind of recover it right yes wow okay
congratulations another really cool game
all right uh we're just
gonna uh we have Misha in studio
Christian let's go Manu first of all
congratulations I believe this is your
first victory at the US chess
championships uh how do you feel right
now is thank you I'm feeling this is
this was a great game he this all this
line up to like uh Bishop A4 this was
all preparation like I think whatever he
found was best chance for black but even
after that it's kind of a difficult
ending for him to hold uh sorry just to
reiterate that you knew Bishop to A4 as
the best move in this particular
variation you actually looked at this
before yes yes I spent a little bit of
time in the opening just to make sure I
don't like mix anything up but yeah I
knew all the stuff I have to say this is
uh this was a very convin vincing
Victory congratulations did you feel at
any point that you are letting him get
back into the game or you felt in
control at all
times I felt like whatever I did was
good but there was this one very
critical moment after Bishop E5 like
okay Bishop D4 seems like best chance
yes uh he played Rook ad d8 and now I
was deciding I spent like half an hour
here deciding between Bishop takes E5
and Rook E3 mhm mhm and why because
another idea was considering was like
Bishop takes D takes E5 Rook takes d8
Rook takes d eight Rook
E3 yes I wasn't like I thought maybe
here black can go B5 and things like I
should be I should still be much better
I wasn't sure whether this was entirely
winning like ab6 cb6 and okay like white
is much better but no you're very right
about that right now black has some
chances for sure and you exchange a lot
of Pawns there's not that many
weaknesses definitely the better
alternative the one that you chose Rook
to
E3 yeah Rook E3 I think uh C5 is a
mistake like I was very happy to see C5
like even if I don't have Rook F3 like
if I go Bishop takes E5 and Rook takes
d8 directly like even that position is
much better version of going Bishop
takes E5 Rook d8 first because here I
kind of gain a Tempo
yeah but the other thing was after Rook
E3 I felt like he had two he had like
basically he can also go Bishop
F4 I wasn't sure like how good it was
but I felt like M should still be much
better because like okay Bishop F4 I had
some ideas like Rook C3 or Rook f I
think like Rook C3 C5 Bishop
E3 like maybe it's of course I still
need to calculate a a lot of things here
but this seemed good for white there was
just one very funny position like here
if I go Rook B3 I don't think it works
but like Rook B3 Knight take C2 Bishop
C3 he has be it apologies uh let me just
catch up with you Mishra I apologize
um uh sorry I'm going to bring you up on
my
board and uh this was the moment moment
uh tell me again this moment Rook E3
yes yes I think uh after Rook E3 there
was a very funny variation that if he
goes Bishop F4 directly instead of C5
yep Bishop F4 uh like let's say yeah
Bishop F4 like Rook of course it feels
very strange to go Bishop E5 then Bishop
four back but now if I say if I go Rook
B3
yep uh Knight takes C2
yeah and now like Bishop C3 was one of
my ideas but now I think after Black
Goes Rook B8 it's kind of Rook V8 I
really I think white just still somehow
be working this but this is very very
funny position it's just Rook on B3
stuck Vish on A4 is stuck very amusing
on C3 can't move yeah I mean the Knight
on C2 is trapped but so are your
pieces that that that that's actually
crazy um Misha it was one of the most
stunning things about this position and
again I think you played a virtually FL
Flawless game and really great
congratulations it's an engine rine it's
an engine line Mishra but it's hard to
believe that in this position the engine
had proposed for you Bishop takes Pawn
takes F4 and it just happens by chance
that this bishop on A4 controls the E8
Square so that after a variation like
takes takes it ends up perfectly timed
and the ewn just actually waltzes up the
board did this ever cross your
mind yeah four unfortunately I didn't
see no I'm just wondering if black goes
if Black Goes Knight C6 uh do I go into
the Rook ending or how do I no you just
go
E6 E6 let's say Knight C6 Rook D1 and
Rook E8 now E7 yes that's the variation
King G8 you have like Bishop B3 or what
is the bishop B3 yes E7 King h8 and
Bishop d
E5 ah amazing Bishop yes wow that's
amazing geometry KN kn7 Rook e won this
exactly you this would have been much a
much better game I if I had
found no we would have checked you for
Security even worse than than we do
already that's there but okay it would
be nicer to play like this it was
amazing uh line it it was engine
generated and I I love the way you
played you you kept control throughout
and uh our congratulations Mishra uh 14
years young you're coming in here I know
you're very very ambitious uh but it's
great to have a good start
too abman I have a question so I know
that when you were playing the US uh
Juniors you're really looking forward to
win the event to qualify for this US
championships now you accomplish that
but how do you change your mindset so
you don't see this as a destination to
qualify but actually to uh to succeed in
in this
tournament yeah playing this tournament
in itself is like a dream come true like
what the world's best players Fabiano
Dominguez uh leavon ronian like these
guys are the top of the top of the top
and playing against them is it's it's
one of the best opportunities in
classical yeah here my my strategy is
that okay if it's a draw it's a draw I
don't really care too much about draws
but I'll try my best and we'll see what
happens I've had some similar opposition
in uh one tournament in Sweden I think
the name was T Sigman I like it was
filled with GES Sidler Arjun arayi
grandelius and Etc and I managed to
almost TI for first there so I'm hoping
to play up to the same standard well
okay let's I'll play my best and we'll
see what happens wow well
congratulations and good luck in the
rest of the
tournament thank you indeed uh our uh
best uh luck for Wow U Flawless what a
game what a preparation I mean Bishop A4
you know you're winning and then just
figuring out how to how to close on that
Advantage wow very well done 14 years or
actually no I like the way he said uh to
play with the best of the best
Fabiano uh lanir and leavon and Wes all
those guys uh it's amazing to me this uh
game between lanir and Fabby because I'm
sure if you were to ask Fabby right here
right now what's going on in your mind
saying I'm playing for a win and the
computer sitting there going triple
zeros or something because you've got
this great blockade on the D5 Square
andle zeros it says black is
better okay rub it in rub it in I mean
tell us why now Zer now it zeros okay
the Knight is on A6 right now for a
second it says Queen to E8 0.1 minus 0.1
I don't know why though that's be okay
this is absolutely ridiculous obviously
how did the Knight transfer itself from
C6 to A6
well
you miss Captain
up well thank you for that but why did
he go from C6 but he wasn't doing
anything on there's a couple of reasons
and maybe a couple of ideas behind it
now especially with the bishop Pawn f8
Knight C7 and then for example let's
make some silly move King to h8 Knight
C7 take Queen takes now you have a
threat clear Queen takes G7 is
threat so that's why he brought his
Knight to A6 he's just trying to find a
task for the Knight because after the
move F6 is very difficult to get it back
into play without exchanging it and we
know that once you exchange it if you're
not careful enough and you exchange the
Queens as well that's an immediate draw
right also is A4 sure B6 is also weak
but we're probably going to actually
exchange this um pawns four pawns on the
queen side and that's going to lead to a
draw Queen F7 was played by Dominguez
0 yeah I mean I don't see it going any
other way uh Dominguez in general is
very very solid he understands these
type of positions he still has 3 minutes
and 20 seconds that's a lot of time for
ler with nine moves to go and a
simplistic position more or less there's
not that much material there's no Rooks
that are going to invade via the seventh
rank so I think he has good chances to
score a drawing one oh very good
bringing up the game of Sam seon versus
Hans Neiman because I was curious to see
how much time Sam had left he had left I
beg your pardon he's down to five
minutes versus 15 for Hans I think after
yesterday's experience Hans basically
said to himself look dude you cannot
leave yourself with 5 Seconds anymore I
don't like that Queen B1 I like that
move Rook C5 and he kind of repositioned
this queen I I always think that the
queen should always get the Oscar for
best
supporting actress that the idea is that
the rook in front of the queen is often
much better than the queen in front of
the Rook it's like The Rook goes and uh
attacks something whereas the queen
doesn't but uh over to you Christian
with special guest well we do have
Karissa in the studio with us Karissa
first of all congratulations a big
victory with the white pieces against
the defending Champion uh first of all
take us through the game and how do you
feel after this important
Victory um yeah I felt it was a pretty
clean game overall felt good about my
play um I think from start to finish I
just felt that I was doing pretty well
and I knew that I was probably much
better after I got in U night A5
95 that was the key uh situation but
before that did you expect her to play
the
caroan no the caroan was a total
surprise I was expecting um E5 on move
one and so yeah I think I've been
playing Jennifer since like 2015 or
something probably even earlier for
almost 10 years now and she's never uh
pulled out the Caro against me so I
thought it was surprising but um I think
I handled the surprise pretty well not a
bad surprise because you definitely got
the advantage out of the opening and it
felt like you knew the positions uh
better how to handle the positions how
to open them up with the move C4
following it up with Knight to A5 so a
great game by you you're one of the
players that's coming back from Mexico
where you participated in the world
juniors you actually took the silver
medal in that one now there's always
this debate look you had a lot of time
to prepare during that tournament you
were coming with a luggage of opening
theoretical ideas but also in terms of
your energy levels perhaps you know
they're a little bit sapped how do you
feel right
now yeah I feel pretty good I will say
at the end of world juniors that was
also 11 round
tournament um I was feeling a little
done with chess uh but uh but that's
kind of worn off now and feel good I
feel like it was a bit of a sort of
warmup for this event and yeah I feel
like I kind of got the nerves out of the
way there and so I can show my best
trust now but one question between the
world juniors and the USA championships
you're missing one month of school at
Stanford that's not easy are you still
doing homework in between games what's
what's the plan
there yeah definitely um so I'm missing
the first 3 weeks cu Stanford starts a
bit later than other schools and I've
been sort of keeping up with lectures
and homeworks online and remotely so
seems to be going okay so far but
hopefully I can keep that up challenge
guys any questions uh just our
congratulations uh Carissa keep it up
you've got a lot of games ahead of
you thank you absolutely absolutely and
as we're going to take a a break oh well
Lon
leavon and Jeffrey we thought there was
a little bit pressure but I guess it's a
three-time repetition that uh because
uh je I think Jeffrey was claiming uh
Frank uh the the chief Arbiter was going
to approve and happy birthday leavon
happy
birthday what 40 years young 41 41 years
Young our
congratulations and uh as we take a
break once again we want to leave you
with a special message from the board of
directors the St Louis chess club and
Scholastic Center here it
[Music]
is
yeah um it's amazing what the club has
done for chess in general because I mean
it's already been 15 years and they've
done countless uh national championships
tournaments for junor
helping gr schools and they've just
grown the game so much across the United
States I think if I look at my own
career and I look at American chess in
general we're in a much better place
than we were 15 years ago and so the
contributions have been immense and of
course it's all thanks to Dr J singfield
and Rex
singfield I would say that S luia Club
is like a rock in the ocean of Chess and
we know that it's it's there it is there
it will be there I think it sense a hope
that the the game of chess will always
stay Al flat by the mere fact of its
existence I think it it it sends
positive waves across the
globe the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States we bring the educational benefits
of Chess to thousands of students across
the St Louis area we also promote Chess
at the highest levels hosting all levels
of the US championships as well as
high-profile tournaments that attract
the world's best players become a member
and enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments and so much
more visit St Louis chess club.org to
claim your membership
today the World Chess Hall of Fame
located in the heart of St Louis's
historic Central West End want to know
why chess has intrigued people around
the world for nearly 1,500 years stop by
and learn about the impact of Chess from
our three floors showcasing the art
culture and history of the game the
World Chess Hall of Fame has something
for everyone to enjoy for more
information on current exhibits please
visit World Chess h.org
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85,000 students in both in
school and after school programs we
created the select chess training
program and the junior select chess
training program in order to elevate the
skill level in students across the St
Louis area these students receive
professional training from Grandmaster
verua niobian other programs include
chess cops a partnership with the St
Louis Police Department looking to
improve relationships between atrisk
kids and police officers in the St Louis
area with over 600 students playing
chess over the board since
2019 the St Louis chess club has also
created a chess merit badge for the
scouts BSA quickly becoming one of the
most popular badges with more than
250,000 Scouts earning the badge since
2011 students of chess can also pick up
a copy of read and WR chess thanks to
Club co-founder Dr jeie Karen sinkfield
anyone can learn how to understand chess
notation in no time we view chess as a
valuable educational tool learn more
about our Scholastic programming by
visiting St Louis chess club.org
[Music]
education St Louis the chess capital of
the United States boasts the world class
St Louis chess club and the World Chess
Hall of Fame it also plays host to an
award-winning dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online for chess
merchandise autograph Collectibles chess
campus souvenirs and much much more from
quirky greeting cards to luxury chess
sets there is something for everyone at
Q Boutique and all purchases go right to
benefiting new exhibitions and programs
at the World Chess Hall of Fame
dedicated to exploring chess and its
immense impact on art and culture
located on the first floor of the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy a shopping
experience like no other and become
everyone's favorite Gift Giver if you
can shop in store make sure to check out
houti stl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to
enjoy the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States and is among the best in the
world thanks to co-founders Dr jeie
Karen singfield and Rex sinkfield the St
Louis chess club is a nonprofit
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess locally and
internationally we bring the educational
benefits of Chess to thousands of
students across the St Louis area
promoting cognitive development critical
thinking concentration and analytical
skills the St Louis chess club welcomes
chess lovers of any age and skill level
to come and enjoy the game of chess we
also promote Chess at the High highest
levels hosting all levels of the US
championships and the American Cup as
well as high-profile tournaments that
attract the world's best players
including the prestigious sinkfield cup
Karen's cup and many more all
tournaments can be streamed via our
YouTube and twitch channels that also
include over 2,000 chess lectures for
anyone to enjoy become a member and
enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments merchandise
discount and so much more visit St Louis
chess club.org to claim your membership
[Music]
today hello everyone and welcome back to
our coverage of the 2023 national
championships we have a few results in
the record books Kate do
the oh I'm going to hold off on the
updates but Mishra what a game wonderful
and Carissa yep uh some of our youngest
competitors in the tournament winning
their respective games and for Karissa
that was a big victory over Jennifer Yu
the defending Champion yeah and as she
said it was a very smooth game right she
never felt uh in any danger she was
slowly getting more and more advantage
and then it was just winning exactly and
this one looks like a draw is going to
be agreed just a few seconds as the
players have been going
back uh together Fabby and lanir Bishop
T Bishop takes G7 that's a funny move
okay just a second now I have to pull it
up on the board and see what they've
been
doing Bishop takes G7 can't lose you can
none of the players can basically at
this point take all my pawns come on
collect all my Pawns right
D5 yes take that one too then play
something like King G1 would be funny or
King E1 okay so exactly in this moment
and and uh White loses on
time uh would it be a loss A because
black doesn't have winning M mating
material no but you can promote your
Pawn exactly to a KN and mate yourself
so he does have M material it's a loss
if you have material on the board it's a
loss yes but do we see a handshake Hardy
hand clasp and a draw and so we have
four results in the open well yes four
results in the open section with two
games remaining we'll get those Graphics
to you back where's the action we have
to go back to Sean versus Hans because
you were anticipating that Hans is not
going to go down to his last 15 seconds
or 5 seconds but down to his last five
minutes both of the players are in deep
time trouble so I think we have to look
look at that game and see what's
happening in that position because I say
that one is very very intriguing and
it's very tense as well it has been
tense for a very long time Hans had that
opportunity to play King H6 King G7 at
this particular moment after King to H6
Knight back to F4 and he could have
repeated the position with a move King
to G7 he did not he chose to fight with
a move F5 and this is where we stand
right now night to B3 was the last move
Hans falling under 5 minutes for minutes
45 seconds this is going to get tense
guys absolutely uh last move was Knight
on A5 back to B3 a bit of a surprise I
thought he was heading for C6 why didn't
he go to C6 Christian well let's take a
look if you do go to C6 then I go C8
right but where is the Knight going to
follow up after C6 the problem is the
desirable Knight takes B4 I get trapped
unfortunately Rook takes C4 followed by
Rook to D4 is a big problem oops Yeah
you lose a piece basically uh fair and
uh just leaving the Knight on C6 for
example and playing a move I you know I
want to play a few moves in a row Queen
C2 and Rook C1 right but my Pawn is
coming to A5 also potentially if you go
Queen to C2 I have a feeling B3 I'm I'm
walking right into B3 B3 Bishop takes B2
or Rook to C7 you don't have time to
solidify your position Queen to B8 by
the way has been played so not Knight C6
Knight to B3 which in fact is the better
move because to be honest the Knight
stands much better on C5 than on C6
right on C5 you have targets you can go
here you can um go back to D3 right also
D3 in typ
position3 uh anybody who s uh who has I
was about to say studied but it came out
suffered the games of ol
Anderson ol Anderson played the Catalan
like a genius put his Knight on D3 in
these endings and won numerous endings
against against the dark squared Bishop
so Knight on D3 would be ideal Knight
went back to A5 A5 with three minutes on
the clock offering some sort of a draw
once again Queen to B6 Knight B3 Queen
to B8 Knight to A5 another opportunity
for Hans to get a draw I do believe
we're finally ready apologies Kate uh
let's start uh the results thus far yeah
let's see the updated results for round
two we have one result winning Karis won
again against Jennifer Yu and we have a
draw atusa kashian against ruang yangang
that was a very interesting game right
ruang yangang got upon PA but apparently
it was not enough to translate it to a
win Jennifer you are defending Champion
crashes to defeat an in the open section
and in the open section we have a lot of
results yes carolana Drew Dominguez SCH
Drew saw Mishra won a very important
game and very cool game against tank and
Aron Drew J absolutely and what do we
have we do have a let's let's go back to
the hands because I think handshake is
coming in that one Queen to B6 was
played let's
see let's see whether I was expecting a
bird's eye view of the players and I saw
I saw Christian I thought wait a minute
was played we have to uh see whether
we're see a handshake or not big moment
right now because Queen to B8 is an
invitation but maybe you can shy away
from that maybe you can try something
else H is definitely thinking about
it the options other than Queen B8 uh
Christian you can do a lot of things you
can go A5 yes why not A5 A5 Bishop to E5
is a move as well there's a lot of
options it feels to me that this is a
position where you'd love to be able to
play the move F5 F4 and compromise the
structure but you need to play Bishop E5
that's right as a preparatory move for
that I mean queen let's let's wait and
see because Queen to B
Sam can in fact stop the clock at that
point that would be a third time
repetition 95 yes gotch and afterwards
maybe we can look this continues he
continues the fight I mean the game
flares a new and uh why what does this
move King H opens up the G file opens up
the G file and you were mentioning this
idea of f4 at the right moment not right
now because F4 is so controlled at this
particular moment but at the right
moment once you open up the G file
obviously Rook to G8 is going to come
with a bigger impact right in the
position and you know also it's a move
to pass time it's one of those
maneuvering positions right well is it
because I'm looking at the position
Christian and I'm uh I'm going to bring
it up on my board as well here because
this is a this is actually a very
crucial moment and I think uh an
opportunity Maybe I'm Wrong uh for Sam
can I play the move now KN F4 it's this
Knight on G2 did its Duty whenever it
was there but in this particular case
I'm really I I really do want to capture
this Pawn on H so I probably have to
take that off the board okay Knight
takes F4 now surprising for me I
actually want to sacrifice a pawn before
is on the board takes F4 and I kind of
like what I'm seeing here for white
because listening to you Rook takes b4s
on tap by by the way if you do take the
pawn on B2 don't forget I could sneak in
a queen G5 so maybe I play A5 to just
defend that pawn and that was what
Christian was telling me that I should
be transferring my oh no not not Rook D4
again I think this is the second time
see if I could transfer I'm dreaming of
transferring the Knight to D3 once the
Knight gets just play along for argument
sake so you can see it visually once the
Knight gets to D3 I've actually actually
cut the action and my action is what
it's all about so sorry uh after A5 I
actually have to pause here for a moment
and think uh do I want to play Rook
C1 maybe Rook C5 also it's a question
maybe E4 o maybe E4 yes yes I can warm
up to that move because again good move
yeah isn't white starting to be be
better that's what I'm thinking thinking
the move Knight
F4 uh gave white an opportunity didn't
have until we saw the move King H7 yes
King H7 opened up that window and Sam
said okay and that's why he was playing
Queen to B8 so that you don't have this
F4 that's exactly right that that was
why um and Hans by the way maybe is ruul
of that mist W because he stopped down
to his last two minutes right now not
only caught up with Sam on the but pass
him Knight F4 and he still has six moves
no five moves to make six moves six
moves for uh for Hans five for uh Sam
right now so still plenty of moves to go
and this is not an easy position this is
one of those positions in which you make
a mistake you lose on the spot I mean
the position opens up with E4 you can
get checkmated so quickly right exactly
especially without the Knight on G6
that's the key situation right now right
uh by the way what is he thinking about
is he thinking about Knight E5 maybe
Knight E5 would be a loss of a pawn
Knight I'll clip that pawn with
happiness and he did it
wow wait wait what he did it he's
allowing he's sacrificing PA Knight
takes H5 Bishop h8 Christian bringing it
up on throwing the gauntlet right now I
mean Knight H5 is good move yes Bishop
to E7 let's continue Knight takes H5
Bishop to E7 not Bishop E8 Bishop E7
Bishop to E7 by the
way he's not even considering taking
that one surprise after another true
that Rook C5 he didn't take much time I
mean Knight E5 took two and a half three
and a half minutes Rook C5 I mean
there's no rush right white can
recapture the pawn later oh I meant in
terms of the speed of the move the the
the the clocks uh are ticking but what
do he do now after Rook C5 oh my
goodness I have to say I'm starting to
like Sam's position more and more much
more yes because I don't see the
compensation I mean I understand okay
maybe Knight to G4 right okay I'm
starting to see some ideas so Knight to
G4 what do you do now you take right I
you know I I loveed the E4 idea of of
Kate and I loved it when my queen was on
F4 and I I think I love it with my Rook
he's going for it isn't he Rook on the
fifth round rank as well what do you
think of them apples Kate that looks
nice by the way Hans is down 1 minute 41
seconds to be
B7 what what is going on uh excuse me
Knight takes H5 what is that maybe some
Bishop take H4 no no no no B your knight
on is hanging too wow he's guarding the
E4 Square to to take away any
opportunity of uh E4 but Knight takes
Bishop h8 no choice on that one but it
feels like the position is starting to
collapse maybe Queen G5 well thank you
for that Queen G5 with the idea of
Knight F6 well he's played Bishop h8
quickly this time Bush I'll take
that don't don't don't don't ask me
twice exactly don't tempt me too often I
will capture the pawn queen G5 anything
else here there could be simplification
like Rook takes E5 and followed by
Knight C5 but there's no reason to do
that right no on the contrary I love
that I love the Knight on B3 is
bothering me terribly and if I could
trade off the Knight on B3 for the
Knight on E5 I like it but I like the
queen G5 Knight F6 threat and kind of
getting the dark score B KN G5 que G5
there's a problem because of Rook to D1
that's why he played Queen B7 so that he
has all these Rook F1 Queen to H1 ideas
oh that's smart nasty
nasty but in that case let's take a look
at what you just uh shoed away uh Rook
takes E5 Bishop takes E5 Knight C5 let's
say you just centralize your queen let's
let's be fun about it takes takes now
the move Queen G5 is not going to be hit
by Rook D1 and you've traded off I think
this Knight which was doing nothing for
uh something here and now that the
question is can I launch an attack it's
I mean you have a knight there with the
queen not too many pieces and the bishop
can capture on B2 well okay let's say I
go Knight F4 okay I've always I've
longed for the opportunity to play
Knight to D3 all right Queen D2 Queen D2
thank you for oh no don't tell me you're
going to take the pawn on E2
no yeah I mean I'm Dreaming this is the
dream three more moves until they make
the time control okay and they're both
well Sam right now under your queen D2
was a good move by the way uh Rook day
C5 it's not the correct move it's what
is the correct it's not good knight F4
just Knight F4 just just go back just
bring it back okay yeah that transition
is not good but it's very tempting
because you're a pawn up and you're uh
exchanging some pieces so it's very very
tempting well I'm not exchanging seconds
for Sam right now what I am exchanging
is a
passive Knight on B3 that was the dream
okay so Knight F4 20 seconds No 7
Seconds right now you have to make a
move Sam Queen to C2 Queen C2 I think
guys we have a next result Sam Shanklin
Drew Ray Robson that was The Rook ending
Sam shankin promoting his book on The
Rook endings had two Rook endings to
start uh these his 2023 campaign Queen
to C2 okay he setting up for something
on that
diagonal you move the Knight to G4 by
the way I have ideas of Rook takes F5 so
you cannot get aggressive with the
Knight on coming to G4 anymore that's a
nice uh tactical trick there
absolutely because a moment ago we were
also getting you looking at ideas of E2
E4 that was why the move Queen on B7 I
don't know why Queen C2 took Sam such a
long uh he was looking at Rook take C5
I'm sure he for sure yeah he was trying
to calculate and assess that position he
made the right decision Queen to C2 is a
good move by the way um if it if you
just leave me to my brothers and let me
play moves like Rook C1 then the idea of
Knight C5 Knight A5 Knight C6 Knight F4
all lots of tempting good good I think H
is in a very difficult position now
because not to find a good move here for
black with 20 seconds on the clock yes
exactly still three moves to go for
Hans H Hans down to your last 10 seconds
you have to make a move maybe Queen we
saw this
yesterday Rook G8 so calmly played also
just Rook G8 just uh saying I moved my
king to H7 for a reason I wanted the
open G file what does that move
accomplished though I think you just
have to make a move you yes you just
have to make sometimes any move is
better than a no move here again it's
like one of those things I've got two
passive pieces the Knight on B3 The Rook
on F1 I find myself drawn to anything
that allows me to trade off my passive
pieces nope Knight back to F4 best move
by uh I I I I I smuggled the pawn it was
uh rubbery uh daylight robbery uh Knight
H5 Knight F4 seems like Bishop F6 is the
most natural move right now at you're
creating drop back to G2 right yeah
Bishop I maybe then will be time to make
the Knight A5 move no he's going Knight
G4 wait a minute whoa whoa whoa Rook
takes F5 Knight just with one second on
the clock whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa Rook
takes F5 youve pointed this out oh my
goodness Knight G Knight G4 was a big
blunder by the way Rook takes F5 was
finishing the game on the spot and it
well
it Knight G6 is bad but it's not as bad
but Knight G4 on the board no he did
play Knight G6 I'm sorry he took it back
he took it back he was going to go with
one second oh my goodness and that's the
final move for Sam and the final move
immediately came for H I think my board
registered
194 it did he did he didn't release the
piece though it's the second time he
does this WOW even but this time he did
it in the good way right he changed he
switched to the better move well I mean
he was losing badly after Knight G4 now
he's just losing slowly right after
Knight to G6 not looking good I think
it's time to look at the women's section
right yes we were mized
apologies uh but through the magic of
Television we get to see a replay of
what we just witnessed because the move
Knight G4 as poting out look at the
clock by the way by Christian 5 Seconds
right there Rook takes F5 as a killer
and relas inct did he release inct told
him something's wrong 3 seconds two g go
wow he pressed his clock with a second
on his clock it was interesting Sam was
looking at it look at Sam was looking at
it
happening but Christian you have a
special guest we do have
lener with us after that crazy finish to
that time scramble in that game but
lener you had a difficult game today
with the black piece against uh a player
that you know oh so well Fabiano caruana
and you defended very accurately how are
you feeling about your performance in
this
game yeah I mean um it's it was a tough
game um I play this idea with B5 in the
opening which is kind of unusual um
taking the game from
typical Italian positions I think more
to Spanish positions more like a marshal
or or Bishop C5 and um I thought Bishop
B6 was uh was precise but I'm not sure
because I'm
I'm stopping I mean not really stopping
but the the idea is always to meet
Bishop B5 with Knight A7 but then after
Knight C4 I I spend uh my my usual 40
minute uh think uh because I didn't
understand
exactly how I should proceed there are
many lines but I didn't see anything
that um that I liked uh um so much for
example um and one of the things that we
were struggling with was all these
changes in Pawn structures were you
experiencing the same uh the same
troubles yeah of course uh so many
different uh structures and a bit
unusual structures like for example
example I could get this Knight B5 ab
and then Knight takes B6 CB with the
with the B Pawn With The Pawn on B4 and
the pawn on B2 or without the
pawns uh yeah so um I can allow white to
play C4 and then I can also take on C3
and go for this position which which is
what I finally decided but um but yeah I
was I was trying to to see if uh if
there is U any other interest for
example there was p takes F2 also
interesting move King takes and then C6
but then yeah instead of bc3
mhm Bishop takes F2 here King takes F2
F2 C6 C6 yeah but then there is Knight
takes D6 I thought it seems like C takes
B4 gives white a decisive
Advantage CB
AB Knight takes no I mean ab4 ah a takes
B4 then maybe Knight takes uh B6 no no
no I mean instead of instead of
cb5 a takes before here yes Bishop to E3
but then Knight takes D6 probably Bishop
to E3 Bishop E3 oh yeah CB AB yes and he
lose yeah I had I had also similar idea
to play uh also after BC BC Bishop C5
with the idea to play
C6 um BC uh BC Bishop B5 yeah yeah
Bishop no I thought Bishop C5 um in this
position Knight takes A5 and C6 mhm uh
Knight takes
A6 Knight takes Bishop
takes Bishop takes takes F2 and King
takes F2 Queen B6 and I thought if
Bishop E3 Queen C6 there is some
compensation but yeah of course Knight
D4 here wins yeah Knight D4 if you take
I take your Rook so so yeah I think I
played uh I played more or less normal
and it should be slightly worse um but
then uh yeah I was expecting more AB uh
to be honest instead of CB and he played
CB very quickly uh tell us about differ
I this
position between ab and C basically I
didn't I didn't really consider CB much
I thought it's it's leads to a
symmetrical structure and black should
be more or less fine although it's also
worse but I was more conc concern about
AB because then his Pawn structure is
very solid and um uh in the long term I
could I could have some some issues with
these pawns on B6 and D6 and so at some
point you go Bishop A3 maybe Rook a C1
and then D4
yeah yeah so I thought I would play
Knight D7 on F5 but it still should be
should be better for white here I think
yeah yeah no you were right in your so
yeah after after CB after CB I was I was
uh a bit surprised and then I thought
yeah it's also worse but then when I
found this D5 I was happy because at
least uh I mean I'm I'm down upon but
then my play is it's uh much easier
somehow Y and you set up a beautiful
blockade it was quite funny we were
looking at this position with the
engines and at some point after this
move Queen G3 it was actually giving you
the advantage after this move Rook to E6
uh with a pawn down did you ever think
that in this position you could
potentially be
better yeah I mean uh black is so solid
now with the Knight on D5 and this
Knight on C6 it's it's a bit a bit funny
there it has no no much prospects so I I
did see like if I could take the E file
somehow someday I could be even better
but um I was so short on time that I
decided to play uh my moves uh quickly I
I saw an natural move and I just played
it I didn't bother to to look for
Alternatives at this point well L you're
still a very good and positive result
for you with the black piece drawing
against the defending Champion
congratulations go get your energy guys
any questions for uh just great defense
lanir I keep it up
absolutely uh lots of games uh uh in the
ladies section that might end decisively
I want to quickly draw our attention to
the game of asria for a moment against
beum asria did lose the first round
right she lost against this last move by
beum is a real wow that that is a
smashing move Bishop takes as she's beum
is setting up a check and a very uh
clear and potential Checkmate coming up
with Bishop uh G3 but if you capture
well that walks into a G5 check and uh
there goes an exchange Bishop takes H4
that looks like a winner oh that's and
beum is going to be joining and we did
see a move by Bish G7 I believe Bishop
G7 just give
it giving you know that pawn on B2 is so
dangerous we G to have some kind of
discovered attack right Bishop G3 and
then Bishop E5 game over right Bishop G
well King but then I go with the King on
H6 right that is hilarious the king
somehow you manag to
keep material that there's still some
work to
that is great oh actually Bishop F4 Rook
b77 I saw the same thing I think at
about just the same time although I
guess I will continue
my my my journey to the eighth rank my
life I don't I don't think you get
promoted when you get to be a rank do
you I mean did they change the rules so
do we play Rook D2 now just to kind of
change how you want to approach the game
yeah change of strategy that should be a
winner uh I'm a little bit surprised
frankly after Bishop G7 we don't have
something more decisive the funny part
is that King D7 is the best right in
order to set up some check ba uh King E6
and Bishop G5 that's exactly but I mean
black is what two pawns no only one Pawn
wow it feels like black is more pawns up
it's because of the effect of this B2
Pawn right it's such a powerful impulse
uh I just wanted to check in on Alice
Lee against tatv Alis has been
struggling in a much much inferior
ending more or less since the middle
game still that's the case but at least
to her credit somehow she's managed to
well an active Rook kind of an active
Bishop she's making it difficult for tat
I mean uh definitely white still for
Choice uh it's not aan just making it
more difficult again you're still
lacking counterplay right you got to H1
you got everything you wanted and I
still have that Rook on the third rank
trending beautifully right yeah D3 your
Rook on C6 is still just guarding my
expansion on the queen side and at some
point that expansion is coming you know
sure B4 that's why your rookies on C6
because if you manage to get B4 and King
B3
that's you can resign exactly but I can
go something like King A3 King A4 tried
to bring my king out yeah a lot of
nursing uh in that game and the in the
matchup between Talia and
Arena uh the dark squares uh the bishop
did manage to get itself to F6 but with
the queen gone Arena's King is far safer
than uh normal and there's an extra
peski over here so arena for choice but
will we be maybe able to capture that
pal because after some Rook D4 I mean I
don't have a E6 I thought but maybe
that's too too ambitious
yeah because you do have I have to be
careful about my back back rank ma again
right yeah something like this and on my
next move I can take uh so yes I agree
you don't play uh E6 but you're saying
you might try to round up Upon This Way
Rook A1 let's take a look
um okay well I'll I'll go with the theme
of the moment which seems to be back
rank
Maids so I will go H3
okay and now at some point it's time
right I have to go Knight C3 and Rook D2
I know Rook A8 sorry I've got to go Rook
A8 excuse me now in case of H3 yeah MH
and by the way we do have Rook D4 on the
board as where uh the players are
catching up with
us at some point you are going to play
E6 yeah I'm even wondering if I need a
rook B1 move maybe I prefer to play H3
immediately so I can threaten the start
with some E6 so we do have this yeah
this move E6 is
really yeah concerning you also have to
be careful right because E6 I have ideas
of Rook F4 and you might actually lose
that pawn right so you have to time it
very well okay so in that case let me
play Knight C3 but now I can play E6 and
grab the Knight because there's another
grab the Knight yes you're absolutely
right you can grab the oh darn it
okay if I fall for a tactic after I'm
trying to put my knight on a light
Square uh Knight D5 no but I kind of
liked your idea your initial one with
Rook
C4 and Knight D4 right yes here I can go
King H2 by the
way and then I put my knight on E6 and
then E6 oh E6
yeah I put my uh sorry uh I right here
after
H3 Rook C4 is another way of getting
nicely to the E6 squ Knight to D4 to B1
right
uhhuh yeah again it's a timing uh issue
I have here uh it's a problem it it it
it's Advantage Arena we just don't know
how big an advantage let's just one more
sorry sorry can we just What if after H3
can I play
Knight
D6 just to transfer the Knight to E4 so
I
can take that bishop and maybe get I'm
trying to make a draw as white so Rook
B1 Rook
B1 yeah so I'm wel I'm welcoming Knight
E4 but I I get to play Rook takes D4 uh
Nasi let's just uh jump in uh cuz she
has been a pawn down against Anna
zatonski from the opening and Anna kept
her extra pawn and by the way the
structure of white on the on the um King
side has been compromised as well but we
do see the active Bishop on e4 right the
light Square Bishop is kind of pretty
nice not allowing some Bishop C6 no
because maybe Queen C5 there boy my
arrows uh Trust Me by round
11 my arrows are going to be pristine
and by the way by round
two be did play the move King D7 in that
position she did which finishes the game
more she she's really cruising in that
game
um now having said this this bishop on
on D7 I mean every one of Anna pawns are
on light squares it is a very uh
compromised Bishop I want to say you
know I'm curious because I wanted to
play maybe bishop C C8 and B7 but I
always worried there about Queen A7
right another pin that is very powerful
how funny is that so Bishop C6 Queen C5
is an awkward pin and then what you're
saying is that you want to challenge
this bishop so challenging it in another
way uh This Way allows a different type
of a pin that is that is funny by so
what if I start with King d8 King C8
King B8 and then the idea of trading the
light Square Bishop okay now a question
for you is did you want to include H5 or
not because I didn't know if while
you're going on a sojourn I might go as
well but I have Queen d8 here yes you do
I will boldly go wow okay to G7 where
you will not Checkmate me but I may be
like four ponds down by the time I get
to safety but the king is in
yeah in the heart of the position and
then he will want to try to maybe give
Perpetual check precisely Queen C5 and
I'm hoping I could if I get out if if
Nasi gets out of this game after being
upon down with a Perpetual check uh
right now she would take it and the
question is is this winning or not and
what a big how big an advantage is it
that one was just plus one just plus one
right just plus one it does seem like
it's some sort of a blockade right it
feels like there's a lot of work here
right right and even if you create some
sort of a past Pawn in the meantime I'm
going to be able to try to harass your
King right so still a lot of work to be
done by both players but Nazi has a good
chance to remain uh oncap by the way I
like the H5 move there just to not allow
the to exactly I was asking you about
that uh uh beum I actually did a
commentary on one of the classics with
uh uh beum and it was really a great
deal of fun boy was she feisty
boy I tell you I tell you you you you've
got quite some students I
mean I've spent four years with her I
know exactly how she is yes yes she's
feisty but King D7 and uh she's just to
move away from
um setting up the Checkmate and to be
honest if you go King E5 the problem is
that I'm blocking you the other Escape
Route I go Rook to F3 and that's it
after King to E5 so if you try to stay
there King to E5 Rook F3 the Checkmate
is still coming it's Brewing there right
that's one Bishop to G3 is another one
that's funny th those pawns those double
pawns control important Square this is
over this is over nice well I think
we're only going to have maybe one
player of steering contention for the
Fisher prize after this round that is
Sam Sean because because he's doing well
well show us against H let's uh maybe uh
take a look at that game and see what's
happening they both reached the time
control right now we see this move um
Rook to C1 Queen to B6 I think we left
it somewhere around this when we left it
for those of you who are joining as late
it was actually uh an amusing moment I
don't know what else to say uh with
about 8 seconds to go Hans firmly
grabbed his Knight placed it on the G4
Square did not release the night
recognized that the move Rook takes F5
is an instant winner kept his hand on
the night brought it back to G6 pressed
his clock with one second no no actually
he moved it back to G back to G4 and
then to G6 and then press his clock with
the second on his but from G4 the Knight
went to G6
in a straight line not how the Knight
usually moves from G4 to G6 but yeah so
here it was and it went from
G4 zap like like a rook a we can add
some point maybe bring that footage back
and see it once again because instantly
viral it it was so good it was so good
uh second game in a row where Hans uh
got down to just m seconds one second
one second not seconds lost it now tell
us why the current position is so
favorable well first of all you're a
pond right you have some sort of counter
chance Brewing on the king side the
problem is once you play the move F4 and
try to open me up this diagonal also
opens up right this line also opens up
and you might be in trouble if the Rook
lands on the Square H5 so in this
position no the Practical approach is to
go E3 right the object objectively best
approach is to go E4 okay but this is a
bit dangerous I don't think he's going
to go for it because after the move F4
you have to find this move E5 otherwise
you're giving black too much counterplay
it does make some sense if you look at
you to play H5 first of all there's H5
right you don't have time to take on G3
because H5 just finishes the game so you
have to get off this pin with the King
probably something like King to H6 and
now I have enough time to defend my
complex of Pawns on this side there's no
more pin if I move my Rook uh to C4 your
Bishop is kind of dead and this position
is uh borderline hopeless but we were
discussing about this moment through the
magic of Television let's take a look at
that particular moment those last few
seconds and this is where Hans reaches
for his KN firmly puts it on G4 with
almost drops it with blee Alan and
changing his mind back Sam was really
ready to pounce on
that at the time one look at look at the
clock wow and Sam was looking at the
clock he's like ah was that move 40 was
that move
40 no Sam is thinking to himself is that
was that time control what the heck just
happened there so funny when you look at
this um footage and just see Sam's like
moving back and forth and just like
following the night exactly exactly he
was ready to write down the move right
Knight G4 he was ready to right down the
move Rook takes F5 he surely saw that
move I mean he had that in the back he
was ready to take that pawn off the
board and win the game by the way I just
have to remind you of one of the one of
the most hilarious moments I've actually
ever witnessed in a US championship
history between these two from last year
where somehow Hans was thinking and Sam
just picks up his opponent's
game and offers him the cross like hes
what you doing that's King right there
show I mean he he picks up his King and
he pulls he pulls the cross out and is
like what are you doing dude you can't
do that you can't can't man handle my
king guys I think just that Ally just
blundered uhoh let's jump to that one
well she does have a losing position but
this might end things very quickly right
accelerate the defeat oh oh yes she did
yes she did so what happened this is
over I think it's time for B5 B4 this
was a move that tatf has been dreaming
about ever since she got a nice majority
on the queen side so your rook's attack
moved your Rook Ellis no I don't want to
move my Rook I want to attack your Rook
okay you want me to move my Rook I'll
move my Rook but I'll also pick up the
bishop in the me now I moved my Rook
what are you going to do about it this
is actually resignation time let's let's
look at that because we're going to
catch the resignation oh boy that
was
that's it that's it skips a be there's
nothing black can do about this yeah
absolutely I have to say great game by
TV I mean kept control throughout kept
control throughout
transitioned precisely into that end
game and yeah she did not have any
troubles
converting very very good game and I
have to say this is yeah there we go
handshake right there nice call
Kino wow
I that was unexpected you think I mean
I'm trying to recall uh when was the
last game that allye lost In classical
she's a very solid player and she's had
a very good year so this was uh this was
a wakeup call has she lost the game at
the junior girls I believe she had one
or two draws only I don't think she lost
the game no that's what I am that's what
I asked about the classical I don't know
how she's doing in the Rapids
tournaments there's so many of those
these days and I want to say this is a
huge victory for T because if I'm not
mistaken in their direct encounters
Alice is dominating Alice has been
winning a lot of games against T and
this is a good bounce back victories
Victory try to equalize the score or at
least get closer to it get some
confidence back exactly our
congratulations to tev good job as uh we
just check in on beum uh for a second uh
the move King D7 ashria
stops for a good reason for a very good
reason very difficult to find what to do
next where the white king is somehow
trapped in King E6 G5 Checkmate is on
beam's agenda you can safely resign
right Talia cantes Arena Crush let's do
it uh again when we left it we just saw
the move Rook to D4 you were we you were
talkinging H3 or Rook e B1 and she went
went for The Rook B1 and here uh arena
is wondering how she's she's going to
take advantage she's going to try to
take advantage of the back rank the fact
that you cannot play Rook takes B4 and
you have to play moves like
H3 uh you don't want to prematurely play
E6 and and leave your Bishop um on pre
yeah I like H3 we are just kind of
making sure we are not going to get
checkmated on the back Rank and we are
preparing E6 because let's say black
plays Rook A4 okay which is a very
logical move you want to now we can go
E6 and here the difference is that after
Rook F4 you can play E7 and there's no
Rook guarding the back rank so that you
end up having to retreat and at least
Rook takes B4 and uh things could go in
White's favor suddenly so don't over
don't be overly ambitious but but uh it
feels like with the extra Pawn Arena
should have some line that she could
press I I just don't see it but there's
not much right I mean you're losing the
B4 pawn and you might be getting the E5
Pawn but you have transition into a
Rooks end game and that's just going to
be three versus two draw easy draw okay
so last Nazi Anna and when we left it
was that extra Pawn H5 by the way by
Anna didn't want to see any uh King
excursions up the board but with the
move Bishop H3 by the way and by the
waying and we see a resignation as wins
loses to beim exactly nice jacket
beim is that a missou of course it is
you're waiting you're waiting for the of
course it is nice it's a nice jacket do
I get a I I mean I will proudly
represent the state of Missouri yeah get
you a personalized one no problem we can
I want the team signature and the silver
though you know I like the the silver no
that's how it goes we have our own the
jacket is like a nice
dark you see the gold black and gold
I'll go with the gold metallic yeah
we'll get you one no wor get by the way
this is second loss for ashita so very
difficult start for the tournament wow
in all of these national championships
because they very very strong somebody
is going to take less place it's just
the way it is uh but you don't know who
so the start is so important because you
don't want to be the one with a Target
on your back if you start with two
losses everybody says uhuh that's where
got to go and so you don't want that as
a start any bad starts in the US
championships that's why U mishra's
Victory too it's the other side of the
coin your confidence sores you didn't
every win is extremely important we see
a lot of draws so if you manage to make
a win it's it's very it's really a big
deal should we go back to our leader in
the open section and let's do it and uh
the Bobby Fisher
prize none of uh the moves that we were
prescribing E4 or E3 he played the move
Rook to D1 okay let me just refresh my
board I apologize now Hans has the
opportunity to equalize the score in
terms of Pawns by taking on B2 Rook
takes C6 Rook C1 Queen C7 and here we
were talking about the move E4 yes I
thought he's going to go follow by E5 E3
is a very practical decision controlling
right yeah you just say okay your turn
make something maybe A5 is a bit
ambitious but okay he instead played a
move we really didn't consider Rook D1
which did allow the trade and yes there
goes H says I like pawns Bishop B2 equal
pawns now so can we can we do something
like E4 and try to get the queen super
fast on
H5 okay let's see if I take that where's
the M very aggressive let take let's see
wow yes I've spent a lot of time with
you
yes let's take it he says uh gleefully
I've spent too much time okay shall we
shall we shall we try to combine some
ideas here okay yes yes G G7 and uh
let's just interrupt uh our analysis of
this game as we go to Studio with tatev
who just won her game tatv first of all
congratulations a big victory for you
against a very unpleasant opponent tell
us about your initial feelings right
now oh definitely I feel very happy and
yeah she has been a problematic opponent
for me I lost two games to her in the
American Cup last year uh but of course
I'm very happy about this result and
she's a very good player so I'm
definitely feeling really good and it
felt quite smooth from our perspective
you definitely kept control and your uh
timing was very good as well you play
that move G4 kind of forcing her to go
for this queen trade at what point did
you feel like you're fully in control of
the
game oh when she went D5 at the end I me
I don't know what happened at the end
because like the whole time I was
thinking just don't lose control of the
position your upper Pawn your her
position is completely ATT trous you
should be winning but then somehow her
Rook got to H1 her Bishop got to F4 and
I just felt like maybe I lost control a
bit but um I mean I didn't really have
time to really think about it too much
what how did happen but I think in even
in the final position if she doesn't
blunder I think her Rook on H1 is
actually quite misplaced and I can think
about sacking on F4 or I can after I
went before before if she moves her Rook
back I thought I can just start pushing
my pawns and I think here it should be
maybe B5 even or A4 I don't know which
way I want to yeah no that that was I
think here already should be
straightforward yeah yeah did you feel
like she lost patience towards the end
she didn't like defending this
unpleasant positions this lost position
in
fact
um yeah probably I mean things really
went bad for her from the opening I
think after Bishop F5 immediately I got
a huge initiative
and um I think the end game okay I know
the end game has to be very good for me
I think is supposed to take on F3 as far
as I remember but here my initiative I
think is very good because um
attempting to put something okay this
looks scary I think because I have the G
file but I don't know how realistic my
attack is but what we got in the
position I think is just supposed to be
very good for me again your timing was
very well this G4 move followed by
Knight to B3 I think this was an
important move as well just to ask
questions where is your queen going what
if she goes Queen to A4 and she tries to
keep the Queens on the board what was
your plan this I
think I think her Knight is getting
trapped here somehow I mean she's losing
something here F3 yeah yeah F3 I think I
had something even better she goes
Knight G5 maybe you can even take H4
okay here I can H4 I don't have H yes F4
I think is no no this is very bad yeah
F4 and then I just G5 F5 I just push my
pawns I think with the queen on A4 my
attack will be huge here yeah yeah no
very controlled game congratulations T
guys any questions for winner our
congratulations T keep it
up thank you absolutely nice game by tat
and and smooth right favorite yeah
excuse me bur me and uh Arena and Talia
is still at work as is Nazi oh so Anna
is going for the plan that I was
suggesting moving the king to B8 and
then trying to trade the light Square
Bishop
right makes
sense if we can do that then if we can
trade off the light Square so
imagine for example I just make a move
yeah and we get a a queen
ending so you do
achieve the maximum if you will so the
maximum then you don't want to play
Queen
D5 and allow me here right so if I go
there right now now you have to bring
your king back to E8 can I go Queen B7
right and then back King B8 oh you want
to remain over here on the queen side um
check
A7 check A6 and check
but now I have Queen B6 and yeah queen
queen G1 maybe but is that do you do
anything with that Queen on Oh I thought
I'm very happy to get the queen there
but I don't think you're meting me you
oh I mean there's no question you know
you're you're much much uh for choice
but I have also still got Perpetual
checks and guys I just take this to the
Sam 7an versus H game because it's a
critical moment right now and maybe we
can see how the players are reacting to
this critical moment if he plays Rook to
C8 this is the key move in the position
he did not play E4 by the way after
Bishop takes B2 he went just simply
Queen D7 gift me the pawn on Rook to G7
and now Rook to C8 is is the key move in
the position if he finds allowing Rook
takes G3 check yes yes yes and that's
the difficult part you don't want to
allow Rook H
G3 why I like your E3 so long ago
exactly but the thing is you're not
going for the Checkmate it feels like
you want to go Queen E8 and go Checkmate
on h8 no what you're going for is to
trap the queen what with A5 no kidding
wow and to transition in uh into an end
game a winning end game that running
right so now I go A5 Queen B5 and then
we swap the Queen's a a pawn just runs
okay well that's almost just impossible
to see no but he gave up a pawn so and
he calculated for a very long time by
the way he's down to his last four
minutes what he's down to his last four
minutes he's been thinking about this
position and this Pawn sacrifice for a
very long time so wow maybe he
calculated
it so maybe he calculated it as as Sam
struggles to come up with the move Rook
C8 we also have another special guest in
studio Christian beg him welcome to the
studio big big victory for you with the
black pieces this was not a easy start
to this tournament because you had
double black what was the strategy
yesterday and today and by the way
yesterday you had a great position as
well so things seem to be going your way
how are you feeling right
now hi guys um yeah to double BL it it
was a little bit uh hard hard to prepare
because I didn't know what to expect um
you know most of the players it feels
like prepared new openings and I didn't
get anything that I prepared in two days
so I'm kind of happy I survived with one
and a half points and yeah yesterday I
had some chances but I don't know I
calculated some things wrong I feel like
and missed it unfortunately tell us
about today's game um did she surprise
you in the opening with this exchange Ru
Lopez and uh how did you approach the
ensuing position were you happy with a
dve at that point or were you trying for
more I was trying for more of course
when she took Bishop uh C6 I was like
okay I have two Bishops and uh most
probably I'm going to win the game
somehow uh I just didn't expect I knew
she could play Bishop B5 but of course I
didn't expect Bishop B5 and Bishop C6
from her especially she lost yesterday
so I thought she's going to try to fight
back mhm so I just made some moves so
her strategy her uh let's say peaceful
strategy surprised you a little
bit yeah I mean I was happy about it you
have two Bishops comfortable position
it's not like uh I forgot all these
lines that existed right I just knew
some things I put the pieces and uh
tried to just play the game and I really
like the way you continued your attack
and expansion on both sides H5 but also
A4 B4 and you were putting a lot of
pressure and it was at this moment when
you broke through Bishop to B3 Bishop to
C2 and now there's no way for her to
keep control in the position uh was that
the moment when you felt like finally
you get that decisive
Advantage actually I was mad at Bishop
C2 I knew that I saw something and I
forgot I had five minutes I'm like wait
a sec why am I giving why am I allowing
C4 what I'm going what I'm going to do
now then I I'm like oh Rook A6 idea was
Rook D6 and Rook D4 somehow yes in that
case so I just played Bishop f8 but I
wasn't sure what kind of pos position is
it feels like if uh White is able to put
Bishop B2 and Rook C1 they they're fine
so I wasn't sure uh Rook C Rook instead
ofes how the game ends yeah for example
G4 I got lucky that I have Bishop D1
here
oo that's a nice move Rook takes D1 and
Rook if I was like Tempo down she should
be fine yeah I think because of this
move my position was fine yeah and after
that uh you ended up in style with this
move King to D7 trying to set up the
mating net Beautiful Finish begging
congratulations and nice jacket I think
Yer wants
one I'll fight you for it
B
thank congratul coach can get you one
all right uh our congratulations good
luck in the rest of the tournament thank
you you thank you guys bye bye
um that was nice by the way very uh we
don't have Rook to C8 we have E3 and
queen to
B8 Queen to B8 play Queen to B8 he's
trying to sacrifice he's trying to get
some Rook takes G3 in the position right
now okay but isn't he inviting Rook C8
he played King G2 just to stop the
sacrifice I have a feeling Rook to C8
was met by Rook takes G3 right or maybe
Queen to E5
first queen to E5 first queen to E5 and
there's still no mate that's the thing I
I was telling you about with the queen
on B6 the idea was not to Checkmate the
black king was to actually trap the on
B6 which is kind of ridic the queen yeah
I guess check me the queen right and now
the queen is finally free right mhm so
King to G2 was the move played but I
have to say the last sequence of moves
and especially the time spender 23
minutes for Hans only 3 minutes and 20
seconds for Sam Sean and after a move
such as Bishop to F6 it's not that easy
and finally Hans has equalized in terms
of material materal yes after Bishop
takes B2 so this is a completely
different game right now Hans might be
inching his way closer to being back
into the game but uh go go for it King
G2 Bishop F6 yes I mean again uh to my
way of thinking the queen on D7 very
powerful Rook on
C5 pretty darn good uh I'm you know I
just want to play like E4 expose the
king uh the Knight yeah it's blockading
the pawn on B3 that's uh kind of a
downer right I mean the if the Knight
were on F4 uh should shouldn't I be like
seriously better somehow here let's say
I play Move Rook C7 let's just try to
you know can I take a pawn bishop takes
H4 yes you can yes you can Bishop takes
H4
Knight okay now you probably you're
going to go back right Christian Bishop
F6 looks good yes right now I don't have
Knight takes uh G6 and my B Pawn is
coming be careful yes yes yes all right
let's push the pawn yeah just way you go
right yes I mean you go Rook to B7 so
it's not that easy but Rook B7 Queen E5
yeah this you it's strange I was trying
to rip open the king with moves like
Knight C5 and E4 but it's not that
playing for a win yeah yeah it's not
that easy to
to and uh let's just go back to Arena
Crush so we're expecting a handshake yes
this one is going to be a draw we're
exchanging all the
pawns for arena just don't take on G6
it's a very nice little final trick
don't take on G6 because you get checkm
on back right Rook takes G6 King seven
H3 G3 anything
works and uh
well Arena couldn't come up with
anything better than this Rec Rook
ending that you had mentioned somehow
she doesn't seem to be very happy with
this result perhaps she feels that she
missed a victory along the way well she
she sure was nursing an advantage for a
long time it felt like you know it's
like one of those things you you don't
mind these types of games you know like
okay you didn't win but at least you
were the one who was in control and it
was a two result game most of the way
for Talia with the white pieces I don't
think she will be too pleased okay happy
that made a draw right uh I was
surprised in the game when uh Arena's
dark score Bishop disappeared so that
was a moment when I yeah I wasn't sure
what what's happening in the in the game
if Irena is losing the advantage or not
M but now we can just see just a draw
though will look uh for a three move
repetition uh while we're over here
let's see what Nazi and Anna exactly
with and they did get into that pure
Queen ending that we were talking about
here with uh the extra Pawn for for Anna
I was always thinking that with the King
on G3 I'm vulnerable to these moves of
C3 and then you get to recapture with a
check I am aware of course that the pawn
on B5 is hanging with check that was why
I was wanting to play F3 earlier right
just to avoid that sequence so black is
probably going to play King B6 here
right to defend the pawn and maybe now
is the time to play F3 yes precisely and
it's going can I travel with my king
king
C5
don't don't tell me you're actually no
no well because you have to make a move
right okay check I'll check you I'll ask
you if you would like to enter okay then
I would like to enter okay I can see a m
too uh self mate self mate into oh Queen
C
wow well done Queen C5 and queen D2
that's a self mission accomplished well
done and Anna has played your move King
B6 she says step closer to the self
mate closer yeah it closer naz's
position is really safe really safe the
king guys guys what are we talking about
what queen
D6 Queen D6 don't go there no no no wow
okay that's how you lose that is
self-destruction
right no don't do that and yeah that
would have happened in my game that's
hurtful that that move that's the cold
shower right there boy that's uh Yuri
scholman for those of you who didn't uh
get a chance to join us at the opening
ceremony uh he was telling this
marvelous story was it from trumo yes
trumo the Arctic Circle uh where he saw
something that was absolutely unique in
his experience uh the law laws of
physics were
violated uh Wesley so jumped into the
ocean the Arctic Ocean the Arctic yes
and he jumped out faster than he jumped
in and we do have a handshake let's go
back to Sam
versus Sam is down to his last two
minutes you seen this picture before he
really enjoys uh being low on timed as
uh our tournament leader but Sam is
winning under Pawn right while he's
winning his Pawn back he lost the pawn
on B2 so he's not Queen takes A6 Queen
takes A6 Rook takes G3 I think is hans's
idea just to sacrifice The Rook wow
Queen takes A6 Tak G3 check F takes G3
Queen takes and this is enough play well
I'm also hitting that Knight right
so what are you going to give me well
right now now it's sort of like this
king is really safe so if I do try to
head to the queen side down to his last
minute guys is so maybe Knight
C5 instead of uh Queen a from Queen que
A6 is not good yeah or A5 I think one of
those moves because after Knight C5 I'm
targeting the A6 Pawn but then black may
play B3 maybe I don't know B3 I have
ideas of sacrificing that PA want to get
this idea of Rook takes G I was trying
to trap the queen but the queen has
Escape after Rook takes A6 I think
you're a bad influence on Me Kate how
about oh he played Rook takes A6
challenging Rook takes G3 check good
move because he could have played King
F3 I was challenging channeling my inner
Katrina there with have a question he
after Rook takes A6 Rook takes G3 can I
just make King F1 yes that is legal yes
and now that wins you're in trouble
right I have to move my queen no
connection with the E3 point and now I
recapture the rook and that's it that's
Johnny ball game he played Queen E7 so
he cannot sacrifice and he did play
Queen E7 which by the way
does there is there is a a
peski okay we can play Rook
A8 there
Checkmate well crazy is it Checkmate I
mean I I
you know it's funny it's not Checkmate
but I know what you you were thinking
you know you're you're playing for the
Checkmate right and you it looks like it
should be but 40 seconds though I mean
that's the problem 40 seconds for Sam
Sean right now I mean but Rook A8 is
kind of an easy move is then I can go G4
right yes but I the whole idea was just
to kind of you know like get a that's
fine no Queen D H4 eight is's on the
board yeah and after Rook G4 I think I
play Queen d8 yeah just offer a trade oh
you've got Queen B7 check do you want to
allow that I might take it though who
knows I might actually exchange those
Queens even though I have Queen B7 yeah
no Queen B7 is Queen B7 is the most
annoying move Of All Times Rook A8 on
the board Rook G4 expected can I just
move my king please something like Safe
and Sound king F1 King E2 but then Queen
D6 E2 yes just some I'm I'm just kind of
looking for King safety Rook G4 on the
board and the problem for Sam is that
despite he also has one minute but also
Black's moves at least up to this point
are quite easy right you're threatening
some sort of a checkmate with Queen h8 I
mean they going to get to my king
exactly I have to defend against it
there's one active move Rook G4 and
there's one passive move Rook G6 I'm
going to choose the active one yes King
and he did play King F1 as expected um
after queen f8 queen D1 Queen D6 guys on
the board or not not yet not yet but
we6
equalizes wow equalizes equalizes and I
have a feeling looking at the position
that from a practical perspective and
it's on the board yeah this is much
easier to play right now for uh black to
play Queen D6 and yeah well because the
nice thing is you're protecting G8 and H
h8 squar so so this whole battery of
Queen and Rook are
not very powerful his ambitious play by
not accepting a draw looked very shaky
doubtful to put it mildly yes at what
point at one point in time but right now
it's starting to pay off guys and and
what is the idea after King E2 by the
way maybe just Queen D5 can I can I just
move my knight and move where on D1 on
d2s yeah D Bishop
C3 Bishop
C3 so I really comes passive I really
don't like the look of this for uh for
oh no King E2 Queen
b77 okay I like that move because at
least it does hit the F7 Pawn but it
allows Queen D1 so okay I guess Sam
doesn't care Sam is looking for a
bailout right now he Sam is looking for
a bail looking for a bailout he wants to
make a draw right now
what really yes I don't think he's
looking for a win anymore
wow well first of all actually maybe
this is not that great because I cannot
recapture the Knight but where's the win
if I just take your knight right so
Queen B7 Queen D1 I take the Knight well
Queen F7 Queen F7 Bishop G7 Queen H5
Bishop H6 I only see a Perpetual maybe
there's more but I don't see Queen F7
Bishop Rook A7 or something yeah Rook G7
H I have no better move than check right
I do have Queen D5 coming and that's
that's a very serious Excuse me yes that
that will rock my world that is for
sure I have to be careful by the way how
exactly are you making oh yeah not not
obvious to me
either yeah I don't think we are making
a draw here uh just show me just R G7
and then Queen E8 Queen E8 let's give a
check just but that's the that's not
made that's the same thing you got King
G6 so you have all the time in the world
queen D5 check and I I don't even have a
threat of M one I I mean I have to make
another additional move before I even uh
wow uh something is happening here and
it's happening in time trouble and Sam
lost control absolutely yes he did I
mean he's down to his last 37 seconds
wow you can understand he just made his
last move with 7 seconds on the clock he
lost control fully in this
position huge huge uh turnaround here
because uh where did it go wrong
Christian well uh the last few moves the
sequence Rook takes A6 was the start of
the WR R takes A6 was a good move but a
good move this move Rook to D1 and just
simply giving up the B2 Pawn that's not
a good idea right he had to see this
move Rook to C8 I mean if he sees Rook
C8 brilliant could shower him with a
golden coins right got because A5 is
coming and that's beautiful but he did
not see it and maybe he did see it but
perhaps he doubted himself right at that
moment because look I mean that's a
check you know that's a check and your
knight is are you losing the Knight are
you getting giving a Checkmate you don't
really know right right he doubted
himself and unfortunately right now Hans
is fully back in the game with good
chances to potentially uh have a huge
Swindle and win the game it's always
difficult in chess right when you are
kind of attacking trying to Checkmate
your opponent and suddenly you have to
switch and you are supposed to be
trapping a queen on the other side of
the board yeah no that's incredibly hard
now I looking at hans's body's post I
I'm reading why can't I take your knife
exactly exactly like dude aren't you
leaving your night on Prix that's a good
read let's have another look at this
whole sequence it goes Queen D1 check
King G2 Queen takes B3 and where's the
Perpetual Christian Queen takes F7
F7 we we we we blockade with the
bishop and as you point here5 check is a
nasty
threat yeah Queen H5 check is not great
um Rook to E8 the simple would you say
simple Rook to E8 is the right H has
asked the question if I give a check I I
think if I take the Knight I think he's
taking the Knight I
would uh and you're saying Rook E8 Rook
E8 is the best move are you serious yeah
that's kind of
ridiculous I mean if he if he actually
plays this move to be honest I'm not
even sure what the idea is probably just
take on E6 M but that's kind of crazy
right crazy looking truly Rook E8 I mean
you allow Queen D5 and B3 really I mean
but the thing is when you have Rook on
E6 you can give check on H5 and there is
no Bishop H6 good
point really no excellent point but you
think to yourself you're losing so much
time find just such a quiet move how how
how did you want to meet Queen D5 check
so I guess right King
H2 man Rook E8 is a difficult move to
see I'm I'm looking at F4 here to be uh
that way I take away the H5 square and
some cases I just ah I guess Queen G8 no
no Queen G8 is the idea
and6 okay okay okay so that's the idea
oh good point we have to be careful
right that is
nice gotcha okay that clear some C
that's the idea of Rook to E8 we
understand that clear some cobweb what
if I go Rook
G6 well now we have uh H5 with tempo
right F6 I'll take it take no The Rook
is not on A7 not
no oh but you can go check and then Rook
E7 not that's the nice one I'm kind of
stuck huh wow
remarkable but this is not easy to see
no oh with no with 20 seconds 30 seconds
he's up to 1 minute because he just
played King G2 in a second luckily he
can calculate now right when Hans is
still thinking whether to capture the
Knight or not he has Sam is definitely
looking at Queen takes F7 and what to do
after yes like a Ferrari his engines are
running uh he knows he's got a minute
and he's looking at Queen takes B3 and
do you think he's analyzing Queen F7
Rook E8 ah no no honestly I think right
now in general when you're in this
position you have one minute you're
trying to calculate the more most forced
moves the check everything that happens
with the check your calculator you have
to this is your primary move right here
right but you're kind of running empty
at some point you're like okay check
check and that's it that's it right
because Rook G7 I can always block right
check check and then because E6 is
defended yeah I I have a feeling Sam is
going to find
rookie very likely that well okay but
rookie
eight it took us a while to actually
understand even why why are we playing
we're playing all right and HT took the
Knight Queen Tak the Salient question
okay let's see let's see and now comes
the key moment okay Bishop G7 is force
right yeah can you do something else
Rook G7 Queen H5 that's a mate King H6
doesn't look like the right solution
there must be even though I guess you
calculate R king H6 as well excuse me
just that uh I had played Bishop
G7 all a Tempo I didn't even consider
the move King
H6 but now you again Rook E8 Rook E8
Rook G6 maybe but then I have H King H6
played it play the one move we didn't
even consider he was his main move King
H6 well now
Rook E8 is much more obvious oh I think
Sam's busted what sami's busted right
now after after King H6 that's the only
move to make to keep some sort of
equality in the position is Rook
A5 be serious yes nobody's looking
nobody looks at that move right no of
course not no wait if he finds Rook A5 I
mean you're stopping Queen D5 it has a
point and I want to take on F5 and you
do want to if the bishop were to drop
back just there is by accident a Tempo
he finds it he survives he doesn't such
a hard move to find by the way uh how
does how does Han survive you bail after
Rook A5 you bail out with Bishop Tak G3
that was important to ask because Rook
takes F5 was actually suddenly
frightening and there's some sort of
Perpetual with Queen F6 Queen F7 after
that oh my gosh so Rook A5 with 25
seconds on the clock Rook A5 Bishop
takes G3 your vote he finds it or not I
think he's going to play Rook E8 I can't
I I would never find I'm not looking at
Rook A5 I'm looking at Rook E8 I'm
looking at Rook h8 I'm looking at H5
Rook G8 eight
seconds I don't see how he finds A5 yeah
queen f8 queen f8 that's that's hans's
game right now to win it but then Bishop
G7 because now Bishop G7 is a easy tempo
right right yes yes Bishop G7
and yeah that's that wow that's checks
are over that's an extra piece and my
checks are coming queen D5 is coming
definitely on the agenda B3 is coming
everything is protected right and the
king is safe oh my goodness so Hans is
risky decision not to repeat paid off
but he definitely took great risk and uh
well he was a second away from l losing
the game I can tell you that Queen
Bishop G7 Queen D6 it's surprising to me
how Sam is playing almost as if you know
like this is a part of his winning
strategy or something you know like he's
just playing these
moves uh a piece down Queen D5 check and
we can trade queens and that's it
it's we have even better than this queen
D5 might be a draw no draw yes
yes how we have Rook B8 and the pawn is
running right right you might be forced
to exchange da for the B Pawn and that's
going to be a draw most likely more more
challenging so Queen D5 not the best so
probably something like
Queen C4 yes yes just to uh be able to
check and allow for B3 B2 put the pawn
on B2 protected by the bishop life's
easy
my goodness what a what a game apologies
I just want to double check with the
ladies uh Queen C4 by the way best move
in the position played by Hans okay good
for Hans and the Nazi this game could go
on for quite a long while the queen
ending but I feel like it's going to be
a draw soon because they're moving back
and forth with the king and queen and I
think soon Anna is going to realize that
uh she just cannot go forward and
exactly it's going to be a draw okay I'm
just going to refresh my board with uh
with uh Sam and Hans for a moment and he
did play Queen C4 he did not play Queen
D5 which traded the Queens but kind of
gave white better chances of saveing
great decision great decision by this
one was a good decision the previous one
to play on I mean that was a risky
decision wow by Hans but it did pay off
and you know he mentioned this he said
look maybe I have to go back to my true
self just be in myself believe in myself
yeah take the decisions that I want to
take and by the way I mean remember that
Knight
G4 yes he almost played it that would
have been game over on the spot well I
mean two eventful moments in these US
championships between these two players
here may I provide you with a broken
King and this one may I allow you to
play Rook takes F5 check and win the
game uh by the way just tell me for a
moment here why why okay we understand
that Rook A5 is absolutely crucial
stopping Queen
D5 attempting to play Rook takes E5 as
well as Rook takes F5 but why didn't he
play
Rook I mean Rook E8 Rook G6 right well
then I play H5 and aren't I like at
least making life a little bit bit
unhappy you might yes you see what I
mean yeah so can I start with a check
Queen D5 check of course and I'll move
my oh excuse me not Rook G6 but you can
start with a check um again I'm just
trying I'm not trying to win I'm just
trying to make your life as as difficult
as possible but now I can go Rook G6 and
I have Queen
H1 after H5 ah you mean Rook G6 H5 Queen
H1 yeah and now that that's yes that's
perfectly sensible I guess you have to
take you have to go on the H file
right sorry I have to go
King where on the H H H3 H1 H2
H oh I simply don't have a move you have
to go to G1 yeah I simp okay there you
go thank you and how is this position
right now no well you go Rook G6 G6 H5
Queen D1 oh so much geometry nice in
this game yeah the king is in all of
this the King was as safe as completely
possible and uh just to update the game
uh Queen C4 Rook
E8 and H said you got nothing yep no
checks yep just one my king is going to
be perfectly safe on
H7 protected by my Bishop protect Ed by
my rook and even my F5 Pawn so there's
no checks on the diagonal as well B2 is
coming it's done and dusted E2 Queen E4
check I don't think there's much left to
be said about this I would like to trap
The Rook with
F3 un no time for that no time for that
Queen E2 always uh kills you in that
instance F3 Queen E2 I pick up the pawn
on F3 but I do like your thinking
trap The Rook be you know the the the
proper perspective grab that Rook grab
the material this one on B3 is just
running yes yeah what a game wow what a
game guys truly Queen D7 okay we were
there there was a game where we were
talking about the final Cheapo you know
you just you don't resign you go for one
final Cheapo what is the final what is
the final Cheapo so Queen D7 to see yeah
the final Cheapo you're x-raying the
pawn somehow yes but how do you do that
because B1 Queen
defends it's kind of sad exactly uh once
I promote the pawn and the problem is if
you do go Rook to B6 I can just still
promote and then go Queen E4 and then
just finish the game like that exactly
so you still don't have Queen takes F5
because the queen you don't have F3 okay
maybe this is not that easy no I think
you you you you give a check on C2 right
but now you go there's a mate at the end
let me show you what you might have
missed favorite
part that's a very nice mate actually
actually it is I
meanti by your own ponds you're tucked
in and tight that's it we might actually
see that I I have a feeling we're going
to see that mate you're right I don't
think Sami is going to allow it on the
board but I think we're going to see
that you play to that uh possibility so
what about Queen E8 here Queen E8 oh
you're just gonna grab that Rook right
Queen I can do that yeah yeah cuz if you
promote yes Queen H5 mhm then I have
Queen H5
yes and I would have to move my king and
nothing that Bishop is a palace guard
extraordinaire it's a it's amazing it's
amazing uh oh but wait so I give check
again on E8 no Queen oh I'm sorry okay
B2 uh Bishop have I want to see Rook B6
I want to see Rook B6 and that variation
is really nice now here take Queen
takes yep Rook B6 okay all right uh oh
are they going to go for our VAR I think
they might all right so let's see what's
happening there okay I'm just going to
refresh my board everybody apologies hey
took his Queen okay maybe we can see
hans's uh body language as well cuz I'm
curious he's been suffering Queen right
he's been suffering a lot he's been
tortured throughout this game but
finally he can enjoy himself right now
precisely so we are expecting this nice
little finish that goes Pawn promotes
equal Queen you don't you can't capture
F5 that's defended so you capture B1 on
check now if you move your king I'm just
going to take the Rook
so F3 checked the king very important
very important driving the King right
into the checkmating arms of the black's
queen that is a a lovely little
pattern I think he sees it
guys but he's not in a hurry Queen E4
first okay Queen E4 first that's going
to be transposition right after F3 we
give first check on C2 and then we
promote to a queen
exactly for check has the chess spoken
for itself I don't know we'll ask
him I guess we'll have to ask you maybe
you should ask no
no last time he said you could be a
lowly commentator if you can't play
anymore after mention podcasting is like
the lowest form of Chess that was last
year ancient history yes ancient hisory
Queen C2 King H3 see I do see a queen C2
intereso oh he sees it we're going
straight for that line very nice and
there you have it there's B1
okay Rook takes
B1 I feel like we going to see the check
you have to take on G4 yes Sam is not
going to resign right you have to take g
wow wow that's very sportive of Sam to
allow that Checkmate and there it
is wow tip your hat Bravo yes Bravo yeah
what a game yeah well there goes our
Bobby
fish prize I'm sorry to say at least as
far as the open is concerned so Nazi is
the only last person who can win
potentially potentially Bobby Fisher
prize but it doesn't look like it's
going to happen not happening
ending uh but I do suspect that that
game will be ongoing for some time uh as
well uh lots of ups and downs in this
game my goodness uh Christian uh we just
uh what the game we just saw once again
Hans uh the first two rounds he's kind
of dominated our show oh yes absolutely
no and how close he was to flagging but
also making a one last look look at this
everybody if you're joining as late
shame on you uh with 7 Seconds To Go a
very clear Knight G4 and then the sudden
realization there is Rook takes F5 let
me reconsider my move yeah no no no of
course I'm right Knight G4 no I'm wrong
Knight G6 and press the clock with one
second check it out one second on the
clock and that would have lost on the
spot yeset different result exactly he's
still losing even after Knight to G6
right but he managed to turn it around
wow what a game yeah what a game and
what a start for hun in this
championships that's a nerve-wracking
start I mean that saps your energy you
know when you go through one game like
that you're feeling exhausted when you
go through backto back games like that I
mean when's my luck going to run out is
the question right have you ever had
that those feelings of uh paranoia and
thinking about this so you so what we
just saw your opponent you are down to
three seconds which you're going to make
and everything and suddenly your
opponent goes C you makes the biggest
sneeze right in the middle and you're
you're taking a back by one second and
then you're oh sorry about that oh
you're down on time I
don't how would you feel for me if your
your flag fell after a big
sneeze I don't
know I mean come on that those thoughts
never crossed your mind it turns into
chess boxing at that point at that
point the gloves come off you have to at
that point you have to
Kate nobody ever done that I remember a
lot of games when I played I was
thinking thinking then I I'm just like
making move and looking the clock that
it's going to one second and then I just
smash the clock very quickly wow and I
remember once it was at a tournament uh
Team event and I was thinking about a
sacrifice okay so I make it and I see
that you know I have one last second so
I hit the clock quickly and after the
after the game Malik Katan our captain
he was like you are making the last 4th
move it has to be a sacrifice with one
second can you just make a simple move
and decide later he was going to get a
heart attack from that oh and you saved
or won the game with it was a it was a
draw yeah but you know what I'm saying
that your opponent does a hand movement
or something that stops you and then
I've never encountered it I feel like no
unfair sportsmanlike conduct in any of
your tournament practice no this way no
and uh for you uh also uh same no never
happened to me um the worst thing it
happened it was I was having this worst
event of my life basically I was scoring
poorly and finally I had a great
position but I missed a very basic
tactic I lose a piece in one move and
then I'm in a completely losing position
got but there's only one last trick and
then my opponent is thinking I see the
trick and then he fakes the move that
would have allowed that trick the trick
and then he immediately Retreats and
plays a different move and presses the
clock and your heart ski the be are you
kidding me yeah right just rubbing it in
that was the only time I didn't shake
hands after in the game I was like if
you ever do this
again oh goodness yeser do you have some
trauma that someone behaved this way no
no trauma I'm trying to think of an
unsportsmanlike conduct and I remember
was a young boy I was playing in my
first US Open and my opponent was this
very elderly gentleman very very kind
looking man a Santa Claus looking man if
you will and beautiful smile I mean his
teeth were pearly whites and those
pearly whites turned into a Grimace and
we both got into time trouble and he had
a glass of water next to the game and he
took his teeth out of his mouth pointed
a glass of water and left the glass of
water right there at the board but I was
like trying I mean these teeth that had
been smiling at me for the whole game
were suddenly next to the board old
habits die
hard that was a little off
I me I'm just saying you know I mean
imagine that happening in time trouble
with you got like 3 seconds on your
clock and the teeth are hanging up on
the edge of the board I'm telling you I
mean we old guys we got the
tricks your time is coming your time is
coming you better not do that you know
what leavon said to me at the opening
ceremony he says yes you really got to
come back to yes said why I don't have
that competit of zeal that you have he
says no you're hoarding your rating
points we need your
rating I said well thank you very much
he got a point agree
with there a lot of points I'm holding
on to there but wow uh well uh what a
finish and uh we've got one game left as
we're hoping to get Hans in studio and
uh well this could be a while on the
other hand it does look really e even is
well she did go through that land mine
with King C5 Queen f8 and if you go to
D4 you lose yeah she she Anna avoided
avoided
stepping stepping on the landmine you
just mentioned there so King A7 um yeah
just one of the things you absolutely
absolutely have to avoid with white is
if you just took the Queens off it's a
very simple B4 C3 like for example Queen
D6 would just be a horrible move you'd
lose it on the spot uh by the what do
they call these these breakthroughs yeah
Pawn breakthroughs that's right exactly
just add a
temporary Pawn breakthrough so don't and
let me just refresh my board as the
players are making some moves
here King to B7 Queen to f8 in time
trouble no no no two minutes two and a
half almost three minutes for Anna but
the position is easy right um you're
just looking for perpetuals and uh
anything that keeps the black
king away from D3 right unless you
choose to completely change the
character of the position with some C3
ideas but that's not going to happen
yeah the only thing I can imagine is you
put your queen on C7 you play C3 and in
some Universe you give up
F7 and uh you hope that with your queen
on C3 the queen on F7 that's not
happening with cck that you get to play
B4 as well but I can probably almost
always avoid it by just bringing back
the queen to B4 I totally agree of
course and I think Anna's been dancing
around this position for like 20 moves
already so she realized there is not
much she can do so she may be just going
here for repetition right yeah this
reminds me of a my longest game in my
chess competition it was the game that
couldn't devour China
this was a hilarious game it had like I
am not joking something like five adjs
wow like 240 moves and it was a queen
ending where I had Queen in five versus
queen in four the next adj German had
Queen in war versus que so how many days
did it take about five days and it was
at an Olympiad and during the game my
team captain eloped with the Soviet star
on board one Elena Ash mkaya ran off
with John Donaldson our team captain and
hey man you the team captain just ran
away with the Soviet
winner it was crazy but Hans is with us
and
Christian Hans uh welcome back to the
show uh you gave us a heart attack you
probably gave yourself a heart attack I
will ask you once again did the chess Pi
for itself
today yes yes it did yes it did
yesterday didn't but to they did finally
congratulations now take us did
yesterday but not in the way that I
imagined of course now every day the
chess is speaking there was a will to
win today that I have to say impressed
me because you had the opportunity to
repeat the position not once but twice
and yet you decided to keep the game
going tell us a bit about that reaction
in that decision in that particular
moment which which two times the first
the first one which is on the board now
yes withing this was the first one
Knight H5 Knight F4 King H6 potentially
King to G7 you decide to go F5 I'm I'm
not risking anything here I have better
piece Play Active uh I'm not risking
there's no point uh the second point
when I didn't that was much more tricky
yes I think it was at this point when
you decided to go Queen B6 Queen B8 and
finally to go King to H7 and allow
Knight to F4 and as soon as I played it
I was uh
very upset um but you know if you want
to win against such strong players you
have to uh risk you have to you have to
bite the bullet absolutely and you did
Knight to F4 by the way was a great move
by him and after that things are getting
A5 wait wait start go back wait wait 95
Queen Rook what what should can I check
what's so Rook Rook C5 book keep play
Rook oh Knight G4 Knight G4 is the best
move in the yeah because I just because
you know when I was thinking about
position after night night G4 I was just
getting Flash back through yesterday
yesterday like night4 night G5 I was
getting like some PTSD I was like I just
because I I I knew that I felt Play N
four I just make a draw I don't lose but
I was just like I got to I got to go I
got to go I got to go and the time is
ticking down and like getting these
flashbacks and it's just so
painful and then uh speaking of
flashbacks I it was move 39 after the
move Knight to F4 and at this point you
had 5 seconds on the clock you grabbed
the Knight you put it on G4 four three
take a look at this because we actually
have the footage remember trust me I
remember take a look at this take us
through this decision
making so I I'm thinking n G4 and then
in a split second I see Rook F5 boom and
then I'm like oh no oh no what do I do
where where can the night go I'm and as
and then I then and then I see but you
went back to G4 close you went back to
G4
yes oh
I and one second H I didn't realize I
didn't realize I did the triple you know
twist you know that's uh that's a triple
twist
yes okay guess there's a first for every
triple twist in your
[Laughter]
life amazing and you press your clocks
uh Hans with a a second
were you aware that that was done with
one second on your clock I was aware
right after I looked at the clock and
disbelief yet gratitude for Kaa looking
down on me gratitude that you're
surviving but at the same time you're
still losing in that position after
Knight to G6 how did you assess it did
you know that you're losing did you feel
that you're losing or you were still har
it's I'm down upon uh uh the the night
has has great potential um but of course
I harbard hope the B2 Pawn is very weak
um there's potential sacrifices
attacking on the king so uh you know he
got into time pressure and he collapsed
at the end mhh beautiful uh execution
Hans I have to say uh guys any questions
for Hans after this crazy game I'm
recovering I don't know about you Hans
but you you you you've traumatized our
crew here and how do you feel I mean you
were that close to well defeat and now
you're tied for first quite
extraordinary honestly this this was
nothing compared to yesterday I was you
know cool chill my usual arrogant
Optimist self you know um uh I think
yesterday got the juices flowing uh This
was um this I just felt like I would
play Super I'm just playing very very
well um I think in both of these games
just there's just one moment where I'm
just uh going absolutely insane um so I
just have to be more more consistent and
and um but I think my general level is
quite good the opening and how I played
I think was very successful in this game
um and uh it's definitely very important
to beat the leader with the black pieces
absolutely and Hance what was your
assessment after you played Queen D1 and
captured the Knight on B3 did you think
you're winning there or did you see any
variation that could yeah well on my on
my walk here um someone spoiled that
Rook A5 was was actually holding um but
uh I did think that I was winning I did
see Rook A5 but I did not realize that
uh it was uh pinned
um as soon as I at first when I saw like
Queen B7 I'm first thinking okay like
Bishop G3 Rook takes G3 like sacrifices
to force the draw and then I'm I have
this AR like wait I can take the knife
like I can win this game because you you
know you would never assume that the
king is so safe but after King
H6 and him having no time in the clock
it seems very difficult but apparent
there was a draw to Rook A5 according to
one of your the person who brought me
over here right and A5 actually was a
key Square in the game because there was
another line that Christian Christian
showed us here where it was actually
losing for you but a crazy move for for
Sam right do you remember Chris I'm
trying to remember so Rook A5 was
winning no no no Rook a rook A5 is a
draw but sooner The Rook C8 and A5 oh so
this was yes yes yes I know what you're
talking about at that point Rook to D1
one it was a good decision but only in
my estimation if you see this move Rook
to C8 did you spot this idea with Rook
to C of course I saw Rook C8 Rook takes
G3 now King F1 and next move is A5
trapping more or less trapping the
queen yeah this I saw um I had some some
I thought Rook takes B3 was holding but
I guess not Rook takes B3 Queen takes S
and H H5 I didn't see H5 this was the
move yeah I missed I missed H5 and it's
an easy move to miss and the problem is
if you do go E5 I can just simply take
your Rook that's the problem oh wow yeah
that's yeah that's even more ridiculous
well yeah yeah and even if you put the
Rook
on I will still take it Queen takes F5
oh wow yeah that's yeah that's that's
quite something and the problem is you
do take my Rook at the end but you also
get checkmated no oh yeah that's oh
that's painful
H congratulations uh big victory for you
go recover after this crazy game and
we'll see you
tomorrow thank you thank you Hans and
congratulations on an amazing game right
right very enjoyable wow uh two
incredible rounds uh for the record book
we do have one game still remaining and
that is our tournament leader uh in a
queen ending and Nasi versus Anna uh we
suspect that this game will be a draw
and may be here for a long time to come
but having said all of that we just I'd
love to take a look at the results uh
Graphics if we've we will get them uh
ready for ourselves as Queen AA check on
the
board and we going to see again King
B6 is and here it is as we have two
tournament leaders right very important
win with for hands and he is the leader
with abanu ra then we have a lot of
players Fabiano Wesley Lenard Jeffrey
Sam darush another Sam and leevon with
one point and uh Ray Robson and Andrew
tang with half a point well let's
reflect on the tournament leaders uh
chess is a Young Person's game okay as
Mishra at 14 and then this finally I
think we're going to make a claim of a
three-time repetition that's it and the
two ladies uh split the haling of the
points shall we and no one has a chance
for the Fisher Price anymore it's gone
after two rounds uh but uh the
tournament leader Sam Sean goes down to
defeat and he might have won this game
he had winning moments and it was so
close one
second so different could all have been
so very very
different uhoh we've got uh a reflection
on hey hey good we forced you to do it
christian we forced you we
took you had this you foresaw this all
the way okay I'm feeling good about my
it's been a wild ride but
wild I like it oh man what a what a
round right seriously what a beginning
of this competition yesterday not a lot
of decisive results nowadays uh today in
fact we had three decisive results in
the ladies section two of them in the
open section I have to say things are
getting Hitt it up and I'm impressed by
the fighting Spirit once again of these
players nobody is giving up everybody
wants to keep the game going even at the
expense of potentially allowing a worse
position as we've seen from Hans is just
Fighting Chess here at the US chess
championships and I cannot wait to call
all the action tomorrow in round three
and let's try it one more time yes let's
see you doing what are you doing nicely
done see you guys tomorrow Christian
very nicely I'm stunned by mishra's
extraordinary preparation and the fact
that he knew all of those positions up
the bishop A4 incredible Kate it's been
so much fun calling all the action we'll
do it all tomorrow pleasure it was very
nice and really a lot of fighting games
and I think we have a more fighting
games to look ahead absolutely thank you
everyone for sharing your day with us
tell all your friends and family where
you're heading hanging out we want to
make this the best chess show possible
thank you for your
[Music]
support
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is
prohibited